tv
worth of los angeles times festival of
books held every year on the campus of
ucla the book tv bus has made this one
of its stops as it goes nationwide
inside the bus today we have nick schau
he is the author of this book kill the
messenger how the cia's crack cocaine
controversy destroyed journalist gary
webb when did you meet gary webb i
actually only met gary once uh when he
was
doing a book tour in 1998 at a bookstore
in santa monica
but i had actually
gotten to know him sort of over the
phone as a reporter because a member of
the drug ring that he wrote about was an
ex-orange county cop and i cover law
enforcement in orange county so
i actually wrote several follow-ups uh
about his uh investigative work before i
ever met him what is what was the crux
of the investigative work that got so
much attention well gary you know wasn't
the first reporter that had actually
probed this whole issue of uh drugs that
were coming into the united states in
the 1980s
a lot of stories have been written about
that at the time and even john kerry
when he was a senator had uh had held
hearings uh trying to get to the bottom
of that issue but the media basically
kind of ignored the story and in some
cases even ridiculed kerry and gary
found out 10 years later where a lot of
these drugs that were alleged to have
come in during this iran contra era had
ended up and connected them to the
biggest crack dealer in l.a history
freeway ricky ross and because ross was
already kind of a celebrity drug figure
who the la times had labeled the kingpin
of crack cocaine
his series received a lot of attention
especially in the black community and
it was a for a while at least a huge
sensation he was on the
television and radio every day
but a couple of months after his story
came out the major newspapers which
pretty much ignored that story up until
it reached a real fever kind of pitch
began printing stories attacking his
work and claiming that there was no
evidence that the cia
had any involvement with this drug ring
or it had anything to do with uh
bringing drugs into the country you
right that his editors betrayed him how
well
gary was a very aggressive reporter
according to the people that worked with
them throughout his career and
they felt that
gary worked best as all good
investigative reporters do when they
have a relationship with their editor
where they uh
have someone that can actually be as
passionate about the story as them but
also kind of like uh restrain uh the
reporter to the certain extent that'll
protect the story from going further
than the facts now gary's reporting as i
found actually was accurate in fact
after he had already been attacked and
discredited the cia acknowledged that it
had covered up its relationship with
drug traffickers during the 1980s and
only admitted this after gary had
already lost his job but the story uh
you know had some very inflammatory
language in the in the lead paragraph
and ran on the internet the first major
news story of to run simultaneously
online with the logo showing someone
smoking cracks superimposed over the
seal the cia so a lot of my book kind of
focuses on this story kind of got out of
gary's hands a little bit and how
because he had editors that
were only sort of too eager to hype the
the facts that he had uh
created such a firestorm of outrage that
ultimately made it easier for the papers
to criticize his work by cr by actually
debunking the false notion that the cia
deliberately started the crack cocaine
epidemic which gary webb never believed
but which i guess to a certain extent
the story had implied through its uh
kind of inflammatory lead sense
what um
what was going on in his life at that
time
well gary had risen to the top of his
field when he published dark alliance
he's been a reporter for 20 years
and he clearly had every reason to think
that this was the story that was going
to really kind of make him one of the
most famous and successful investigative
reporters and for a while that's what he
was he was writing for the san jose
mercury news
and uh
after the criticism started coming in at
first his paper defended him but then
they basically backed off the story and
printed a half retraction half kind of
maya culpa acknowledging that they
shouldn't have implied that the cia knew
about this activity when they couldn't
really prove it and gary predicted
accurately that this was going to be
viewed as a complete retraction which it
wasn't actually and uh and he protested
this and became very vocal in
criticizing his editors for for actually
printing this retraction and at that
point he was essentially forced out of
the paper and left journalism shortly
thereafter and his life basically became
kind of downhill after that
when did you first start uh writing
about him or looking at him well i read
the story when it came out and i was
amazed that
in 1986 after four years of dealing
drugs this drug ring had basically been
the focus of a big multi-agency law
enforcement rate in l.a and one most of
the places that were rated were in south
central or east l.a where most of the
drugs were found but one of the places
that was raided was a mansion in mission
viejo where a former orange county cop
told the police officers that he worked
for the cia and it turned out that this
comp was a money launderer for the drug
ring he was providing weapons to gang
members that were involved in the drug
ring as well as police scanners that
enabled them to know when the police
were zeroing in on their uh drug stashes
so i spent several years actually
investigating that one cop filing
freedom of information act request and
getting records from the fbi and cia
most of which were censored but which
revealed that in fact he did have a
business relationship with the former
chief of covert operations for the cia
so it's my conclusion that in fact if
the the rest of the papers that had
spent so much energy sort of attacking
the story and attacking the conspiracy
theories that were sort of floating
around it if they'd actually put any
resources into really tracking down uh
the evidence that gary had not quite
been able to achieve with his reporting
who knows uh what ultimately would have
been proven correct who are you writing
for i was writing for oc weekly which is
an independent that's where i still work
it's an alternative weekly in orange
county california it's a sister paper to
the village voice and la weekly ellie
weekly also ran my stories as did the
san francisco bay guardian
when did you decide to change the focus
and look at him and not the story well i
mean i kept in touch with gary until
shortly before he died in december 2004
and i was very saddened when i learned
and read in the newspaper that he
committed suicide and the obituary that
ran in the la times was very i felt
dismissive and uh the la times had never
even covered the the cia report that
admitted for the first time they had
worked with drug dealers and in fact
this obituary uh was
to me sort of insulting and i felt that
somebody
needed to really write an accurate
biography that really portrayed gary
webb and the tragedy of his life and
also tried to answer some of the
questions that have been kind of ignored
in the uh in the scandal you spent a lot
of time with his family
yeah i would not have probably been able
to have written this book or wanted to
have written this book without the
cooperation of this family because i
felt that
gary
as much as his story was kind of
misunderstood by people who sort of used
it uh for their own and
you know gary was also very
misunderstood and
i i didn't in fact know him that well i
mostly knew him on a professional basis
but uh
after he had
left journalism and wrote his book he
was still being criticized as sort of a
conspiracy theorist by
people that were reviewing his book and
i found out that in fact this guy
had always gone after
corruption and abuses of power
regardless of a democrat or republican
affiliation he was kind of a equal
opportunity muckraking journalist and uh
many of the people that he worked with
now are at papers like the new york
times uh and uh
and and these people all remember gary's
actually like the model of what they
uh wish more reporters would be like a
really hard-hitting investigative
journalist that actually got results
actually exposed corruption and
uh you know i i think that this book is
kind of a cautionary tale for people
that are you know uh considering careers
in investigative reporting because it
provides an inside account of how this
story uh went so wrong but it's also
sort of uh begs the question of
whether
our country would be better off if we
had more reporters like gary webb who
you know weren't afraid to take on very
powerful institutions what did he do
wrong well gary you know
it's not so much what he did wrong is
what he did what wasn't there to assist
him in getting the story out and what
what he didn't have were reporters or
rather editors that were basically
he thrived
at the mercury news but also before that
at the kentucky post and the cleveland
plain dealer where he had very tough
editors that basically just sort of made
sure that the headlines especially the
headlines didn't go overboard he had
been sued a couple of times at the
cleveland plain dealer but the
settlements that the papers ultimately
signed were over misleading headlines
and ultimately what i found out with
dark alliance was
the facts were there it's just that the
headline and the sort of the lead
paragraphs the kind of things that were
rewritten over and over and over in the
process of getting this story out in
which gary ultimately doesn't entirely
uh have control over
that's what caused the sort of
misleading reaction meaning the editors
were changing the actual text
his story was rewritten so many times
and went from a four-part series to a
three-part series back to a four-part
back to a three-part where at the end of
the day he didn't even know what version
was going to go into the paper because
he was on vacation when it ultimately
came out and you know
he deserves all reporters uh you know
have to take ownership for anything that
appears under their name there's no
question about that but with he was the
only person that suffered any
consequences as a result of the story
and ultimately paid a very heavy price
but the editors that basically in one
case the managing editor that made sure
that nobody else at the paper really
knew about this project and wanted it to
be his sort of he thought that this was
going to be a pulitzer story and that he
would get glory out of it he stopped
reading the story halfway through
because he had applied for a corporate
job and was no longer really paying any
attention to the story at all so i
actually among other people i
interviewed uh leo wallinsky the
managing editor of the la times who was
responsible for their criticism of dark
alliance and he told me in retrospect
that gary got way too much of the blame
in this whole scandal that other other
editors that were promoted who didn't do
a good job editing that story deserve
at least as much criticism as gary got
and that gary did exactly what you
should expect from a great investigative
reporter he was trying to get the story
out and the la times ironically probably
would have printed this story themself
but they would as as leolinsky put it
might have done a better job editing it
what happened after he left the paper
and what led to the suicide well it's a
pretty complicated story when you're
examining a suicide of anybody i mean
there's a lot of different factors that
play into it but basically all the
people that i interviewed that knew gary
well felt that this story was pretty
much the central event in his life and
that after his after story exploded in
his face and he lost his career in
journalism that's when
he started experiencing major problems
with depression his depression lasted
for years he went through divorce
and ultimately
committed suicide
shortly after having to put his house on
the market and he was about to move in
with his mother he was 50 years old and
the only paper that would hire him was a
small alternative weekly paper he'd just
been recently laid off
by a state government agency in
sacramento and wanted to get back into
journalism and it's my feeling if he had
been a little
bit
less depressed and more hopeful he might
have been able to get a better job but
as it was the job that he had didn't pay
the bills and he just reached the end of
his rope
what did what do you hope people will
get from this book well i mean i i
i think it's interesting because the few
people that are familiar with gary webb
and with the dark alliance story don't
already have their mind made up about it
one way or the other they either feel
that it's complete nonsense and that
gary was a terrible reporter or they
feel that gary was a hero and that you
know he
was unfairly criticized and possibly
even assassinated by the cia
which you know was a major part of the
reason why i wanted to write this book
basically set the record straight about
this guy i found him to be a fascinating
uh reporter a fascinating human being
and his career spanning a few decades in
journalism he worked at some very
interesting papers with some very
interesting people and the totality of
his life i think is really a tribute to
the best
uh you know aspirations of investigative
reporting what was some what was the
most interesting response you've gotten
from it so far well
it's hard to say i'd
i
one person who i won't mention because
he hasn't publicly criticized the book
felt that i was far too sympathetic to
people that had criticized gary's
reporting when it counted and i made a
very deliberate effort to talk to
everybody that knew gary and had
anything to say about him including
people that worked with him at the
mercury news that thought that he was a
kind of a hot shot or a hot head
reporter more sympathetic towards him
but i also interviewed all the critics
that have published articles critical of
gary's work who would speak with me so
the book is as objective as i could make
it and it's as fair to everybody who is
willing to share their views on it as i
could possibly make it because i think
that
that only strengthens
the ultimate conclusion of the book what
where are the editors today well one of
them works for an environmental
organization in new york city left
journalism
jerry seppos who was the editor of the
paper at the time uh recently retired
and was living on a vineyard in northern
california and the editor that was
working hardest with him but who was
also supervising several other stories
and 50 reporters all together is uh
teaching at stanford university did any
of them talk to you for this book well
actually don garcia who's with the
knight fellowship at stanford did and
she was the only reporter that worked
with gary that actually acknowledged her
own mistakes and her own
feeling that she had wished that there
had been
[Applause]
a better process with the editing
but i talked to a lot of people at the
mercury news
but the other editors above her that i
feel were really ultimately responsible
for the problems with the story were the
only people actually that wouldn't talk
to me
nick scow is the author of this book
kill the messenger how the cia's crack
cocaine controversy destroyed journalist
gary webb thank you for your time thank
you
at nine live coverage of a discussion on
the changing political climate with
columnist william sapphire and
journalist chris matthews
[Music]
next a hearing on allegations of cia
involvement in cocaine trafficking
yesterday the senate intelligence
committee chaired by senator arlen
specter of pennsylvania heard testimony
from inspectors general from the cia and
the justice system
recently the san jose mercury news ran a
series of articles on the c i a and drug
trafficking
the hearing's two and a half hours
intelligence committee will proceed
the
subject of today's hearings involves the
allegations of cia
involvement in the united states drug
sales to finance the contras in the
nicaraguan war
this is the first day when
senator kerry and i could get together
after the
senate
recess
we are going to proceed today
in our oversight capacity on the
central intelligence agency
we are going to hear from witnesses
jack blum who was formerly counsel to
the
senate foreign relations subcommittee
and the inspector generals from the
department of uh
justice and also the cia
to outline the scope of the
investigation which will be undertaken
on
this important matter
during the course of the past several
weeks i've been engaging in a series of
town meetings around my state
pennsylvania
and uh i know to an extraordinarily high
level of distrust of the government and
so many many lines
we see the militia movement we see
what had happened
in a small township bradford
pennsylvania
interest in a 20 year old shooting of a
man named leonard peltier
and
yesterday we noted the
filing of an information in the
events relating to ruby ridge
we intend to
move through these oversight hearings
very much as the subcommittee of
judiciary did just a year ago this time
on the hearings of ruby ridge
we heard some 62 witnesses over 14 days
of hearings and
i came out with findings right down the
middle
and
found general satisfaction of what the
oversight committee did in that
situation and this is a
matter particularly suited for
uh oversight
i'm not saying how many hearings we're
going to have are precisely what we are
going to do because we're going to have
to see how the matter unfolds but it is
a matter of some considerable interest
and this
achieved quite a high level of
recognition around the country
i'm going to take a little longer than
usual today to
set the stage
with a summary of the matters as they
have appeared in the public media
beginning august 18th of this year the
san
jose mercury news ran a three-day series
purporting to trace the origins
of crack cocaine epidemic to a pair of
nicaraguan drug traffickers with
connections to the
u.s back contras
the series was entitled dark alliance
the story behind the
crack explo explosion
in
uh stating what the san jose mercury
found we do not accept them and we do
not endorse them but merely outline
these allegations to set the stage for
the
testimony which we are going to hear
today
the series focused on
the activities of two nicaraguans oscar
de nilo bland and reyes and juan norvin
meneses canterrero
and a los angeles drug dealer named
ricky ross
blandin had served as a minor official
in the government of former
nicaraguan dictator anastasio samosa
blandon fled nicaragua before the
sandinis came to power and ended up in
california
he entered a guilty plea in 1992 to
conspiracy to distribute cocaine and
serve 28 months
upon release he became a dea informant
and in march 1995
testified against rick ross
vanessa's is currently serving time in a
nicaraguan jail for a 1992 conviction on
cocaine trafficking
meneses comes from a prominent
nicaraguan family
long time supporters of the samosa
regime his older brother was a general
in samosa's national guard and chief of
the national police
meneses has a long history of
involvement in drug trafficking
as early as 1976 the dia identified him
as a
cocaine supplier in managua
he fled to the united states when the
samosa regime collapsed was indicted by
a grand jury
in the united states in 1989
ross also known as freeway rick is a
36 year old african-american from south
central los angeles
in the 1980s he became a major cocaine
dealer in los angeles
rising to such prominence that local
authorities formed a
freeway ric task force so-called in 1986
and according to the mercury news series
and what i'm reciting now
comes from that series and as i say we
don't accept it or endorse it but are
repeating it
in 1987 ross moved to cincinnati for a
cooling off period and in 1991 was
arrested convicted and sentenced to 10
years for establishing
a cocaine distribution ring in
cincinnati
that sentence was cut in half
after he agreed to testify against los
angeles nor
cottage agents accused of corruption
1995 he was arrested in a dea sting
involving blondin and was convicted in
march 96 of conspiracy to distribute
cocaine and as a waiting sentence
the mercury news series further alleges
that in 1981
blandin became involved with efforts to
help the nicaraguan congress through
largely
unsuccessful fundraising rallies and
parties
blandon met manesses who encouraged him
to sell cocaine
to raise money so says the mercury
series
manesses took blandin to honduras to
meet a contra military leaner colonel
enrique bermudez
blandon has testified that bermudez told
him that the quote-ins justify the means
close quote
and although bermudez never mentioned
drug trafficking
blandin began selling cocaine supplied
by manessas to raise money
for the contras
sometime between 1982 and 1983 according
to the mercury news series
blandin began supplying cocaine to ross
who marketed it in the predominantly
african-american neighborhoods in south
central los angeles
again according to the mercury news
series ross turned the
powdered cocaine into crack and became a
major dealer in los angeles
according to that series manessa
supplied blandin
who supplied rost with a seemingly
seemingly inexhaustible supply of high
grain cocaine close quote
the nicaraguans supposedly laundered
their profits through a bank in florida
back to the contra organization the fdn
run by adolfo calero
the series refers to this as the fdn's
drug operation
the series also makes what could be
characterized as veiled references to
possible cia
interference in the investigation and
prosecution of blandis and meneses
in discussing vanessa's long history of
drug trafficking
and the unsuccessful investigation
conducted against him the series says
quote
records and interviews revealed that a
number of these probes were stymied
not by the elusive vanessas but by
agencies of the u.s government
the article continues quote agents from
four organizations dea u.s customs
the los angeles county sheriff's
department on the california bureau
of narcotics enforcement have complained
that investigations were hampered
by the cia or unnamed national security
interest close quote
and we will
do whatever is possible to get to the
bottom of that allegation
since the series ran in late august
several members of congress have called
for an investigation and the director of
the office of
national drug control policy general
mccaffrey
has also called for a review of the
matter
director of central intelligence deutsch
deutsch testified before this committee
of
the
cia's intent to investigate
and he outlined that a preliminary
review found no signs of cia involvement
in any such activity
the
san jose mercury news series caused
considerable national concern
because of the question as to whether
the u.s government bears responsibility
for the crack cocaine epidemic
several major newspapers have
independently examined the allegations
of the mercury news and reached
different conclusions
the following is a very brief summary of
some of those
newspaper findings and as the case with
the
san jose mercury the committee does not
accept or endorse
any of those findings but we'll repeat
them to provide
to provide some balance as we begin this
hearing
the
other newspapers
noted that the link in establishing an
alleged connection between the rise of
crack cocaine
and the cia-supported contras is the
role of blandis and manesses
the
mercury
news series characterizes blanda and
meneses as contra leaders saying that
blanda was one of the founders of the
fdn in california
according to the other analysis the
mercury news offers little support for
this claim
beyond a photograph of manessas and the
fdn leader adolfo carrero
and blanda's assertion that he was
selling drugs
out of his sense of patriotism
the new york times says quote neither of
the two ever held an official position
in any
of the nicaraguan groups close quote
the los angeles times concluded that
meneses gave less than 50 thousand
dollars to the contra effort and
blanda's participation
was even more limited
other press reports have questioned the
linkage between blandon's dealings with
ross and lecontra effort
blandon's testimony indicates that by
the time he started selling to ross
he had stopped using vanessa's as his
principal supplier
and was dealing directly with the
colombians blanda also testified
that after his break with manesses in
1982 or 83
he was not sending money to the congress
but was in business for himself
it was only in late 1983 that he began
his association with ross
and according to these other new series
if blandon was buying from the
colombians
then selling to ross and pocketing the
prophets there is no connection
so say these other analysts
between the cia back contras and the
crack that
ross was peddling on the streets of los
angeles
all sources acknowledged that manesses
and blandin trafficked in cocaine
but most have questioned the
characterization that they fostered the
crack epidemic
the washington post reported that
blandin based on law enforcement
estimates in his own accounts
handled about five tons of cocaine over
his 10-year career
that is obviously a significant amount
but it is two-tenths of one percent of
the nationwide
cocaine trade
and raises a question as to whether the
mercury news
accurately characterized him as the
quote johnny appleseed of crack in
california close quote
according to the other analyses law
enforcement
and academic experts discount the
hypotheses
that any one individual or organization
was responsible for the growth of crack
the epidemic was driven so they say
by a combination of factors that began
appearing across the country nearly
simultaneously
these other news analyses concluded that
ross was a major
los angeles crack dealer but one of many
and blandon vanessa were mid-level
traffickers who sympathize
with the contras and probably donated a
smaller money to the cause in the early
1980s and the other news analysis say
the trio
was not directly connected to the
nicaraguan contrast or the cia
and the rise of crack cocaine would have
occurred regardless of their
participation
that i say is a very brief setting
as to
what has appeared in the public media
and this is obviously a matter of very
very substantial importance
the news stories directly implicate the
central intelligence agency
this committee has direct oversight
responsibilities for the central
intelligence agency
and we intend to see to it that all the
facts are laid before the american
public so that we can follow those facts
and draw whatever conclusions are
warranted and as i say today's hearing
is just the beginning
where we will hear from
a former investigation by senator
subcommittee
the
committee on foreign relations not the
intelligence committee and what
investigations are now planned by the
cia itself and the department
of justice and this committee itself
will be doing considerably further
i now yield to my distinguished
colleague the vice chairman senator
kennedy senator kerry thank you very
much mr chairman and first of all i
i
do support strongly your decision to
convene this hearing on these very
important allegations that have been
made
against the cia for its actions during
the reagan administration
until we had the data however which the
inspectors general before us today will
uncover
our hearing must be tentative and
inconclusive
but it can serve at least one very
important purpose
it can signal the seriousness and
determination of this committee to learn
the truth and to act upon it
this is a very inflammatory subject to
say the least
either the cia a u.s government agency
approved or condoned the introduction
and sale of crack cocaine to americans
in order to finance the nicaraguan
contras during the reagan administration
or the people who served in the cia at
the time many of whom were still serving
have been erroneously accused
we have a duty to get to the bottom of
these allegations and as we do so
i'm confident we'll be guided by the
evidence
and the evidence only
speaking of confidence i know mr hitz
the cia inspector general very well and
i know the statute which makes him
completely independent from from cia
management so i have confidence in his
ability to get to the facts and to
report them
now the audience uh we're gonna we're
gonna ask that uh
the proceedings be conducted in
accordance with our regular rules and
we'll hear the witnesses and we'll ask
some questions we've asked for no
response from the audience believes and
i'd say to the audience uh who shows uh
uh understandable uh cynicism about my
statement that mr hitz has been on many
occasions many occasions
under a great deal of pressure from the
cia as a consequence of his honest and
direct evaluation their performance
and on many occasions our former
directors have actually come before our
committee and asked that he be removed
because he's done such a thorough job of
evaluating
so i do not praise mr hitz and say that
i believe that his ig report will
provide and we will make to the extent
possible that information public so it
can be examined
i do not make a complimentary remark
about mr hitz
in order to cover for the cia i do it
because i believe the the ig's report
which is initiated as a consequence of
the cia's concern or for what is going
on i believe that report is going to be
enormously constructive and i look
forward to
the work product i do not know mr
bromwich
but i
had the same very high expectation
that we have had on mr hitz when he has
examined many of these things in the
past
i would say parenthetically as well
that one of the difficulties that we
have is that when we recruit
men and women who work whether it's for
the central intelligence agency or the
fbi whoever they're working for
we ask them to do many things and we ask
them to do above all
to to keep what they do in secret it's a
very difficult environment
these men and women have families these
men and women
love their country they're trying to the
best of their ability to do their job
i i believe
that they should be afforded
the same presumption of innocent until
proven guilty that every other american
is given
regardless of the truth
of the specific allegations from the
mercury news
i believe we must also step back and
step back
and ask how america was affected when
the reagan administration made the
policy decision that communism in
nicaragua and not drug trafficking was
america's top priority in latin america
this policy choice may have made it
easier for the cocaine cartels to build
their business in this country
and it may have placed cia personnel in
contact they otherwise would not have
had with drug traffickers
if the worlds of covert action and drug
trafficking bumped into each other
we need to know how cia people reacted
and whether those reactions would be any
different under today's rules
mr chairman emotion can be the enemy of
evidence
but the emotional reaction to these
allegations sends a powerful message
it is our duty as elected officials to
listen to the message
learn from it and act on what we learn
the message i am hearing is a deep
seated cynicism and hostility towards
government and its motives on the part
of many in the african-american
community
they contrast
they contrast the government's military
and scientific prowess with its failure
a long-running bipartisan failure mr
chairman to keep drugs from ruining
their families and their neighborhoods
and they conclude their government is at
best indifferent to them
from their perspective the war on drugs
is war against the people of our own
inner cities
not against those who mastermind and
profit from this trade
and you look at the great majority of
those in prison for drug offenses you
can hardly
argue with this point of view
if we were to bring something positive
out of these allegations mr chairman who
must hear this message and we must work
across party lines with the
administration and with state and local
government to put in place counter-drug
programs which everyone in the country
including those in the inner city can
see are effective and are for the
benefit of all americans
the democratic government can't last
very long if many of its own people
view it as an enemy
thank you much very much senator kerry
[Applause]
uh i would uh underscore what you have
said in one respect
uh about uh the cynicism
uh and it is not only the
african-american community which is
cynical about what goes on in the
government
and i would refer again to the hearings
at ruby ridge where
there was great cynicism as to what the
fbi did and the alcohol tobacco and
firearms unit
and a subcommittee in this very room
just a year ago at this time
as i had said earlier conducted 14
hearings and heard 62 witnesses and
produced
150 five page report
and while it's taken the justice
department some time and i suggest too
long
they did file a criminal charge
yesterday against a very high-ranking
fbi official
and the responsibility really is lodged
on oversight with the congress we have
that responsibility we'll hear today
from
executive officials but the buck comes
to the congress of the united states and
this committee will discharge its
responsibilities fairly and fully
uh we'd like now to have um
mr um
hits and mr bromwich
a step forward
uh and i would deal now to senator rob
who has joined us
mr chairman i thank you i have no
opening statement the
allegations are serious and deserve a
thorough
uh inquiry and evaluation i look forward
to hearing the
testimony of our opening witness
and subsequently to the
investigations that the inspectors
general will conduct
and i will suspend any conclusions until
that time i thank you
we'd like to proceed now to hear all
three witnesses uh siri adam and then we
will have questions so
if we could have
as i say mr hitz and mr bromwich step
forward and
be seated at the witness table and we
turn to you uh first mr bloom
jack bloom is the former
special counsel to the senate foreign
relations subcommittee on terrorism
narcotics and international operations
and that subcommittee conducted an
extensive inquiry
and filed an extensive report back in
1989
and we're very interested in those
findings at that time and we
uh now turn to you
mr chairman i very much appreciate the
invitation to appear here this morning
i find it ironic in a way that i'm here
in the same room where we began hearings
on the same subject
in 1988 in january of 1988 we began the
investigation in 1987.
the questions you put this morning are
questions which
are extraordinarily important
the question of reform of the
intelligence community really requires
that these issues be debated publicly
and discussed publicly and i would hope
that the inquiry goes beyond the narrow
questions posed in the san jose mercury
news story
the answer you get to the questions you
ask depends totally on how you frame a
question
if you ask the question
did the cia
sell drugs in the black neighborhoods of
los angeles
to finance the country war the answer
will be a categorical no
the fact of the matter is we found no
evidence whatsoever
to suggest that there was a targeting of
the african-american community
cocaine in the mid-80s and into the
early 90s was a perfect equal
opportunity destroyer
we had addiction and problems in school
yards across america it didn't matter
what color you were where you were from
what your national origin was the
problem became more acute in the
african-american community because the
definition of a problematic in america
is an addict who runs out of money
and if you run out of money quickly you
become involved in the drug trade you
become a visible social problem and you
get on the screen
in fact the stock brokers the
entertainers the lawyers who use cocaine
around america escaped that attention
but their lives were ruined too perhaps
not financially
the second issue is uh did the cia do
the selling of the cocaine and did the
contrast profit
and as far as we were able to determine
no uh member of the staff of the cia
that is someone on the payroll as
opposed to people they worked with
was in the cocaine business
and certainly no one on the staff of the
cia as far as we could determine
was actively selling the drug
and then finally the question of was it
used to support the contras i will tell
you of two meetings that i had with
contra veterans one in 1986 and one in
1989
at the beginning and the end of my
investigation
and they said our problem was we never
had any money
our leadership stole most of it they had
houses in miami they had
opportunities to gamble they had
girlfriends they traveled and we who
were in the field and one of the groups
that i talked to had men who lost their
arms and their eyes and their legs
fighting the sandinistas we in the field
had none of the benefit
so i submit what went on led to the
profit of people in the contra movement
not to supporting a war that we were
trying to advance
now having said that
we have to go back to what is true
and what is true is
the policy makers absolutely closed
their eyes to the criminal behavior
of our allies and supporters in that war
the policy makers ignored their drug
dealing their stealing and their human
rights violations
the policy makers
and i stress policymakers allowed them
to compensate themselves for helping us
in that war by remaining silent in the
face of their impropriety and by quietly
undercutting
law enforcement and human rights
agencies that might have caused them
difficulty
we
knew about the connection
between the west coast cocaine trade and
the contras
there was an astonishing case called the
frogman case
in that case
i believe it was in that case the united
states attorney for san francisco a man
by the name of rusanello
returned 35 000 of cocaine proceeds
voluntarily to the contras
when it had been seized as the proceeds
of drug trafficking
we found that absolutely astonishing i
know of no other situation
where the justice department was so
forthcoming in returning seized property
was that the justice department or the
district attorney of san francisco this
was the justice department united states
attorney that's correct
we had a telephone conversation with mr
russinello
asking him to provide us documents and
access
to the people involved in the case and
he shouted at us he shouted at senator
john kerry who chaired the committee uh
he accused us of being subversive for
wanting to go into it
it should be stressed that the blondon
minases ring was part of a very much
larger picture
and to give you an idea of how large
that picture was there was a point where
the wholesale price of cocaine on the
street in los angeles reached twenty
five hundred dollars a kilo
we were talking about cocaine that was
available in such quantity they could
not find buyers twenty five hundred
dollars a kilo according to all the
experts is below cost
and that that is a flood of cocaine
and our friend freeway ricky was
touching only a tiny fraction of what
was coming in
we had a definite cocaine epidemic
now you might ask why did the hearings
we run in 1989 and the report we
released in uh the hearings we ran in 88
the report we released in 1989 not get
more attention
and the answer is we were subject to a
systematic campaign to discredit
everything we did
every night after there was a public
hearing justice department people
administration people would get on the
phone and call the press and say the
witnesses were all liars they were
talking to us to get a better deal
that we were on a political vendetta
that none of it was to be believed and
please don't cover it
the consequence of that was the hearing
and the report were given very modest
play in the press
i think the report and the hearing as
you go into this matter
and look at some of the transcripts and
i do hope you'll get the
actual records and closed session and
deposition hearings from the archives
where they all are and i hope all of
that is made public you'll find we did a
rather thorough job
it was a systematic effort to discredit
us that prevented the conclusions from
receiving the attention i believe they
warranted
now
i would argue that over a period a long
period of years covert operations were
undertaken
and it's not only the cia obviously the
decision in that area is of a political
level and the cia would be an
implementing agency
were taken on an ideological basis
that verged on religious belief and with
an eye to short-term results
and not long-term consequences
never again should that kind of
ideological blindness
and short-term vision
uh infect intelligence assessments
in the 1980s all of us could count the
number of people dead on the streets of
america as a result of the drug problem
you couldn't find me a single person in
america who had died as a result of an
attack by a sandinista inside our
borders
there should have been some ability to
notice
that distinction and understand the
importance of the drug problem and
understand that that had to be addressed
and at the very least that anything you
did
to
solve any other foreign policy problem
not make the drug problem worse
i think that among the other things you
should be looking at
is a review of the relationship in
general between covert operations
and criminal organizations
the two go together
like love and marriage
and it's a problem which really has to
be understood by this committee
criminal organizations are perfect
allies in a covert operation
if you sent me out of the country to
risk my life for the government to do
something as a spy in a foreign land
i would think criminals would be my best
ally
they stay out of reach of the law
they know who the corrupt government
officials are and they have them on the
payroll they'll do anything i want for
money it's a terrific working
partnership
the problem is
that they then get empowered by the fact
that they work with us
so now they have stature and influence
and an impact in their own country and
if they have influence with politicians
and people who come to power we now have
a new
powerful criminal enterprise
and we can't always control what they do
once we stand down
and unfortunately we have yet to figure
out how to prevent
criminal friends from becoming an
albatross
there's a second problem and that is
when you run covert operations you train
people in a lot of skills
unfortunately the story of adam and eve
stays with us
once you learn something once you've
bitten the apple of knowledge you can't
unlearn it ever
and when you teach people how to change
their identity
how to hide from the law how to build
bonds how to assassinate people they
don't forget how to do it and you wind
up after the covert action is over with
a disposal problem
we've never been very good at handling
disposal
we had that problem in the bay of pigs
babe pig's veterans have turned up in
everything from watergate to the lately
assassination there's a list that's so
long it it's painful to recount
now
the connection with a drug trade and i i
had to go into much of this in in
preparation for the hearing and we heard
it again and again from people we talked
to
uh goes way back
uh we were involved in assisting the
kuomintang armies against mao zeitung in
the 1950s
during that period
we
supported people who were in the heroin
trade in the mountains of burma
and those kuomintom
tong armies help themselves and finance
themselves out of the heroin business
it turned up again in the vietnam war
where our allies the
hmong tribesmen were in the heroin
business there were many accusations and
all kinds of stories about was the cia
dealing heroin and the answer was we're
not doing it probably true
it's our allies and we have to work with
whoever we have to work with
in afghanistan recently we've had allies
who went into the heroin business big
time it's the largest cash crop in
afghanistan it's the most important
export from the region it's coming out
by the time
and we also have a disposal problem we
have all kinds of people who've been
trained in bomb making and by god
they've been with us everywhere from the
world trade center to paris and all over
the world wherever there's somebody who
doesn't suit their ideological
tenor
now to turn specifically to the latin
american
story and where our investigation picks
up on the drug
trail we had testimony from a man who
was a civilian employee of argentine
military intelligence leandro
sanchez-reece
he told us that the united states had
occurred encouraged the argentine
military
to act as proxy for the united states
during the carter administration
because we had a public policy of
supporting human rights
and another policy of really trying to
sustain our anti-communist efforts
and the argentines
he said
sponsored the cocaine coup in bolivia
and then set up a money laundering
operation in fort lauderdale and we
later checked and indeed he had set up
that operation
and he used the money laundering
operation in fort lauderdale
to provide funds to the argentines all
over latin america
who were in the business of quote
fighting communism
we should remember that it was the
argentines who were the original
trainers of the contras
they were the ones who brought the
original contrast to honduras guatemala
and began to teach them how to do what
they had to do against the sandinista
government
sanchez rhys told us that he believed
that the reason the argentines were so
willing to go to war with the british
over the falklands was
that the argentine generals seriously
thought that the assistance they had
given us the covert assistance they had
given us
was going to
put them in our good races to the point
where we would side with them
a tragic mistake indeed if he was
correct
the second man who turned up on our
screen very big time was general noriega
and as you'll recall
press accounts have said it the
government has has made this public so
i'm not saying anything that's
classified noriega was on our payroll
the accounts
we heard
were that he was getting paid some two
hundred thousand dollars a year by the
united states government
at the time that was going on
virtually everybody who dealt with them
knew he was in the drug business it was
an open secret
in fact it was so open it appeared on
the front page of the new york times in
june of 1986.
i testified about it in the closed
session of the foreign relations
committee in 1986.
we have as the absolute low point of the
contra war
ali north having a meeting
with
with uh general noriega and he recorded
that meeting in great detail in his
notebooks
in which he's bargaining with noriega
noriega says to him i've got this
terrible public relations problem over
drugs
what can you do to help me here's what
i'll do to help you i'll assassinate the
entire sandinista leadership i'll blow
up buildings in managua
ali doesn't call the cops what all he
does is he goes back to poindexter
and poindexter says gee that's a little
bit extreme can't you get him to tone it
down go back and meet with him again
which all he does
when our committee asked the general
accounting office
to do a step-by-step analysis of just
who in our government
knew that general noriega was dealing
drugs and when they knew it and what
they did to act on that knowledge the
administration told every agency of the
government not to cooperate with gao
labelled it a national security matter
and swept it into the white house and
cloaked it in executive privilege
that investigation never went forward
should have gone forward
i was very much dismayed
our committee subpoenaed ollie north's
notebooks
and the history of those notebooks is
quite astonishing
not many people realize this but the
senate never got a clean copy of those
notebooks
north's lawyers were permitted to
expergate
sections of the notebooks based on quote
relevance
our committee subpoenaed those notebooks
and we engaged in a 10-month battle to
get them and ultimately the
investigation ended the subcommittee's
mandate ended we never got them
on top of the fact that clean copies why
wasn't it pursued at that time
the administration to begin with
classified the notebooks and these this
is truly bizarre because they remained
in ollie's possession at the code word
level
the expergated copies were kept in your
committee's office
under code word under code word uh uh
classification
when i read those diaries it wasn't
exactly my command no but i i say you're
you're in the sense of the intelligence
chairman at that time yes but and and
that was quite proper because those were
the rules the question the question that
i raised mr blum is there are ways
of dealing with claims of executive
privilege and they can be taken to the
courts
and the courts have
ruled that the privilege is not well
founded on some occasions and there are
remedies which the
senate can undertake to deal with the
administration when the administration
acts improperly well we started down the
track
the effort to get the subpoenas became
mired in the presidential campaign and
the political debate surrounding it
the committee there's always one of
those going on
the committee's mandate expired and
frankly i can't tell you why in the
ensuing congress it wasn't pursued there
was a later effort by the national
security archive under the freedom of
information act to get further
declassification and release of the
notebooks they succeeded to some degree
the notebooks in their entirety are
still not public and my belief is that
your committee
the intelligence committee should
undertake at the earliest opportunity
a complete
investigation of the notebook situation
and do your best to make it public to
restore some degree of confidence in the
process
now
the uh
the problem of general noriega and ali
north's notebooks and what was in them
is only one of a number of problems
related to this war and related to drug
trafficking that we stumbled into
we had problems in haiti
where friends of ours that is
intelligent sources
in the haitian military had turned their
facilities their ranches and their farms
over to drug traffickers
instead of putting pressure on that
rotten leadership of the haitian
military
we defended them we held our noses we
looked the other way
and they and their criminal friends
distributed through a variety of
networks cocaine in the united states in
miami in philadelphia new york and parts
of pennsylvania
honduras was another country that was
key for the contras
honduras was the base of contra
operations
most of the contra supplies came through
honduras
we wanted to do nothing to embarrass the
honduran military
ramon mata balosteros a member of the
gang that was involved in the camarena
murder
went to honduras and found refuge there
he was walking the streets
of tegucigalpa openly and publicly
the response of the united states
government was to close the dea office
in honduras and move the agent station
there to guatemala
we took testimony from that dea agent he
said it made no sense the drug
trafficking was going on in honduras and
the honduran military were at the center
of it
when the war ended almost the minute the
war ended
to our credit
the
administration arranged the midnight
extradition of mr mata balasteros who is
currently serving a life term in
american prisons the response of the
honduran military was to allow a mob to
burn down a portion of the u.s
facilities into goosagalpa
but we sat by as long as they were
helping us and allowed them to carry on
their illegal business
we also became aware of deep connections
between the law enforcement community
and the intelligence community
i personally repeatedly heard from
prosecutors and people in the law
enforcement world
that cia agents were
required to sit in on the debriefing of
various people who were being questioned
about the drug trade
they were required to be present when
witnesses were being prepped for certain
drug trials
various at various times the
intelligence community inserted itself
in that legal process
i believe that that
was an impropriety that that should not
have occurred well when you say when you
say
yes
when you say inserted itself into that
process are you suggesting that the
intelligence community thwarted or
stopped prosecutions which has gone
forward that too that too or could you
be
let me explain we're we're we're going
to have to have this hearing conducted
without interruptions from the audience
uh you are all here and you're all
invited to stay but if there are
interruptions we can clear the room
receive mr blum
there were
first
participations in the investigative
process a process and procedure for
clearing informants that were put on by
dea
a process of being there for deep
briefings of important witnesses
but then when there were criminal cases
that threatened to expose
various uh covert operations in the
region those criminal cases would be
then put aside
uh for one reason or another and there
was a procedure for doing that within
the department of justice we attempted
to probe that procedure the department
of justice rebuffed us rather
systematically we had some conversations
with one of the justice department
officials involved and took his
deposition but we were never able to yet
really satisfactory responses to the
questions we asked we do know that ollie
north directly intervened in a number of
cases to help
people who had helped the covert war
mr bloom when you come to that subject
during my earlier tenure on this
committee i saw that done much to my
dissatisfaction
there is a statute which sets forth
proceedings
where the
department of justice is authorized to
drop prosecutions where they cannot make
disclosures of confidential informants
and i personally have questioned the
wisdom of that kind of a procedure but
it is authorized by u.s law
and this committee was frequently
rebuffed by
claims of of that sort but let me ask
you a question relevant here did you
ever see any of that interference by u.s
intelligence cia or otherwise
of any prosecutions against cocaine in
los angeles
we did not focus on los angeles and los
angeles prosecutions i can tell you
there were cases in miami and there were
other cases in other parts of the
country well i think we refer to them
and if you dig into the
materials i can't remember them all
right you say there were not cases in in
los angeles
we didn't find them that doesn't mean
there weren't any well i understand that
but i'm asking whether you found them
but you say you did find such cases in
miami now right did those cases permit
cocaine dealers to continue to operate
one had the sense they did but we could
not get when we got into this area we
confronted an absolute stone wall
uh bill weld who was then the head of
the criminal division
uh put a very serious block on any
effort we made to get information
there were stalls there were refusals to
talk to us refusals to turn over data an
assistant u.s attorney who gave us some
information
was reprimand and then disciplined even
though it had nothing to do with the
case in a confidential way and he simply
told us about who is he i don't recall
his name but it's in our hearing
materials and we can furnish that for
the record
we had a series of situations where
justice department people were told that
if they told us anything about what was
going on they would be subject to very
severe discipline
and i got a lot of backdoor information
and then i was told i couldn't ever use
it because the careers of the people
involved
would be seriously compromised
now we had another problem wait a minute
when you were told that uh
did you make any efforts to use that
information yes what did you do
we uh went back to the justice
department we uh talked to them we said
we really want to talk to these people
and they simply stonewalled us now
you're saying that you received
information on a voluntary basis
but under
an agreement not to use it because it
would affect the careers of those
individuals right and you honored uh we
honored the we honored the
confidentiality it's the only way i'm
sure you understand that that you can
ever get anyone to talk to you but then
we went back and tried to get the
information on the cases and as soon as
we did the answer was sorry we can't do
that and there were a thousand excuses
we ran into another procedure which was
extremely troubling
there was a system for uh stopping
customs inspections of inbound and
outbound aircraft
from miami and from other airports in
florida
people would call the customs office and
say stand down flights are going out
flights are coming in
we tried to find out more about that and
were privately told again by customs
people who said please don't say
anything but the whole thing was
terribly informal and there was no real
way of determining the legitimacy of the
request to stand down or the legitimacy
of what was on the plane and going out
to people in the field
that i found to be terribly troubling
and it's a matter that you all should be
looking at very
carefully uh
there was a flip side to this drug
problem as well
one of the favored techniques of various
people in
in this operation was whenever there was
someone they didn't like they would
label him a drug trafficker
so we ran into the case of ron martin
who had set up an arms warehouse in
tagusagalpa honduras and he did it at
the request of various
friends of his in the u.s government and
it was sort of a pre-positioning of
weapons to help the contras and the idea
was that when the ban on direct aid was
lifted his stuff could be sold
ron martin was a potential competitor of
the secord north supply network
north started telling everyone that the
martin warehouse was financed by cocaine
not to deal with it and the impact was
to destroy ron martin financially
so this became a matter of uh
affirmative and negative use
i would say that based on my experience
with this affair and my look at the long
history of our
covert operations dealing with
criminals and drug dealers
that this entire affair needs a thorough
review a historical review as well as
the narrow review of the issues posed by
the article in the san jose mercury
the problem as i say it is if you go to
bed with dogs you get up with fleas
if you empower criminals
because empowering them happens to be
helpful at the time the criminals are
sure to turn on you next
and the people who plan covert
operations
should know that
and should be held accountable for not
telling their bosses if in fact they're
dealing with this kind of guy
and they do come back and and bite them
the most important loss that we had as a
result of the covert war in central
america was the loss of public trust in
the honesty and integrity of the people
who run america's clandestine operations
the measure of that
is how ready everyone is to believe
freeway ricky
and his fable about being the arm of the
c.i.a and selling crack in los angeles
ricky deserves life in prison for what
he did to his people in his community
the cia didn't make him do it and the
profits from his deal certainly didn't
go to help the contras but that does not
mean that there is not a need for a very
powerfully done investigation and a
backward look at the entire 40-year
history of this problem
thank you mr chairman
[Music]
we will proceed with 10 minute rounds as
to your testimony mr blum because it
will differ substantially in nature from
mr hitz and mr brownwich
let me begin with the overall question
as to whether you believe that the
united states has now placed proper
emphasis on
countering our college counter narcotics
as a foreign policy goal
uh yes i do i think the priorities have
changed very substantially
and i'm very pleased to report that uh
we have correctly now assessed narcotics
and international organized crime as a
significant threat do you think the
interdiction of the international flow
of narcotics has been successful that we
stopped
drugs from coming in from latin america
we have terrible problems in mexico we
have terrible problems in uh
still in latin america and we have
problems uh coming at us in terms of
heroin from asia and from latin america
as well should the united states be
doing more to stop the flow of drugs
into the united states i think so yes
uh mr bloom let me go back to the
specifics of the
mercury news series because we are we
are focused on that here
and you have raised quite a number of
other issues and they're all very
important but
did the principal participants in the
current allegations uh that is blandin
and manesses
a figure in any of the investigation
which your subcommittee did yes as i
said we knew about menaces i believe
one of senator kerry's staff did
interview meneses at one point
we were aware of that cocaine ring and
as i said
when we tried to get information through
government channels
we were blocked was there any
information that you did get that link
to either blandon or manesses to the cia
not not directly no
well indirectly
indirectly
we would say i would have to say yes and
i i hear here i'm relying on an
eight-year an eight-year memory when i
say yes let me explain what i mean
uh
we had people in the contra movement
southern front contras and indeed
there's a television a video deposition
of one of them
who says look i discussed the problem of
the drug dealing among our number with
my case officer
and he told me
who was that who was on the video this
this is a contra leader he was a member
of the contra directorate we took his
deposition in video form in san jose
costa rica do you recall his name uh not
off the top of my head okay
uh
i i just i just at the moment can't
recall who it was
he told us that he had discussed the
drug problem and his case officer said
look there's nothing we can do about it
you do what you have to do just don't
tell me anymore about it he discussed
the drug problem with his case officer
and what kind of a case officer was cia
and we had that just straightforward the
reaction of the people who were running
the covert operation as best as we could
determine was look we've been sent here
to central america to do a job
uh our job is to win this war against
the sandinistas and to change the
political climate here we're not in the
law enforcement business we can't be
playing cops with the people who are
working with us if there's drug
trafficking let the dea deal with it but
we have to do what we have to do and
please don't let that other mission
interfere with what we have to do
because by god it's difficult enough so
what you're saying is that the cia
individual did not stop him from dealing
in drugs right but he did not encourage
him to deal drugs no
or did not use this but he then always
excuse me the question is not finished
or did not use the proceeds
or or encourage the use of those
proceeds to finance the contract not at
all and as i said before all of the
people who played in this took the money
and put it in their pockets
now there's there's one other thing you
have to understand about the situation
in central america at the time and it's
relevant to the question you asked
there were
facilities that were needed for running
the war clandestine airstrips
cowboy pilots who would fly junker
airplanes
people who would make arrangements for
the clandestine movement of money
every one of those facilities was a
perfect facility for someone in the drug
business
so there were people who were connected
very directly to the cia who had those
facilities
and uh allowed them to be used and
indeed personally profited from their
use do you have anything do you have any
specifics on that i do and i will let me
finish the question who from the cia
permitted those facilities to be used
it's not that someone from the cia
permitted them to be used it's that a
contract employee had the facilities he
was doing a job that job wasn't
delivering drugs contract employee but
not a member of the cia that's right and
so the contract employee allowed those
facilities to be used
and the contract employee benefited from
the president you bet okay you bet and
none of that money went to the countries
and i i've shared with your uh staff the
name of the person involved
uh i don't want to uh uh here uh violate
the secrecy requirements that we were
bound by
the point is that
this was going on in tandem with the war
and the people who were organizing it
from our side saw all of it in fact you
had to be blind not to see it and
instead of trying to stop it or say wait
a minute we really ought to change our
policy here or rethink how we're doing
it
they went forward and said we're going
to solve the problem with the
sandinistas and the devil take this this
other set of issues mr blum
referring now to some specific
individuals who have been
who have been cited in the
mercury news series adolfo calero and
enrique bermudez
were either of those individuals
involved in the investigations which you
conducted
certainly they were central figures in
the uh contra movement
and uh their names came up uh again and
again in conversations about the problem
were they involved in in cocaine
directly directly to my knowledge i no i
have to say no all right indirectly to
your knowledge there many of their
people and their close associates were
but how about those individuals
specifically
i can't say that i have evidence of it
and who among their close associates
were involved
we have uh
listed uh people in the report we have
additional material and you'll find it
in our transcripts after eight years i
can't list names and if i did i'd be
taking a terrible risk well i can
understand that uh
are any of those individuals identified
in the san jose mercury series
not to my recollection no
uh
going back to the
uh issue of uh covert operations uh uh
mr blum
uh
based on what you have found do you
think the united states congress as a
matter of public policy
ought to ban covert operations
i think that there may in some
circumstances
desperate uh
matters of national urgency be some kind
of argument for them
but i will say that in my experience we
have rarely considered the blowback
we have rarely considered the long-term
political consequence and if you look at
the kind of catastrophic record
that
the operations that got us tangled up in
the drug business led to
i would say they failed remember we lost
the war in nicaragua
remember that our dear friends in the
argentine military
disappeared thousands of people
look at the horrible brutal reality of
pinochet's chile
and asked what kind of threat there was
to the united states that warranted that
kind of behavior
well i come to the i come to the public
policy question because this committee
has been very deeply involved and it's
continuing at this moment
on evaluation of what may or may not be
covert activities and i'm interested in
your judgment
but your but your net conclusion is that
there are some situations which may be
sufficiently serious to warrant covert
activities there may be but but uh i
believe that nowhere near the scale not
even a smidgen of the scale that they
were carried out on
in the past and certainly a complete
rethink of the idea of building
alliances with criminals and drug
dealers well i think we need to spend
much more money on overt diplomacy and
on public health for people who are our
friends and on real diplomacy we've
slashed the state department budget by a
tremendous amount and not done the same
for the intelligence budget i find that
quite mysterious
do you think we have slashed the state
department too much
in the past several years way too much
there's no money for people to travel no
money for them to negotiate no money to
bring foreign leaders here to teach them
to educate them no opportunity to bring
emerging leadership here we have a very
real budgetary problem my time is up and
i want to just ask you two very pointed
questions
when you say that
there
have been too many covert activities
are you aware of how many covert
activities there have been because the
findings are secret
they're made by the president
they're supposed to be secret there are
a fair number that do remain secret
believe it or not because this committee
does review them
uh so i just wonder what your basis
you know
let me finish the question so the
question is what is your basis
of knowledge as to the covert activities
which are which have been undertaken to
say that there are too many i have now
spent a number of years in
the field that is traveling around the
world talking to people
i will give you just one experience with
washington's notion of secrecy and the
world's notion of secrecy
it was one of my first trips to asia in
the middle of the vietnam war i was on a
klm plane flying over vietnam
the pilot dutch said ladies and
gentlemen look outside the window we're
flying over laos see that area it's been
carpet bombed
i came back to washington and i said to
senator simington i was then working for
the senate senator you know we're
bombing in laos he said shh that's
classified
now i submit to you he didn't he didn't
fly klm right
i submit to you
that lots of what you sit here and look
at and say boy this is classified it's
code word it's secret
uh they can only be talked about in a
skiff by people who've had their
backgrounds investigated to the nth
degree
out in the field is being talked about
at 40 decibels in a saloon somewhere
well let me come back to that it's a
it's a fairly involved subject which i
do want to pursue with you but i want to
yield at this time to senator kerry
thank you very much mr bloom
the record should show i disagree with
you on that on that point i mean there
are people out there
uh uh who are at considerable risk and
if what you said was true they wouldn't
be alive so i mean i i just let the
record show that i disagree with what
you just said
first first
mr bloom can you tell me it seems to me
that the
subcommittee and on that committee at
the time senator john kerry of
massachusetts brock adams washington
center moynihan of new york
on the on the ranking side was
congressman senator mcconnell uh of
kentucky and uh senator mccoskey of
alaska
it seems to me that the recommendations
i want to i want to give you an
opportunity to talk about this it seems
to me the subcommittee was successful in
some areas in other words that there
were some policy changes that occurred
both in law and on the administrative
side as a consequence of
uh the subcommittee's work is that is
that correct i hope so
well the answer is yes
i think we did
begin to to change the public perception
of the foreign policy issues i think we
did begin to get people to understand
the dimension of the drug problem and
refocus on the drug problem but but
there was very specific administrative
recommendations and very specific
legislative recommendations that were
made
do you know
mr bum how many of those
administrative recommendations and how
many of those legislative
recommendations were either accepted by
the executive branch or enacted by the
legislature i can't really tell you that
i left in
1989 and did not
handle the follow-through i think
some of them were considered maybe some
of them were adopted but i don't think
they were all uh accepted readily i
think we had uh some changes but they
were not really very dramatic well would
would uh you be prepared to to evaluate
this or perhaps i should just ask the
foreign relations committee to do it i
think that it would be more appropriate
to evaluate them i know we made it very
strong as i look at as i look through
the list and there's one two three four
five six seven on the administrative
side and one two three four five six
seven eight on the legislative side as i
look at the list there are
a number of them that i recognize
immediately as as being current u.s
policy and so it seems to me that uh
that it's likely to be the case that a
number of these recommendations were
made both by the executive branch and by
the legislative branch in response to
the subcommittee's work
i think that there were changes and i
think the hearings did have a positive
impact can secondly uh mr bunker you
talked to me you said that there was a
systematic effort to discredit the work
of the
of the subcommittee and you separately
mentioned that there was a refusal by
the department of justice to was it
justice justice to provide you with
information that you needed right is
that correct can you can you tell me put
a little more detail on what you mean by
systematic so some examples we would
want to know
systematic to me means that there was
there was an organized effort right is
that is that a correctness
how would you define systematic uh an
organized effort from the top who was in
charge of it
as best i could tell it was coming from
the top of the criminal division who was
at the top of the criminal division bill
weld
and and when you say the effort was made
what would they do they call you they
would tell us attorneys systematically
you can't talk to them don't give them
paper don't cooperate
don't let them have access to
people who you have in your control
and we had a very tough time finding
things out
thirdly mr bulma i don't want to get
into a great deal of argument about this
but i think it might be important just
from the standpoint of your evaluation
of when
in a covert environment
u.s personnel should say
that we're going to provide this
information to law enforcement in order
to be able to to uh in order to be able
to uh to
bring a conviction it seems to me you're
saying
this is one of the trickiest questions
in the law enforcement intelligence
agency world and i i should spend a
minute
giving you just a little bit of the
flavor of why it's so devilish well i i
actually you you needn't give me a
minute because i could give you an hour
i i understand that it's devilish
what i'm what what what's your view of
uh mr blum of the contra policy itself
do you
did you support at the time the contra
policy do you believe it had carried a
high priority i
thought that next to other things that
were going on in the hemisphere
the problem of the sandinista government
in nicaragua was
really at the low end of the scale but
did you did you think the contra effort
i understand that but did you you did
you think the contra effort was
worthwhile did you support it i didn't
think it was worthwhile i didn't take
any position on it uh publicly i i
thought that it was a a wrong a wrong
affair but i my business was to find out
what was going on in the drug trade and
we looked not only at the contra problem
but we looked at drugs going through
cuba drugs going through the bahamas and
all of the different national security
issues that were tangled up in in those
as well
so uh and we had bipartisan support
this was not a political effort to
unstring the contra war it was a
political effort to understand how it
could have come to pass
that we had tons of cocaine in miami and
people instead of trying to solve that
problem
we're telling law enforcement people to
look in a different direction can you
imagine a scenario mr blum under which
you would say that the objective the
foreign policy objective was so
important that it would in fact be a
higher priority than the law enforcement
effort here's my problem i think that if
people in the government of the united
states make a secret decision to
sacrifice some portion of the american
population
in the form of exposing them let's say
deliberately exposing them to drugs
that is a terrible decision that should
never be made are you saying that are
you
well now i want to be clear i'm not
saying
i'm not saying i'm not saying here that
there was such a secret decision well
then why did you make the statement let
me explain i mean i appreciate it
just a minute mr blum let's let senator
kerry finish his question
i mean
[Music]
i mean you you you made a statement that
that was was in the context of this
overall discussion of what's going on
with the cia's efforts in the contra
policy and and it seemed to leave the
impression at least that u.s
policymakers consciously sacrificed a
portion of the u.s population
mr chairman i i i will say to the
members i i support the chairman when he
says this this public hearing has to be
conducted uh with some civility and the
audience uh is is welcome and invited
here but i'll support the chairman's
decision to clear this room if we
continue to get interruptions it it does
not work for us you heard my opening
statement we're we're not trying to
cover up anything well
mr chairman
mr chairman i'm uh
well
may i have an opportunity mr plum
my judgment is that we ought to proceed
there's a lot of public interest in this
matter we want people to be present
uh we can't identify who's saying what
we're not going to get into any
investigations we just ask for your
cooperation
and allowing us to proceed with the
questions without a response to the
extent that you can
i would like to try to answer that as
best i can
when people
who are engaged in an operation
say
we're going to look the other way
we're not going to do anything interfere
in the law enforcement process to
protect people who are running the
operation and in that process of
interference permit drugs to flow in
you have an extraordinarily serious
problem now the dea
when it has mr
let me get you back to the question i
ask
i don't disagree with your statement
if you listen to the audience listen who
keeps interrupting with their
enthusiastic support of what you said
earlier
i i do think it is a terrible mistake
to say that we're going to allow drug
trafficking to destroy american uh
citizens
uh as a consequence of believing that
that that the contra effort was a higher
priority i ask you a question the
question is this
do you in your own mind
have a situation obviously you were at
best lukewarm to the contra effort
do you ever you see in your own mind
risk to the people of this country
that would carry with it a high enough
priority that in that circumstance you
believe that it would not be wise
to
bring the evidence out and pursue a
prosecution in that in that case
let me give you an example how about
nuclear nuclear proliferation how about
and how about it how about a covert
operation that's designed to enter to
interrupt and and and to uh prevent the
flow of of chemical and biological
agents in the united states in that
situation mr blum
in that situation mr blum what is your
view
if they if if the people that are
involved in that uncover evidence that
might lead to a prosecution should they
shut down
the operation
i understand that and there are
circumstances where i would agree
that you would shut down a prosecution
but you don't do it
uh on
the the question isn't is there a bright
line and can we draw a bright line
right there was a judgment call here and
that judgment call aired so far on the
wrong side of of where judgment should
have been
that we wound up with a terrible problem
and that terrible problem was a de facto
result
that i was describing that is where many
people did suffer as a consequence and i
started to say when dea
allows a controlled delivery of drugs
there is a furious debate
uh those control deliveries are
monitored because dea says our job is to
prevent it from coming in and if it
escapes on the street for any reason
we've blown it
and that kind of standard is really the
kind of standard that should have i
think been applied here
and maybe you can give me and maybe we
would both agree that there is some
dreadful circumstance where this should
have occurred and been allowed to occur
and so on and i probably could be
convinced in the right set of
circumstances but the problem was that
that issue wasn't put that way and the
sensitivity to what was going on was
simply missing
thank you
all right thank you very much senator
kerry senator rob
mr chairman i think that i will
defer any questioning it at this point i
think the
challenge to the committee has been
sufficiently articulated
and i think the sensitivity and
volatility
of the concerns are such that it would
be appropriate to have the two
uh
inspectors general uh complete their
work
before at least as far as my own
participation is concerned
uh
it is
the the the matters that are under
discussion are extremely serious and i
think they
deserve as factual um
an investigation as we can provide and
i'm not sure that attempting to come to
conclusions at this point
would advance the cause that i know that
the chairman and the vice chairman seek
in holding these particular hearings
i would i would ask a procedural
question perhaps to mr blument and that
is whether or not you believe
that the authority of the inspector's
gen goal is sufficient
to provide the kind of
answers
and the kind of objectivity that that
your concerns uh have addressed
to whatever conclusions this committee
might draw from those reports
i think that the authority is sufficient
as far as the behavior of people
who are employees of the specific agency
in question the justice department or
the cia
the
rest of the question which is at the
political level at the nsc
and the policy decisions taken will
undoubtedly wind up in that realm of
executive privilege
and top secrecy and therein lies the
very great difficulty in expecting the
inspectors general to solve the problem
i think we can find out whether cia
employees followed the rules
i don't think that the inspector general
can tell you all about what ollie north
did and didn't do
or what what uh
what was going on in that circle of
people and who they brought in and what
they told people to do
and we know enough now to know that many
people played out of channels and did
things out of channels or didn't
necessarily report them so i i have a
sense you can get a good part of the way
i'm not at all sure you can get all of
the way
mr chairman i think that i will
uh persist in in uh withholding at this
point i do have a couple of
articles that i was going to
use as the basis for questions that i
would like to simply provide to the
those who are going to conduct the
investigations to consider as a part of
any other information they may bring to
bear on their investigations
and i will await a formal uh completion
of their activities i know that they
haven't had an opportunity to speak
formally yet
but some indication of when they believe
that their reports would be available
would be useful
at least to me in terms of figuring out
what kind of time frame we're talking
about getting the kinds of facts
that would
hopefully address and perhaps put to
rest some of the questions that have
been raised senator rob we will address
that time frame what they expect to do
thank you mr chairman thank you senator
rob
uh mr blum
just a few more questions
come coming back to the end point of
uh my inquiries as to
covert actions and you gave the one
illustrations to klm and
i think it is obvious that there are
covert activities which are known
uh beyond the realm of secrecy but
your critique is very forceful and it
may well be that the congress ought to
make some different conclusions as to
covert activities
so that's why i was asking you
uh the basis for your statement that
there are too many covert activities as
a generalization the covert activities
are only known
to the oversight committees the
covert activities are undertaken after a
finding by the president so people in
the executive branch know
and we have some oversight
and it is true that sometimes covert
activities are disclosed in the public
media but it is a relatively rare
occurrence considering how many
uh there are so that's why i ask you the
question to what extent do you know of
the covert activities to
come to a judgment that there are too
many and they're
too far-fetched maybe what i should be
doing is paying much more careful
attention to language
and
i understand that
in in defining a covert activity you
have a very specific definition in mind
the question may turn more on
relationships and ongoing arrangements
than specific presidentially authorized
covert activities
so on the question of
protecting our friends in different
places whether they've been engaged in
human rights violations or in drug
trafficking violations there may not be
a covert activity as defined by law as
authorized by the president but there
may be ongoing relationships
this may be a definitional question i
may be
saying something different than what you
mean
i can't tell you though that i know
and i don't want to deceive you i don't
know what has gone on in the executive
branch in secret i have not been privy
to the findings and i don't want to
mislead you well it is a different
matter as to whether there are human
rights violations which uh
are not being pursued and this committee
has been very diligent in our pursuit
for example of what goes on in guatemala
and the committee used to be and behind
closed doors i'm sorry and the committee
is to be commended for i want you to
repeat
you you had made uh had made a comment
uh
about things that were taught to people
that were hard to
uh erase from their minds and one of
them was to teach people how to
assassinate
other people do you
have any uh evidentiary basis for a
conclusion that the united states is
seeking to assassinate someone contrary
to existing u.s policy certainly not uh
not currently but i refer you back to
the church committee investigation i'm
familiar with that yeah i know you are
so that's so that's that's about that's
the historical uh base from from which
i'm i'm talking i'm not talking about
currently that was specifically
prohibited and that problem was
addressed
uh mr blum in the course of the report
which was filed by the subcommittee on
terrorism narcotics and international
operations
what is the most explicit statement if
you could give it to us
on a finding that
u.s intelligence forces were permitting
people working for them to engage in
drug activities
i think i have to let the language of
the report speak for itself and i'll say
why
that report went through
so many editorial changes that even
after reading it i can't remember which
version uh got to where
the the report does speak for itself the
problem that we saw and we could
definitely speak to and i know the
report speaks to it is the problem
of
standing by when you knew
that people were doing the drug
were in the drug business when you were
an employee of
of the government well that's a very
very serious very
tough problem very serious matter are
you suggesting that it was stated more
explicitly but was cut out in the
editorial process
no i i think we were pretty i think it
is there that we we believed
that the government that is the cia was
aware of this problem was aware of
trafficking by people
and i think we said that
i i don't think that that's something
that was edited out i don't um
aware that
the intelligence operatives were
allowing drugs to be disseminated
certainly in the case of general noriega
beyond
my guess is and that's it's a guess but
i think a very educated guess that in
the case of uh honduras yes
uh in the case of uh haiti yes
they knew they knew there was a problem
how about with specific reference to the
distribution of drugs say in los angeles
uh i don't think they were ever given a
clean understanding of the full
implications of what was going on the
with respect to
with respect to
colonel north
and there you raise uh very very serious
questions
and
the congress had
said there'd be no more
support for the contras
i voted with the majority on that
opposed to supporting
the contras
there was a select committee
which investigated that matter the
investigation was started by the
intelligence committee when i was
honored in an early stage and it was
my hope that the intelligence committee
would have pursued that but a select
committee
took over
and
you had access to challenge the
refusal of the executive branch to turn
over information to you let me tell you
this mr blum that's going on today
senator kerry and i are fighting with
many of the departments of the executive
branch about not disclosing materials to
us
and it is an extraordinarily laborious
process and i believe that started in
george washington's day it didn't uh
it's been going on a long time and it
was very frustrating and i think very
damaging to the country that we do not
have access to materials
uh but but uh
uh
the select committee with uh senator
inouye an outstanding chairman uh
uh you had your own committee uh you you
did not lack for uh uh political power
to pursue
the committee's investigation and to
pursue
in a judicial context to find out more
about uh about colonel north uh
uh why wasn't it done is there really
something there that should have been
done that
but the committee was for a one
uh one term
uh
two year mandate and the mandate of the
committee expired
uh did you seek a supplemental mandate
uh
senator kerry did and it was uh turned
down
do you think the select committee was
derelict and not pursuing north further
i think that uh north should have been
pursued further that the diaries should
never have been accepted in an
expergated form that they should never
have remained classified to the degree
they did
and some of the things that happened
with the classification of those diaries
was bizarre
once when they were declassified in part
by the select committee some passages
were declassified others kept secret
then in the freedom of information suit
they were put through the classification
process a second time and the second
time some of the things that had been
released before were classified and some
of the things that were secret before
were made public
and that undermined any confidence at
all in the uh process that uh went on
you have two sets of those diaries with
different classifications
senator kerry i have no following
questions for sure
uh sean robb
i have no questions at this time mr
chairman
well uh thank you very much mr plum we'd
appreciate it if you have the time if
you would stay because there may be some
issues which will arise during the
course of the testimony from mr
hitz and mr bromwich would be uh we'd
like to have your information on uh we
now turn to uh mr fred hitz who is the
inspector general for the central
intelligence agency welcome mr hitz uh
the floor is yours
thank you mr chairman
i don't know is this microphone on
it is in uh the letter that you sent uh
on october 18
inviting me to appear
you asked uh that within the to the
extent possible in an open hearing you
would like to hear from me about the
nature of the allegations the scope of
our investigation
and the results of any previous
investigations or reviews conducted by
the cia that may be relevant
now you sir have sketched the
allegations in the san jose mercury and
i don't think i need to repeat those
uh at this time
but i will uh if you would permit me go
through how we got involved in this uh
the direction from
dci deutsch that would be fine mr hitz
we would appreciate that
on three september uh
after the appearance of the mercury
articles
dci deutsch wrote to me that he had
quote no reason to believe that there is
any substance to the allegations
published in the mercury news end quote
however he requested that i initiate an
immediate inquiry into the matter
because of the seriousness of the
allegations and the need to resolve
definitively
any questions in this area
at that time dci deutsch also requested
that i submit a report to him within 60
days containing our findings and
conclusions
in four september letters to several
members of congress this committee and
its counterpart in the house of
representatives
dci deutsch explained his decision to
request an inspector general
investigation he also stated that a
review of agency files quote including a
study conducted in 1988
and briefed to both the intelligence
committees
supports the conclusion that the agency
neither participated in
nor condoned drug trafficking by contra
forces end quote
further according to the dci the agency
never had any relationship with the two
individuals alleged by the mercury news
to have funneled drug trafficking
profits to the congress
also the dci stated that the agency had
never sought to have information
concerning these individuals
withheld in a drug-related prosecution
of a third individual as alleged in the
mercury news
we also as an office recognize the
seriousness of these allegations
and accordingly we reacted quickly to
the dci's request
by anor by organizing an initial team of
three investigators an auditor a
research assistant and a secretary to
conduct a preliminary review of the
scope and nature of the issues involved
that team developed
and i transmitted to all agency
components
a 12 september 1996 request for
comprehensive searches
of all agency record systems regarding a
broad range of relevant subjects
the request also called for the
components to designate specific
personnel
who would be individually responsible
for certifying to the thoroughness of
those searches
we also published a bulletin to all
agency employees
explaining the nature of our
investigation and asking that they
provide us with any relevant information
in their possession
the search request extended to any and
all documents and information
regardless of its form or sensitivity
relating to
number one
any cia connection with a number of
specific individuals
two any possible drug trafficking and
related activities by the contras or
associated persons
three
what actions cia took in response to
such information and four any contacts
with federal state local or foreign law
enforcement entities in regard to these
individuals and activities
because of the dci's request for report
within 60 days
we established a deadline of 18
september for the components to provide
our office with copies of all responsive
documents and information
it has since become apparent that there
is absolutely no chance we will be able
to meet anything like a sixty day
deadline
the size of the information base that
must be thoroughly reviewed by the
agency components in order to respond to
our documents to our to our request is
enormous
for example
our two our team has reviewed over five
thousand cables that were identified in
our own preliminary and limited
electronic search of the agency's cable
database
we have just received our first several
hundred documents from the directorate
of operations in response to our request
and have been advised that five to ten
thousand electronic records are in the
final stages of review for relevance to
our tasking
while over 350 boxes of files have been
recalled from agency archives and must
be manually searched for responsive
records
additional searches are underway in the
directorates of administration and
intelligence the offices of
congressional affairs and the general
council which have provided only very
limited responses so far
we have been told that a search of the
same records base in the 1980s at the
request of the iran-contra independent
council took two years and the efforts
of 50 to 60 agency personnel
we are not saying that our investigation
will take two years
we're stating merely that we have a lot
of ground to cover
mr hitz uh what are you saying as to how
long it will take uh i understand mr
chairman that you're going to
seek a precise answer to that question
no no i already i can't give you one but
let me just sketch a bit what we're
about and perhaps we can return to that
while we are attempting to tailor our
requests as much as possible the bulk of
the information that is responsive to
our request will not even be received by
my office for at least two weeks
thus we remain in the preliminary stages
of our investigation
soon we will face the requirement to
review catalog and digest substantial
amounts of information in order to move
into the interviewing phase
in anticipation of this requirement we
have assigned three additional
investigators
an independent contractor and another
research assistant to our team
another auditor and two inspectors will
be joining the team shortly as well well
how many people do you have in total
than working on it we're going to have
six plus three uh plus two so uh 11 at
this time is that enough i'm not sure
sir
i'm not sure
i think
we always have the problem and you've
been through these investigations
yourself too many cooks spoil a broth if
you haven't got something for them to do
initially but we are prepared
uh to
put the resources on this matter uh that
are required to do as expeditious as a
job as we can well mr hitz i just
suggest and you're an experienced
investigator that you have to make a
determination as to how many people you
need and get them at an early stage it
sounds to me as if you have
quite a task ahead of you and that
it ought to be done
as promptly as possible which is a
customary phrase but there's a lot of
concern here
and there's a question about our
deferring to you and to the justice
department ig
uh and if we're to do that we have to
have some pretty precise ideas to
as to when it's going to be completed
then the resources available to it i
appreciate
your concern mr chairman and
i'm going to try to refine if i can
our time frame but i can assure you that
we will devote whatever resources can
profitably be expended on this matter
okay and i'm also
happy to report that we've had
preliminary discussions and are looking
forward to working closely with mike
bromwich
the justice department inspector general
who's here and his staff
since it's obvious that there will be
several areas where our investigative
interests and jurisdiction
will overlap and complement each other
while we do not have much substantive
insight at this point
i can describe what we have learned from
the limited document documentation
provided to us thus far
regarding the agency's position when
similar questions were raised in the
line
in the late 1980s
we are not vouching for the accuracy of
these statements at this point
but are describing for the committee
their contents
according to these records
in early 1987 the state department
requested that the agency review
all available information relating to
the possible involvement of the contras
in drug trafficking
the 21 january 1987 paper that resulted
was described as coordinated throughout
the intelligence community and with dea
the drug enforcement administration
it began and i'm quoting
uh from that paper
review of information available to the
intelligence community gives no
indication
that anti-sandinista groups that have
received
or now are receiving support from the u
s government
have engaged in drug trafficking to fund
their operations
some allegations of contra involvement
in drug trafficking have surfaced over
the past few years
dea and fbi officials along with the
intelligence community
along with intelligence community
leaders however
say no credible information exists to
support such allegations that's from the
paper the paper went on to discuss
allegations
you say in early
87 and then the paper was produced uh 21
january 87 that's pretty early as well
and when when was the request made
how much time did it take them to
produce this this report
i'm not sure
uh the initial request
uh senator kerry was nine january so on
nine january state department request
the agency review all available
information relating to the possible
involvement of the conscious and drug
trafficking 12 days later a response is
given and you're telling us that you
can't get your work done in 60 days or
50 days
i mean does that does that cause you to
reach some conclusion about the
about the
report that was produced in 12 days it
might sir i we're going to have to
determine what documents there they
reviewed and i take i take your point
the paper went on to discuss allegations
regarding certain individuals that had
been received and acted upon by the
agency
just over a year later on 28 march 1988
then deputy dci robert gates sent a
memorandum to the agency's deputy
directors for intelligence and for
operations
asking for a briefing concerning quote
contra involvement in narcotics related
activities
to include any pilots involved in the
resupply effort who may have had past or
current ties to narcotics related
activities end quote
he indicated in this memorandum that he
wanted to be quote fully informed
on the facts because so many questions
and allegations were being raised about
these subjects
the memorandum also suggested that quote
there may be some merit in setting all
of this down on paper for the record
perhaps to be provided to both the
president's intelligence oversight board
and to the oversight committees of the
congress end quote
according to the memorandum the briefing
was to include specifics and
comprehensiveness this request appears
to have produced at least two written
responses
one is an undated and unsigned paper
entitled quote allegations of resistance
activities in narcotics trafficking end
quote
it begins by stating and i'm quoting
from the paper
all allegations implying that the cia
condoned vetted or participated in
narcotics trafficking are absolutely
false
the agency constantly checks for any
evidence of drug smuggling by nicaraguan
resistance members
and any person or entity found to be
involved in such activity must be
separated from the resistance
in addition the agency has consistently
informed the congressional oversight
committees of any resistance drug
activities in briefings and in written
responses
the paper then goes on that's the end of
my quote from the paper the paper then
goes on to describe a variety of
allegations as to specific individuals
and how the agency responded to each
the second apparent response is a 31
march 1988 memorandum to ddci gates
entitled quote
pilots airplanes and shipping companies
used in the resupply efforts that may
have had past or current ties to
narcotics related activities end quote
this memorandum was prepared by the
central america task force which was
responsible for managing the agency's
program in support of the contracts
it begins as follows
and i'm quoting again from the
memorandum during the past several years
there have been numerous allegations
in the media that pilots and airline
companies that the agency has used in
the resupply efforts of the democratic
resistance have been involved in
narcotics activities
to our knowledge no pilot or crew
members have engaged in the illegal
narcotics activities while working for
the agency
as per your instructions a year ago and
because of agency concerns about drug
activities
the agency has been extremely careful to
properly vet
all pilots mechanics and companies
involved in transporting equipment for
the nicaragua program
the agency runs internal traces on these
individuals and companies and in
addition routinely queries dea
fbi and customs and in some cases such
as shipping companies the us coast guard
if no derogatory information is found a
conditional approval is submitted
if some derogatory information is found
or alleged but the various agencies do
not believe it would be a problem for
the u s government to have a contract
with the individual or company a special
approval is required which is signed by
the chief of the division
that's the end of my quote from that
memorandum this memorandum then
discusses allegations
regarding specific pilots and
organizations and how they were handled
by the agency
while we are not yet in a position to
vouch for these conclusions we'll have
to look at all the documentation that
underlay them
these documents illustrate the agency's
view of the matter in 1987 and in 1988
other studies may have been conducted by
the agency in the 80s however we have
not yet been able to find or review such
other studies as might exist
and that serves my effort to try to
bring you up to speed on the reviews
conducted by the cia that we have been
able to
uncover so far without getting into the
kind of vetting and
examination of what lay behind them to
see if there's a substance to it
in closing i would like to assure you
and the american public that my office
will conduct as thorough a review as
possible
of all available information and will
report what we find
candidly and completely
over the past five years i believe we
have earned a reputation for
independence and objectivity
as a result
of dealing in this fashion with other
highly significant and controversial
subjects
these have included the alder james
investigation human rights abuses in
guatemala
the paris compromise the b l scandal and
many others they're not as well known
outside our venue
in many ways
and i want to underscore this mr
chairman and senator kerry senator rob
in many ways the recent allegations of
cia involvement in narcotics trafficking
are the most controversial
politically charged and potentially
damaging of any that we've looked at
while some may choose not to believe
findings that do not correspond to their
pre correspond to their preconceptions
we will present the unvarnished truth as
we find it
and we'll do so to the best of our
abilities
we welcome the support of the oversight
committees and believe it will be
essential to the credibility of our
findings
and i thank you for your attention
thank you very much mr hitz before
turning to mr bromwich could you give us
uh
an estimate a guesstimate a ballpark
figure as to how long it's going to take
you
well i tried to sketch
mr chairman
uh the enormity of the document review
that we're going to have to undertake uh
i believe i think you've done that
fairly well now we'd like to know how
long it's going to take i would not like
to give you a specific date sir i think
it would just uh be
a premature at this time but i give you
my solemn assurance that we will expend
the resources on it and this committee i
know
will
verify that that is the case to move on
this
as thoroughly and as quickly as we can
it's our top priority
dr deutch has made it clear that it's
his top priority as well
mr hitch i think we need more than that
why don't you go back to the drawing
board and take a look at the documents
you have and take a look at the
parameters and take a look at your
resources and figure out what you can
use and give us
a projection as to how long it is going
to take i'll attempt to do that mr
chairman okay
we now turn to
the inspector general for the department
of justice mr michael r bromwich mr
bromwich thank you for coming and the
floor is yours thank you very much mr
chairman senator kerry senator rob i
have a brief opening statement that i
would like to introduce for the record
it will be admitted in full and you may
proceed orally as you choose thank you
very much senator i i do not want to
talk about the issues that are discussed
in my prepared testimony obviously i
invite any questions
that you may have i want to sketch a
little bit about
how this committee and the american
people can be assured that our inquiry
will explore independently fairly
objectively
exactly what the justice department's
involvement
was in the allegations as first frame by
the san jose mercury
for better or for worse mr chairman i'm
not a stranger either to
issues of narcotics distribution nor to
issues relating to
iran contra i served for four years as a
narcotics prosecutor in the u.s
attorney's office for the southern
district of new york first under john
martin who is now a federal judge and
for the bulk of my tenure under now
mayor rudolph giuliani we did not in
that office do street level drug cases
we focused on
high level narcotics trafficking both in
cocaine and in heroin
the largest cases i tried the last of
which was in december of 86
focused specifically on large rings of
people the last case involved elements
of italian organized crime who were
making deals with drug dealers down here
in d.c and the sales were ultimately
made directly into the african-american
community here in the district of
columbia i was
in that office senator uh responsible as
deputy chief of narcotics for
supervising the work of from 20 to 22
lawyers who did nothing but focus on
high-level narcotics trafficking cases
uh shortly before i left the office in
december of 1986
i was named the chief of the narcotics
unit by mr giuliani
i left that office senator to
work for the iran contra independent
council lawrence walsh i began my
service with him in january of 1987. i
was one of the first seven lawyers hired
by judge walsh let me just quickly
sketch some of the things that i did
while in that office that i think do
bear at least some relevance to the
inquiry that my agency is going to begin
and that
your body is going to be working on
during the early phases of that
investigation a colleague of mine and i
focused on allegations that there had
been illegal fundraising on behalf of
the contras and then that in particular
certain individuals most notably carl
channel and richard miller had worked
together with lieutenant colonel north
in soliciting wealthy american
individuals to provide money large
contributions uh to the contras there
was a specific representation uh by
lieutenant colonel north and his
colleagues that in fact the contras were
in desperate need of weapons
they assigned particular dollar values
to the weapons
and made very elaborate presentations to
wealthy individuals that's all part of
the public record both with the house
and senate select committees as well as
that of my office we early on secure
guilty pleas both from mr channel and mr
bill miller who pled guilty to in fact
misusing a tax exempt foundation to
solicit contributions for the contras
and specifically uh to buy weapons for
the contrast i was
mr chairman and senators
responsible for coordinating the overall
grand jury investigation
during the first two and a half years of
iran contra in approximately the fall of
1987
i headed a team
of approximately seven lawyers and
approximately the same number of fbi and
other law enforcement agents who were
specifically looking at possible
criminal misconduct on the part of
employees of the central intelligence
agency the department of state as well
as private individuals who were involved
in the resupply network out of that team
as i'm sure you recall came the
indictment of former costa rican station
chief joseph fernandez
and that case as you know was aborted
subsequently
in the latter stages of 1989 because the
department of justice which as you well
know was completely separate and
independent from our work as the
independent council refused to release
the documents and declassify the
documents that our office needed in
order to pursue that matter
uh were you dissatisfied with that very
much so
now you have the power to get into the
inside of that as the inspector general
of the department of justice i do part
of the problem obviously is going to be
framing an inquiry that can be done in
some reasonable period of time and i
really want to work with this committee
in trying to determine what framing
makes sense so we're going to we're
going to come to that but but here you
are
having been an adversary of the
department of justice
now you're the inspector general of the
department of justice i'm not suggesting
a conflict of interest because
he worked for the united states he
worked the people of the united states
on both occasions i certainly do how how
how would you be able to proceed on that
uh well i don't that is currently not
within the scope of our investigation if
this committee or others ask us to look
directly into this i will certainly do
so i have to be obviously very careful
not to pursue an investigative agenda
here that others may think may derive
from trying to settle old scores uh or
probe into something that i have a
particular an individual interest in i
just throw that out i'm happy to have
further discussions uh with you and
members of the committee about well on
the surface it uh looks to me as if it's
relevant but uh i don't want to draw any
final conclusions at this uh i don't
want to do that on horseback today thank
you uh senator uh
in from from january of 1989 through
may of 1989
i was one of the three courtroom lawyers
for the united states of america
in the prosecution of lieutenant colonel
oliver north
as you recall some of the newspapers
i've seen recently suggest that that
case ended in an acquittal it did not
lieutenant colonel north was convicted
of three felonies in that case uh his
conviction was only reversed
subsequently by the court of appeals
uh i was in that office for two and a
half years i was
i i've described in brief detail what my
overall responsibilities were
i left that office in october of 1989
and returned to the private practice of
law
and did that for approximately four
years i was nominated in the late winter
of 1994 and took office in june 1994
as the inspector general of the
department of justice
i have not dealt with an issue since
i've been inspector general i've dealt
with some very sensitive and very
important ones that has resonated so
clearly uh both with the congress and
with the american people
when i first became aware of these
allegations in mid-september
uh i obviously wanted to examine what
the allegations were i reviewed the
articles in the san jose mercury
and it seemed to me that there were
enough troubling questions about the
points of contact between individuals
employed by different components of the
justice department and the allegations
that drew together the cia and the
contras and the introduction of crack
cocaine into south central los angeles
that i thought it was very important to
launch an investigation to clarify the
record i did so on my own without being
directed by anyone either inside the
department or outside the department we
complement you for that mr bromwich
thank you
since that time i have spent time
because i think it's important dealing
with the representatives of people in
the affected communities to try to
assure them that given my background and
the reputation that my office has that
we will do our very best to try to get
the bottom up to the bottom of this and
to explore fully what the involvement if
any of the department of justice
employees was
with these allegations indeed the very
day that i decided to open the
investigation i met with congresswoman
waters who's here today i subsequently
met with her again
she facilitated an introduction to me to
gary webb the author of the san jose
mercury articles and i have talked with
mr webb on subsequent occasions i then
proceeded to talk to other members on
both sides of the aisle who clearly had
an interest in this matter and having
the investigation done properly and well
i met with your counterpart uh senator
spector mr convest the chairman of of
hipsie the house permanent select
committee on intelligence as well as mr
dix i met with
julian dixon who is a senior member of
the house permanent select committee on
intelligence and whose district in
california borders on south central los
angeles and i also met with juanita
melinda mcdonald who is a congressperson
as ms waters is
from south central los angeles they made
me even more aware than i already was uh
that of the importance of our
investigation and the fact that we were
facing deep cynicism and distrust of the
federal government and and even with the
department of justice i just returned
last night senators from what for me was
an extraordinary trip to south central
los angeles i was invited to do so
by congresswoman melendra mcdonald
to meet with some computer community
leaders so that they would have a chance
to
meet firsthand with the person who is
going to be conducting one of the
investigations that touches on these
issues
i won't say that that trip was was
roundly endorsed by others in the
department it was an extraordinary trip
but i certainly felt the responsibility
to go out there and do whatever i
thought roundly endorsed no it was not
department was it opposed uh i'd prefer
not to talk about that
okay it was it was opposed by some
and while i was out in los angeles i met
with a a number of people i met with a
group of approximately 30 to 35
community leaders i met with the mayor
of los angeles i met with the membership
of the county board of supervisors uh i
met with yesterday a group of from 12 to
15 clergymen from the south central area
who has who i i am told represented
about 50 000 or so parishioners in south
central l.a
and what i tried to tell them is what
i'm going to tell you and the american
people here today
is that don't rush to any conclusions
what i ask is for people to keep an open
mind and let us do our work
the facts and nothing but the facts will
drive our investigation
and its conclusions and i don't think
anybody at this point is in a position
to say whether those allegations are
true
or they are not true
when i decided to open this
investigation on september 20th i
immediately put in place a team and
within a week we had a very
comprehensive documents request that
went out to all components of the
department of justice
we have already started to
receive the products of that work uh and
it looks to be that the documents that
the justice department has that deal
with
monessus and blandone and ross and
others are in fact quite voluminous
right now we have a team of nine or ten
that are assigned to the matter and i
will preempt your question and tell you
that that in my judgment will not be
enough uh and i'm in the process of
trying to get additional resources uh to
supplement my team
that really is all i want to say at this
point senator i take this investigation
and the responsibilities that it imposes
on me
and my office very seriously i will only
mention that i think the work that we
have done in my office since i took
office
should establish that we are capable of
calling the tough ones toughly and as we
see them we did i think the definitive
review of allegations relating to the
good old boy roundup
around which there were serious
allegations of racial misconduct and
other kinds of misconduct in a law
enforcement related gathering in
southeastern tennessee from 1980 to
1995. we told the whole story there and
laid out that in fact uh some of the
some of the worst of the racial
allegations were in fact true
we recently completed a review
that was a department of treasury matter
wasn't alcohol tobacco and firearms well
there were more treasury department
employees who attended uh than justice
department but early on we had
information that there were a number of
justice department employees attended as
well and i thought it was my
responsibility to explore that even
though it wasn't given
how did the treasury department do on
that investigation
i i think their investigation was a less
complete one than ours that's why i
referred to ours as i think they still
haven't uh admitted to any failings in
the ruby ridge matter i don't know if
they ever will
right up to the secretary of the
treasury
is that a question for me no it's a
statement my question was how they did
on your investigation i just wanted to
say
on one that you ran side by side with
them uh the other investigation that i
would draw your attention to is one that
we completed in in june of this year
involving allegations that the
congressional task force on immigration
reform led by representative gallogly of
california was deceived by high-level
officials within the immigration and
naturalization service who conspired to
create a potemkin village if you will a
false appearance to facilities of the
chrome detention facility and miami
international airport we found that
in fact the deception had taken place
and that high level officials in the ins
were responsible for it
we recommended in our report that 13
officials of the immigration
naturalization service be disciplined to
some extent up through and including
termination
those are just a couple of the special
investigations that we've done we also
have uh going right now investigations
of the fbi lab which i'm sure you're
aware of in other matters as well uh
that's all that that i would care to say
in this statement but i am obviously i'm
all too happy to respond to any
questions that you might have well thank
you very much mr bromwich and
uh
we commend you for
meeting with the community leaders i
think that is very important to
let them know what you are doing which
is what we're trying to today to let
them as well as others know what we are
doing what you are doing
and that the matter will be pursued
i'm glad to hear you have nine
investigators when you
sent us over your statement yesterday
you say you had three attorneys as well
as additional investigators both here on
the west coast is the total of nine or
is that nine attorneys nine nine to ten
no it's not not nine attorneys i don't
have nine attorneys who are experienced
in doing these kinds of investigations
you do not have enough people that's
correct have you determined what uh does
constitute enough i won't know until we
see more of the what the volume of of
documents are
but it is clear to me that i will not be
able to suffice simply with the former
prosecutors that i have on my staff and
as i've done in some of our other
investigations both in the roundup
investigation the miami ins
investigation and the fbi labs i will be
seeking uh people from other parts of
the justice department hopefully very
experienced people who have done complex
investigations like that to supplement
my own team well how about the ultimate
question how long will it take you to
complete your work i am under oath in
front of the house judiciary committee
when i testified in september that i
will never again become a prisoner of my
own estimates i did under uh duress from
this is this is the senate uh mr brown i
understand that
i understand that i i
i'm not going to give you a precise
estimate i will tell you that i will do
uh everything that i can to do a
comprehensive uh investigation that will
leave as few questions on the justice
department side of things uh unanswered
and we'll do it as fast as i possibly
can
which do you have to be called before
the judiciary committee to get an
estimate pardon me no i'm not i'm going
to give them the same answer senator i
think it's unfair to you i think it's
unfair to the public to give you an
estimate uh that is based really on very
well permit me permit me to disagree
with you i i would like you to assess
what you see the scope to be and what
you see the need for personnel to be
and to give us a projection of the
timetable i'm only adjusting with you
about judiciary which has oversight over
the department of justice
we have some overlapping membership
including mine but just as i've asked mr
hitz to do that
i would ask you to do that i think i
think we need a time frame and we need
some mild posts we need to have some
congressional
oversight as to us as to where you're
going
senator i'm
very unhappy let me say this for the
record today i've already said it with
the justice investigation of ruby ridge
i was not involved in that i know i know
you weren't but it's your department uh
and and uh
that investigation started in august of
1995 only because
the senate undertook an investigation
and there have been a lot of people who
are hanging in the wind there and just
yesterday an information was returned
and i have pressed your department for
an answer and they won't give me one i'm
well aware of that
as to as to what what is going to be
done i don't think we can wait for 15
months
and then begin to wonder when it's going
to be done i am happy to be in close
touch with you senator with senator
kerry with senator rob with everybody on
the judiciary committees and the
intelligence committees to let you know
how we are proceeding and what the scope
of our investigation is i think that is
evolving to some extent as we sit here
today the estimate that i gave to
congressman gallagher and other members
of the task force was that if everything
went right and nothing and nothing ever
does as you know senator i thought we
might be able to get it done in three
months it took us 11. all of them agreed
that it was worth waiting for because we
were blocked at various key points uh by
the immigration and naturalization
service but i i am not going to pin
myself into an estimate at this early uh
in an investigation i don't think i
don't think it's i understand your
interest in doing so
but i must tell you mr chairman i am
extremely reluctant to do so because
i've had bad experiences with it in the
recent past well it may be that your
estimate of three months uh enable you
to get it done as early as 11 months i
understand i understand your reluctance
and
i've had some uh experience in the
matters myself and i know it's hard to
estimate
but
this committee wants uh
once it wants an estimate if it turns
out to be a guesstimate or a ballpark
figure we like to have some ideas to
what you're going to be doing and your
resources and your parameters i'm happy
i'm going to give unlimited amounts of
information about that senator i just
don't want to be put into a number
estimate at this point well
uh i'd like you to reconsider that
when you say in your statement that you
do not have jurisdiction over cia
employees
that raises a concern on my part as to
whether you're going to have access to
cia employees you don't have
jurisdiction over
over the los angeles county sheriff's
department or the california bureau of
narcotics enforcement
and
the
mercury story
says that quote agents from four
organizations dea u.s customs los
angeles county sheriff's department and
the california bureau of narcotics
enforcement have complained that
investigations were hampered by the cia
or unnamed quote national security
interests
enter quote
close quote
now one of the questions i have for you
and for mr hitz is uh
how are you going to deal with that if
it's going to be investigated by this
committee
we have authority to go beyond your own
department although i'll tell you this
we've had some terrible
results asking the department of defense
to say anything to this committee
so we haven't done too well on that
either although we
had
moved for a subpoena on one matter but
how are you going to deal with
these groups outside your jurisdiction
do you really have the competency mr
hits have the competency to convict this
investigation or does it have to be done
by a congressional committee i think
that that
we have the jurisdiction to get at a lot
of it and we to tell the whole story of
what the justice department did and
didn't do with respect to some of these
matters i fully expect to have to go
outside the justice department not only
to the cia but to the other agencies
that you've just mentioned
i can't i can't compel them
to provide the information but i
certainly have learned in my two-year
tenure on the job that a specific and
public statement in a final report or
elsewhere that somebody has failed to
cooperate with us is a powerful
incentive to get people to cooperate
with us and to give us access to
witnesses and documents that we need to
do our job mr roberts i have to disagree
with you about that i don't think a
statement on the final report that
somebody's failed to cooperate with you
is nearly forceful enough
you do you do not have subpoena power we
have administrative subpoena power we do
not have within your within your
department no we have administrative
subpoena power more broadly than that
senator well can you use that
administrative subpoena power to
go after the california bureau of
narcotics enforcement if they won't
comply if they will not voluntarily
comply i'm fully prepared to use the
administrative support do you have the
authority you're on your own to issue
those subpoenas yes i do
how about you mr hitch i don't have
subpoena authority mr chairman and i
share the same concern that you do that
when our investigation bumps up into
other agencies we're going to count on
getting their full cooperation you'll
recall senator spector you were the
father one of the fathers of the intel
the inspector general provision i was
the grandfather charles battaglia the
staff director as well
the parentage will uh still hold up the
point being that you have uh directed us
in that statute to come back to this
committee when we find that uh the lack
of subpoena power or a lack of
cooperation with any other entity
makes it impossible to do our job and we
will do that but i think that uh
between mr bromwich and myself we can
cover an awful lot of ground and i think
we'll just have to keep this committee
informed as to
bumps in the road if we encounter them
well perhaps we ought to consider we do
have continuing jurisdiction as to
whether we ought to be the vehicle for
subpoenas uh mr bromwich
uh who enforces your administrative
subpoena we do
my office has his own office of general
counsel and how do you how do you do
that you go to court to get an order we
force your subpoena we do and the
attorney general has no say over what
you do that's correct
well okay you've made some strong
statements about your subpoena power
i have
if we are making uh wishes for or what
we would like to have i think the fact
that i don't have testimonial subpoena
power uh severely restricts the ability
that i have so what is the scope then of
what you describe as administrative
subpoena power or documents and things
dukasticum the equivalent of of either
trial subpoenas do costume or grand jury
subpoenas ducas teacum well that's
documentary that's very limited if you
can't subpoena witnesses it it certainly
is uh and i have for a long time thought
it was very important just for an
inquiry such as this that we have
testimonials subpoena power we don't
well i'm very concerned about the tools
that you have at your disposal to move
interagency and
move beyond the federal government to
state agencies or local agencies senator
kerry
well mr chairman uh follow me along that
line i mean i had a whole series of
questions uh that addressed the
difficulty that both of you are gonna
are gonna face and
and i'm gonna say that one of the one of
the one of the problems that may be here
that we've we've we've got we're gonna
have a bar that's much too high but
you're never gonna be able to satisfy it
in other words uh you let's say uh mr
hitz produce your report let's say you
get it done in 50 days
uh you produce a report the the the
constraints on the inspector general for
the cia are considerable
i mean you you will have
national security concerns you've got to
produce a declassified document
that's correct and the and the
suspicions are going to be rather
substantial that the declassified
document
left out information that could have
been damaging to the cia the perception
of lack of independence
is going to be
there my guess is my guess is it's going
to be difficult to produce i mean we we
just spent uh i don't know how many how
many how many months uh
with a with a special special committee
the senate looking at white water
special committee the house looking at
travel gate nobody died in those deals
uh you know it seems to me
i mean both senator rob and i
participated in one on the powmia issue
when it became uh
senator kerry jared as well senator john
kerry where the evidence was that
perhaps uh the government the united
states had not done all they should have
i'm just i like your opinion as to
whether or not given the your
understanding of what's going on in the
public and their attitude towards the
cia whether or not we're asking the
inspector generals of the department of
justice and the and the central
intelligence agency to do something that
they in fact are not going to be able to
do satisfactorily
well i think senator kerry uh
you're quite right to point out uh
the fact that we can
take the horse to water but we can't
force them to drink if we produce a
report that
doesn't meet this high bar that you
speak of
we're going to get second guessed but
my suggestion would be
on the key matter that you just raised
for example about declassification
materials now you've got director
deutsch's firm assurance that he's going
to push that as hard as he can he has
nothing to defend here
wasn't on his watch wants to get to the
bottom of it
i tend to hold him to it and i know you
do too on the declassification matter
secondly as to whether or not we'll get
the whole story i would suppose that
at the end of the day you will look at
what
we come up with
and if you determine that it is uh
wanting
uh you will
jump in and finish the job i basically
feel that we ought to be given a chance
to
find out uh
what went on i
perhaps have
i have enough to do just to look at the
records that were generated in cia
as a consequence of the kerry
examination as a consequence of iran
contra as a consequence of our own
look-sees before i start thinking about
department of defense or some other
outfit that might not that might be
involved i guess i mean what i'm
wondering is whether or not it would be
advisable for you to produce both of you
an interim report it would not be fine
the lord knows uh we're basically asking
to get back and give us some idea of how
long it's going to take you to do your
work and likewise with you mr hitz uh
it me
are you
qualify do you think to make an
evaluation as to whether or not the ig
itself is going to be able to
satisfactorily complete this
investigation you know given that one of
the things we're trying to do is both
not only get to the bottom of it but do
it in such a fashion that in a
non-emotional way people look at the
facts and uh and and reach the
conclusion uh based upon what the facts
say
all we can do senator is our best and
you'll understand i understand that but
may redirect the question or restate the
question i guess i don't want to
redirect it to uh you redirected it i
think but it it is are you qualified in
uh
to make a judgment or do you feel any
constraint to make a judgment to us that
would include the possibility of you
saying
this is just you know the ig cannot
cannot do what you're asking us to do
you're asking us to do something that we
may not be able in fact complete but
let's take a for instance because i
think is a very uh
sound question
let's take a for instance that after we
can finish our document review uh we
seek to interview individuals who may
or have been alleged to have been
involved in this
from a period that we've already stated
takes us back into the eighties they may
not wish to speak to us
and at that point it seems to us that we
have we will have to come forward and
tell this committee tell the director
that that is the case
well that's a that's a that's a clear
potential limitation which we hope we
would be able to overcome
uh uh through
persuasion but we as i say don't have
subpoena power and it may not be
possible but again what i'm asking you
both
mr bromwich and you mr hitz is are you
are are you
are you
liberated
to reach the conclusion that the ig may
not be able to satisfactorily do this
investigation
whether it's because of personnel
or because of other restrictions that
may be upon you and you know what yours
are i mean the chairman of i've been
struggling trying to get documents
declassified so we could get them out
public and
to to put it mildly but not a very
satisfactory process and it leaves
hanging out there questions instead of
answering questions it ends up provoking
more
and i i mean very
direct again it would be
very much grateful for a yes or no
answer do you feel
like in your arsenal of of words that
you have the word no i can't do this
this is you've asked me to do something
uh mr director and let me just get right
back to you mr director deutsch and say
i just went up and met and appeared
before the senate select committee on
intelligence and uh listen to what
chairman specter was asking me and the
questions that he asked and the answers
that i'm giving and i'm telling you i
don't think we can do this i think this
is going to lead to to the to the
production of a report that may provoke
more questions than it answers
is that yes or no do you do you feel you
feel liberated to be able to to say
we've taken a look at this thing and we
can't do it we should not this should
this is not something perhaps the ig can
be supportive
of another evaluation another
investigation understand what's going on
here
the public's going to say
it's the ig report that we're looking at
whatever the ig report you you are doing
the investigation
of this entire map both of you are
uh and i i might look to you again for
an answer
directly do you are you are you prepared
uh if you reach the conclusion if either
one of you and i
appreciate an answer from both of you if
you reach if you reach the conclusion
that this is that this effort is outside
the scope of what the ig can do are you
prepared to say to your bosses uh that a
different process needs to be set in
place let me answer that senator kerry i
want to remind you that no question was
put to me and no direction was given to
me it was my decision
independently to examine these
allegations and i only did so at the
time because i believed we could do a
credible
job credible comprehensive and
independent job of examining these
allegations now
the scope of this investigation
obviously is changing
i'm a little worried that it's become
going to become an amoeba and
it's going to take entirely uh too much
time that it's not fair to ask this
committee or or the the people to to
wait but i will i will tell you an
amoeba or an octopus uh either senator
either well i mean but but i but i i am
i was confident and am confident
that at least on the justice department
side we will be able to explore
many if not all of the questions that
have been raised with respect to the
allegations as first frame for the
american province you've independently
reached the conclusion that an ig
evaluation of this is necessary yes sir
are you are are you prepared if you
reach the conclusion
that an ig evaluation of this would be
insufficient are you prepared then to
say to the attorney general the united
states of america that we have a
situation here where the ig is not going
to be able to do this work and likewise
to you mr hitz if you reach the
conclusion
that this work is going to fall outside
the scope of the ig's office are you
prepared
to say to director deutsch mr director i
can't do this work yes i'm prepared to
do so and i would obviously tell this
committee that at the same time i'm
prepared to do so as well
thank you
thank you senator kerry senator rob
thank you mr chairman the essential
questions that concerned me earlier have
been answered but let me ask just one
question that might refine it
in terms of how we proceed from this
point forward
are you
confident
in
proceeding with the tools that are
available to you at the moment
which include the lack of subpoena power
in the cia context and the lack of
anything but administrative or to take
them subpoena power for the justice
department that if you proceeded
and ran into obstacles that you could
not overcome
that by proceeding now without uh
requesting additional tools at the
outset that you would prejudice any
result
or
activities that might be required to be
taken down the line in other words do
you
incur any risk
by proceeding with the tools that are
now at your disposal i i have some
measure of confidence in the tools that
i have at my disposal and i'm certainly
prepared to recognize limits on them i
do not i believe that given the
assessment that i have now the tools
that we do have versus the risks of
going forward and when i ultimately may
conclude that we can't go far enough i
think the risk is is relatively small
and i think the public interest is in uh
permitting me and mr hitz separately to
go forward
mr hitz i think senator rob that i can
get the tools that i need
to do it and i can assure this committee
and assure you personally that if i
don't you will know about it and i don't
think the point that you raise by not
being able to
foretell all that we'll need at the
present time is prejudicial as far as i
can see i mean we have for example we
can't reach former employees
the classification power uh
belongs to the director of central
intelligence not to us but with respect
to that he director deutsch has made it
clear that he wants to declassify this
he wants a public record on this as much
as he can and we're going to hold him to
it and you'll know uh
if he uh
he will be the first to tell you if he's
got a problem
thank you mr chairman i would suggest
that perhaps uh
and this is consistent with your uh
request for a finite or specific
timeline that uh
some regular interim reports about
progress to the committee not in
not as extensive as a full interim
report by any means but simply a an
indication of progress and
the availability or lack of availability
of necessary tools or resources to
continue the project uh in accordance
with the timeline that is is has been
generally agreed to ie as
to proceed as rapidly as possible to
come to a factual conclusion uh would be
uh appropriate uh i have no further
questions
thank you very much senator rob i think
we do have to
maintain continuing oversight as to what
is going on here
one of the options of the committee is
to run the investigation ourselves
and
that is a difficult thing to do
for a lot of reasons but
i have grave reservations as we've
expressed them and senator kerry has
senator rob raises the question about
how we're going to do it
as to whether you have sufficient
authority
and the brutal fact of life is that even
when congress when committees
ask the executive branch to disclose
materials it is very very difficult
somewhere between very very difficult to
impossible to get them disclosed
in a timely manner mr bloom has
testified about that and i could tell
you
war stories about it which which support
it
and we have a matter here which is very
very important a lot of public concern
and justified public concern that it is
a part of the overall skepticism about
what goes on in government
in this room we had last year the
hearings of the militia brought the
militia in to find out what was
troubling america to lead to the growth
of millions of people in the in the
militias
and we've had the instances in guatemala
which this committee has gone into we've
talked about the ruby ridge hearings and
it was really important
that the american people have confidence
in what
is being done by way of oversight and
that is a job for congress or job for
members to do
and exercise the maximum leverage we
have some some tools that you don't have
we have the power to hold up
confirmations
we also have the power to hold up
appropriations
we look for comedy within the executive
branch of the legislative branch and
very often we do not get it there are
quite a number of matters just like that
on my mind
at this moment
so we would press you both mr hitz and
mr bromwich to
go back to the drawing boards and define
the scope of your inquiry
analyze your resources and to come back
to us with with the game plan
uh and and we will uh have to
participate in the game plan and we
obviously have the authority to proceed
with our own
with our own hearings both in closed
session and in the
in open session but i think this has
been a very a very useful proceeding and
summarizing to some extent what we now
know
and to give as positive assurance as we
can to
people in this room and people who are
looking at what is going on here that we
are determined to get to the bottom of
it and we will that concludes our
hearing thank you all very much
you
[Music]
[Music]
our coverage of state races continues
tonight at 9 00 pm as we bring you live
coverage of two debates from manchester
control policy
and later a hearing on what's known as
gulf war syndrome
[Music]
and now from los angeles cia director
john deutsch
friday he talked about the allegations
of cia involvement in cocaine
trafficking to residents of this
california district
represented by democrat juanita
millander mcdonald
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen
good afternoon
thank you so much for adjusting your
schedules to be here this afternoon and
we welcome you
to the 37th congressional district's
people's town hall meeting
i would like to ask you to
stand
as i ask
dr william s epps
the pastor of second baptist church my
church to come and give the invocation
let us pray
lord we pause to acknowledge and
recognize that there is a source
for every good and perfect gift
and the giver of every
life
so we pause to reflect and remember that
you are the giver of every good and
perfect gift and you're the source of
our lives
we've been admonishing your word that if
we acknowledge you and all that we do we
have the assurance that you will direct
our path we've gathered here as a
community concerned about the crisis
which confronts us all
and we have brought someone here to help
us address an issue that's dear to all
of our hearts
we pray that we would have open minds
and open hearts as we probe
the depths of the concerns that trouble
us and cause our communities to be in
disarray
we're thankful for those who had the
vision and the foresight to pull us
together and to bring the necessary
parties here so that we could like
intelligent people sit down and resolve
our differences
and bring a resolution to the rift that
exists
in government and people
go with us now sustain us and keep us by
your power divine in jesus name we pray
this prayer and for his sake amen
i am juanita millander mcdonald
the representative of this area in
congress
this is a town hall meeting unlike ever
held before
for this town hall meeting allows the
south central community
to interact solely with the director of
central intelligence
an unprecedented moment in time
but then
the turn of events
over the last three months
have also been
unprecedented
for the last three months
this community and this nation has been
reeling from one of the most devastating
revolutions
to come before us
however
some community members living here will
tell you
that this startling news was not
shocking
while others will admit
it caused havoc
i cannot adequately express the anger
and disgust
with which these news reports
from the san jose mercury news
have been received by my constituents
there is no doubt
that all americans
regardless of their age
race
or economic status
who have been affected by crack cocaine
would agree with my constituents
that we need to uncover the truth behind
these reports
if the federal government
and those of us who are representatives
are to continue to hold the trust
of the people
we must be vigilant about our demands
for a comprehensive investigation
no matter where the trail
may lead
there is no single city
or congressional district in this nation
that has been spared the ravages caused
by crack cocaine
today we are in a community that was
already crippled
by the miseducation of our children
a lack of job training
and double-digit unemployment figures
that made survival difficult
at best
then on august 18 through 20th
came the shocking news reporters
paper
that the u s government
and more specifically the c i a
may have been involved in almost a
decade of introducing
financing
and distributing drugs
among the communities of watts compton
and all of south central
and that the profits from these
operations went to fund covert
operations in nicaragua
the mere idea that our government could
have
in any way
been involved in the distribution of
this horrendous drug
throughout our community is repulsive
since this news broke
i have tried to keep my community
informed as developments have been
available
while there is much we still do not know
we do know that lives have been lost
families
destroyed and babies continue to be born
at martin luther king hospital not
certain if they will ever have a normal
life
in running for this seat
i made a commitment to use this office
to restore hope
and opportunity to those who have given
up
and to use my power and influence
to empower my constituents
to ask questions
obtain answers
and work together to find solutions
i conceived of this town hall meeting
soon after my colleagues
in the congressional black caucus and i
sat
with the director of central
intelligence in september
i felt that it was important that my
constituents
and the broader community have an
opportunity to hear the director and
what he has to say about these
allegations i further wanted him to have
the opportunity
to respond to your questions
feel the depth of your concerns
and understand the need for a thorough
and comprehensive investigation into
these allegations
i am committed to seeing that this
happen
we live in an information age
and information is power
without it we are powerless
with it
and its effective application
our potential is unlimited
thus
town hall meetings like this one will
provide knowledge
and leadership
so that events such as drug trafficking
will not happen in the future in our
community
i hope you will engage
the director in a respectful exchange of
views
use the time wisely by posing concise
thoughtful
and provocative questions
lastly let me say that these are
challenging times
and i am charged with the challenge of
bringing my community back
i in turn challenge each of you to help
me
as we turn the corner on this issue and
begin to rejuvenate our community
as i outlined in my congressional
hearing
i plan to bring job training and jobs to
our community
to increase child care for our teen
mothers to help them gain jobs and
self-esteem
to counsel those who have befallen to
drugs and gain violence
to give special medical attention to our
babies who have been affected by the
drug use of their mothers
to address the disparity in drug
sentencing
and to build an enormous base of support
for each of us in our community
i have sought the assistance of federal
officials such as the drug czar
upon whom i have called to convene a
community-based task force
in which select members of the community
can try to address the pressing issues
caused by crack cocaine
and this crisis
and to get first-hand information on the
investigations as they unfold
i ask that we all keep an open mind
until all of the investigations are
completed
and the evidence is in
as we are all aware that the integrity
of our justice system
is at stake
also
it is not up to us to prove
the c i a was involved in drug
trafficking in south central los angeles
whether or rather
it is up to them to prove that they were
not
thank
[Applause]
you would like to now ask my colleagues
who have been with me through these two
congressional inquiries and town hall
meeting
to come
and extend greetings and say a few words
first
the senior member on the permanent
select committee on intelligence
congressman julian dixon
[Applause]
thank you very much thank you very much
congresswoman mcdonald
i have a very few remarks to make today
because i think the opportunity is for
us to dialogue with the director here
mr director i would like to thank you
for coming to the community
to hear firsthand from constituents from
all over southern california as their
concerns about the activities of the cia
i think it goes without question that
drugs particularly in the minority
community have been devastating but the
question is whether the united states
government has been involved in any
direct or indirect way
you certainly know that some of the
activities of the cia of the past for
which you were not responsible nor in
the agency at the time
you must bear the burden of the chore of
overcoming those past bad deeds
and so i congratulate you for having the
courage to come but most important i
think you should address the citizens
here as to what your intentions are as
it relates to an independent
investigation
thank you juanita for inviting
congresswoman harmon and myself and we
look forward to working with you
and secondly
no matter what the justice department
finds or what the
independent
inspector general of the cia i think it
is responsibility of congress
collectively and the house intelligence
committee similarly
to come forth with an open report that
all of you will be able to challenge and
criticize and so i look forward to
working with you in that endeavor
juanita and thank you once again
director deutsch for being here today
[Applause]
and now a strong supporter and colleague
of mine who also serves on the permanent
select committee on intelligence
congresswoman jane harmon
[Applause]
thank you very much juanita and welcome
everyone i am very pleased to join my
congressional neighbor friend and mentor
julian dixon and our rising star your
representative juanita melender mcdonald
at this precedence setting hearing
as you know it is the second such
hearing that has been convened in this
district uh i was proud to attend the
first one as well
let me point out how extraordinary it is
to have the cia director here
i doubt that any of john deutsch's uh
predecessors would have come to such a
meeting
but i'm not at all surprised that he is
here
he is a man i've known over 20 years
since our days in the carter
administration in washington
and who means what he says
and who delivers when he says he'll
deliver
so i suggest to you that
while there are good reasons uh
for a bad history between this community
and the cia
there are good reasons
to place your trust in the members of
congress who are here whom you know well
and in this cia director
who has a long history of concern about
the inner cities as a member as a
trustee of the urban league and also as
a member of the massachusetts governor's
economic development council and who has
a long history
of doing precedent setting things and
delivering when he says he'll deliver so
i'm honored to be here
i salute juanita for her leadership and
i salute john deutch for his thank you
very
[Applause]
and much introduce the director of
central intelligence let me just do a
few housekeeping matters
there will be
the 37th congressional district staff
that will be using the mikes to robe the
audience
randomly selecting participants with
questions
please wait until i call on you to ask
your question or make a brief statement
that statement must be brief as the time
is short the director will be leaving to
go overseas
following the 37th congressional
district's town hall meeting
please remain in your seats until the
director and members
of congress
have left the stage
if you must leave the auditorium before
we are finished it is a possibility that
you cannot return back or be readmitted
finally
ted koppel of abc nightline will be
moderating a segment of this show after
a brief intermission
you are welcome to remain for this
additional opportunity to share your
views to a national televised audience
and so we do ask that you do remain
seated though until the director has
left
it is without a doubt
this is unprecedented
when i called the director of central
intelligence
i
just knew from talking with him that he
would try to make every effort
to come
and to hear you and to listen to you
and to try to answer your questions
i am very pleased that he accepted to
come
i am with jane harman that perhaps
others would not have come
he chose to come
the director of central intelligence was
sworn in as director of central
intelligence on the 10th of may 1995
18 months ago
following a unanimous vote in the senate
in this position he heads the
intelligence community
all foreign intelligence agencies and
the united states
and directs the central intelligence
agency
mr dorch previously previously served as
the director as the deputy secretary of
defense
since march 1994
and earlier served as under secretary of
defense for acquisition and technology
he graduated from amherst college with a
ba degree in history and economics
as well as earned both
a bs
degree in
chemical engineering
and a phd degree in physical chemistry
from mit
i cannot tell you how pleased i am to
have you
have the opportunity to talk to the
director of central intelligence please
join me in welcoming mr john dortch
[Applause]
[Applause]
off times i have been in audiences where
i did not like the speaker
but the one thing i did do was give him
or her respect
[Applause]
this has been a long haul
wait just a minute
wait just a minute wait just a minute
wait just a minute
wait just a minute i have not asked you
anything
but i have asked i have only asked you
to have respect
wait a minute wait a minute
i have oh thank you he was not there
when this was going on anyway
[Applause]
i have asked you to please
give the respect of this congresswoman
[Applause]
you must recognize that we did not have
to do this
wait a minute wait a minute
we did not have to do this
we could have continued to allow you to
not see the face of the person who is
going to launch this investigation not
knowing what he's going to do how he's
going to do it but i saw the need for
him to come so that you can raise those
questions
we have just gotten over a very
difficult election
i have to take a red eye out tonight to
washington to start your work
thank you very much
so please
for the sake of our community
if you don't want to give the respect
then you might want to exit at this time
[Applause]
let us now receive
mr dortch
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you congresswoman mcdonald for
holding this public meeting
for giving me the opportunity
to talk with members of this community
about charges
that the cia
introduced crack cocaine
into south central los angeles in the
mid 1980s
thank you principal webb for allowing us
to use this high school
i'm going to be brief
i want to make four points and only four
points
first
the people the central intelligence
agency
and i
understand the tremendous harm
that drugs do to americans the drugs due
to families and communities and the way
drugs kill babies
we understand
how ravaging drugs are to this country
cia employees and i
share your anger at the injustice and
lack of compassion that drug victims
encounter
second point i want to make to you is
the following
the c i a is fighting to stop drug lords
from bringing drugs into the country
for example in the mid 80s at the same
time the allegations that are being made
here about the cia bringing drugs into
los angeles the cia was helping
bring down the drug lords in the
medellin cocaine
cartel in colombia
during the past two years while i have
been director of central intelligence
our case officers intelligence
operations have directly worked to
capture all
all of the kali cartel drug lords we
have seriously disrupted the movement of
cocoa paste between the growing areas of
peru and bolivia to the cocaine
processing facilities in colombia and we
have seized huge amounts of heroin grown
in the poppy fields of south west asia
our purpose
is to stop drugs from coming into the
united states
so my second point to you is
that the cia is fighting against drugs
now our activities are secret
and accordingly there is not a lot of
public understanding of what we do
i understand that people are suspicious
of the cia
in the course of recruiting agents to
penetrate doug cartels
to break up
those groups that bring drugs to the
united states
our case officers our men and women
deal with bad people very bad people
sometimes at great risk to their lives
these are criminals with which we must
deal if we are going to stop drugs from
coming into the country
they frequently lie about their
relationships with us for their own
purposes
so it is hard for the members of the
public to know what's true and what is
not true
now we all know that the u.s government
and the cia supported the contras of
their efforts to overthrow the
sandinista government in nicaragua in
the middle eighties
now it is alleged the cia also helped
the contras raise money
for arms by introducing crack cocaine
into california
it is an appalling charge it is an
appalling charge that goes to the heart
of this country
there's a charge that cannot go
unanswered
it says that the cia
an agency of the united states
government founded to protect americans
helped introduce drugs and poison into
our children and help kill their future
no one who heads a government agency not
myself or anyone else can let such an
allegation stand
i will get to the bottom of it and i
will let you know the results of what i
found
i have ordered an independent
investigation of these charges and the
third point i want to make to you is to
explain the nature of the investigation
i have asked the cia inspector general
to undertake a full investigation
he is the right official to do so for
the following reasons
first the inspector general is
established by law by law of congress to
be independent to carry out
activities to look for fraud and crime
within the cia
secondly the inspector general has
access to all cia records and documents
no matter how secret
third the inspector general has the
authority to interview the right people
fourth he is able to cooperate with
other government departments for example
the department of justice the dea the
department of defense all of which had
operations ongoing in nicaragua at the
time
and finally the inspector general has a
good track record of being a
whistleblower on past misdeeds in the
cia
for example just last month
he uncovered cia employees were misusing
credit cards and they are now in jail
in carrying out
[Applause]
in carrying out this investigation i've
asked
in carrying out this investigation i've
asked the inspector general to consult
with several groups
the house and senate intelligence
committee
two members of the house intelligence
committee congressman harmon and
congressman dixon are here today the
congressional black caucus and others to
build public confidence that this
inquiry is fair and thorough
your elected representatives will be
kept informed
most importantly when this investigation
is complete i intend to make the results
public so that any person can judge the
adequacy of the investigation
this investigation report of the
inspector general will be reviewed by
myself both intelligence committees of
the house and senate the president's
intelligence oversight board
anyone in the public who has a wish to
look at the report will be able to do so
and throughout this period of time we
will be cooperating with the ongoing
investigations that are underway in the
house and in the senate
i want to stress that i am not the only
person in the cia who wants a complete
and independent investigation of these
charges
our employees do not want any americans
to believe
that the cia was responsible for this
kind of disgusting charge
finally i want to say to you that as of
today
we have no evidence of a conspiracy by
the c i a to engage in encouraging drug
traffickers in nicaragua or elsewhere in
latin america during this or any other
period however i am going to wait and
see what the results are of this
inspector general's investigation
let me once again thank you for the
courtesy of listening to me my message
is simple the men and women of the cia
must obey the law and we are committed
to protecting american families from the
drug lords that poison our children
cia fights drugs cia does not encourage
drugs the independent inspector general
investigation that is underway will be
thorough and the results will be made
public and finally if any wrongdoing is
discovered we will pursue it and those
responsible will be brought to justice
thank you for your courtesy in listening
to me and i look forward to hearing your
questions thank you very much
okay thank you so much director dortch
the lady in the black and white uh
sweater was the first hand that i saw
i saw to go up
and then i will do the roving as i have
seen others i will if you will just be
seated
and raise your hands then we will see
you
thank you i'd like to know wait wait a
minute no well there's many black and
whites i'm sorry
this
this lady here
okay fine and then this one next sir i'd
like to know how this incident differs
from my school what happened at my
school at tuskegee university where for
20 for 20 years the government denied uh
inflicting syphilis among
african-american men until they were
they they died and then they agreed that
yes they had something to do with it so
for 20 years we were told the same thing
and these were able-bodied men who had
families that the government injected
syphilis into them as a test to see what
happened and they denied this for 20
years so i want to know how this differs
and i'm just deeply touched by this
because i attended tuskegee and it
affected a lot of that community and it
brought them down so i want to know from
you how what you're saying now differs
when the government said that for 20
years to the men were dead because we're
alive now let me ask you to state your
name and perhaps um
no i'm not going to do that because i
don't want to automatically get an audit
[Applause]
you know what
i respect
pardon me
i respect your right and you're right
but let us all respect each other's
rights
would like to answer that sir uh i'd
like to say two things uh first of all
uh 20 years ago uh those horrors took
place and i share
the revulsion about them i i i hate it
as much as you hate it but let me say
something else there was nobody who came
forward 20 years ago and said they were
going to investigate
just a minute please now the lady in the
um
black and white there
my name
[Music]
what can we do to make our city
[Applause]
the one thing that we can do may i
please answer you
i am charged to bring this community
back
it will take you and i to do that
we must first wait a minute we must
first
seek funding from the federal government
to help us restore this community
we must
charge them with the restoration of the
community
and the renewal of the family
that is what we must begin to do
and that nobody has spoken about a
solution
we need jobs look around you got all
these
wait just a minute wait just a minute we
can all we can all we cannot all speak
together please
let me say this
the minute this story broke
i first sent the letters the appropriate
letters to all of the agencies demanding
the investigation
but then after that
having been in the seat just five months
i began to develop a plan
the plan is what you're talking about
because we cannot wait on an
investigation to restore our community
we must begin to restore the community
right now and that's what i'm talking
about
the gentleman there in the back that's
by you sir
and then next will be you sir
mr deutsch could you please uh define
for us
the difference between
an operative
and an asset and do you have any of
these individuals working in the press
corps domestically and can you please
tell us do you know who walter pincus is
i i don't know that i can give you a
difference between operative and asset
uh i don't know what you're referring to
uh we have a policy
wait a minute
only ask the question because we're
trying to get as many people as possible
so let him answer that please
you might want to clarify wait a minute
if he said
that's fine
please please
i am conducting this meeting
i recognize that he wants to clarify
please sir clarify
is there a difference between a cia paid
operative and a cia paid asset
no
do you know who walter pincus is
i believe he's a reporter for the
washington post
sir you're not entitled to but why is he
an asset of the cia
no
he said no to that question the
gentleman in the white and then the
gentleman in the tent
had over here
my question is to you juanita and that
is the following
what is going to happen next are we
going to be at first ami church with
julio butler chair in the meeting is
that what's going to happen next juanita
this man coming into this community at
this time
as far as we are concerned most of us in
this audience is a mandate to close the
investigation and to prepare us for him
to say six months down the line that the
cia didn't do anything
how and my god who did you in your
constituency juanita did you uh consult
with to bring this man into our
community at this time what is going to
happen next anything that happens next
is terribly anticlimactic and you know
it
i am i'm
my other question is does maxine waters
endorse this meeting because i want to
tell you right now i'm a kglh listening
family i've been supporting everything
you've done up until today i can't
understand why you would bring this man
into this community and why you would
bring him my name is matthew dillon
[Applause]
thank you so much maxie
i represent 600 000 people i can't
attempt to ask everyone what my next
step should be
i did ask some of my constituents and i
think there are some constituents here
who appreciate this
director coming to this community
[Music]
uh ma'am if you were just allowed excuse
me sister excuse me
yeah i want i want to know if you think
that black folks are just tipping over
to colombia and low riders talking about
giving me 100 keys you know
all this is you know you sit up here
drinking your coffee your son probably
go to duke you know and y'all killing
babies bro with that [ __ ] you know
you sit up at the top of john do you
feel to do some investigation you know
white folks sailed across the pacific
ocean in 1866 when millions of slaves
raping torture kidnapped this is some
[ __ ] buddy
[Applause]
let me just say this
while i do know your anger and your
outrage please refrain from using
words such as what you've used
fine the next person will be joe walker
down here the lady next to him and then
the lady in the in the black and white
uh yes
uh
it's uh there's a lot of coincidences
in this investigation this cia deal
uh
i'm talking in the mind are the mics on
so that the audience can hear please
speak louder and speaking to them okay
what what i said there's a lot
there's a lot of coincidences
and i'm i'm
i've read things in the paper prior to
the uh
uh this uh
article coming out and afterwards
but have y'all looked into why
by the time that the cocaine and the
drug smuggling came over here
reagan
eliminated most of the air traffic
controllers
okay
and put bush
over the cia and other things there
why is that now the drugs is coming in
and we figure
that the cia helped
by allowing them to bring cocaine over
here
free transportation
when they take
the things over to take up okay when
they take uh
when they when they took supplies over
to the contra they brought drugs back
over without going through
without going through
radar or the uh inspection
but we are stopping at the cia but it
looks like
reagan and bush
had something to do with it
by
messing with the air traffic controllers
and allowing this to happen
please try to make your questions as
brief as possible so that we can get to
the people
director
purpose of the investigation that i
described to you
was exactly to find out whether cia
officers
allowed that kind of trafficking take
place knowingly or conspired to do so
that is the purpose of the investigation
if we find anybody who did it we will
bring him to justice
the lady uh wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait hold it
hold it hold it hold it
and yet the question was raised to me
why did i bring him here had i not
brought him here the questions and all
the people who hands her up would have
been denied questions so please allow us
to proceed with this question and answer
make your questions very brief the lady
in the in the grave
i thank you so much for being here
because we've needed this the drugs have
been coming in this country and they
have been sanctioned by our government
because when you talk to those basket
bushes
and that are black and white americans
who have served the united states of
america
they were drug
induced back then
they passed it on to their families
in baldwin village where i live
there are no jobs for the children
and our kids are commodities
they are being cycled through the
prisons they come back to the street and
they're marked and scarred for the rest
of their life
that's the pain of it
i know because i'm a mother of three
kids at 30 32 and 34 and i went through
there working to try to raise these
children
and bring them up two of them have been
in the military after serving in nuclear
submarines my son came back to the
street
and had no way to get a job in this
country that he served because he's
black
and now with children of being psycho it
has to stop the search and i hope that
you'll help to put an end to it because
we are tired and we're hurt and we're
angry
thank you
[Applause]
i hope you can understand as i am
if nothing else this is the beginning of
a healing process the lady in the black
and white and then the gentleman in the
jean jacket and then we're going over to
this side thank you very much
uh you said we only yeah i'll try to cut
it down because i do have a million and
one things to say but one of the things
i would be concerned about if i was the
director we've held
with the cold war we've held russia at
bay for 40 years at least
don't you feel kind of strange that we
can't hold a third world country at bay
that they have infiltrated
and they have infiltrated south central
l.a
this is a community with really no money
no power
and all of a sudden
these are not only drugs but arms
i was in the police academy all the
police officers here should be upset
because all of a sudden they gave we had
little guns like toy guns to play with
and these guys were coming out with
things that you know they were having
war over there forget the drug part
how did the guns get here
give us some explanations you you the
president and everybody else should be
highly upset
and say how
did this cancer get here
how did it happen
i've been here i've been coming here
giving lectures to these kids i left
these kids today
they are they are a bundle of nerves i
look at them i know their moms and dads
have been on crack cocaine they cannot
even sit in their seats
so make sure your statements are brief
are your questions please mr director
mr director
please allow the director to respond
you see
you're quite right
if we have to
we want to interdict drugs stop drugs
from getting to these shores
then you're going to have to rely on
all the skill
that we can mount in the government
whether it's from the central
intelligence agency
or the drug enforcement agency
russia could not even get here
third world countries are just walking
in just doing whatever they want
are you guys that incompetent
excuse me
wait just a minute
[Applause]
excuse me please
the more you applaud the more we will
use up the time here please allow all of
these folks who want their questions
asked and answered rather please allow
that to happen
sir in the jean jacket
yes
have you
looked into a a uh john hall who has
been named as a cia asset whose costa
rican ranch was used to run cocaine and
drugs
on behalf of the contras he was indicted
by the costa rican government with
oliver north just for this so this man
is i believe is a cia asset and uh have
you ever heard of this person named john
hole and will you look into this person
if you haven't
yes i know that uh the john hall and
john hall was listed in senator kerry's
senate foreign relations report in 1989
uh he was a a farmer in costa rica an
american farmer in costa rica that had
an airstrip on his property that was
used for drug trafficking and yes it
will be looked into
all right the lady in the purple and
then
he was not a cia asset
thank you so much for mr c.i.a official
for being here but i would just like to
ask you
how are we supposed to trust
the cia official to investigate
themselves
i mean we
we are having a problem with that
because
we we was told about so damn insane now
we wouldn't act so damn insane to
investigate his army to see if they was
making
uh uh uh
bombs if we did we would be in a hell of
a fix thank you
[Applause]
mr the inspector general
is
established by law
to look independently
about wrongdoing in the cia
that is what he's established to do to
look at wrongdoing in the cia
okay the gentleman in the navy blue
jacket steve over here and then the
gentleman in the burgundy after that how
are you doing i'm chico i'm ricky
and you guys wrote a
you guys wrote a declaration
to my judge saying it wasn't no
involvement how could you say there's no
involvement in an investigation ain't
over me and ricky ross is waiting to get
sentenced tuesday and she
what a judge gonna say to us come
tuesday
you wrote a letter saying there's no
involvement now you're up here saying
hey
what else to go to
so i want to know you know me everybody
in here think you know anybody in here i
don't know political reason or what but
i know me and ricky ross tuesday will be
getting sentenced
i don't know
i don't know what other people in here
doing but i know why i'm here and i know
what happened to me
uh may i just say that the question
which was asked of us by the judge was
was ricky ross
ever a agent or a contract employee
wait just a minute please let him answer
the gentleman who has the mic right now
well i was in court i'd be in court
every time there's a ruling and
everything because i'm part of it and
the judge asked the prosecutor to get a
written statement from you saying there
wasn't no involvement you guys wrote a
letter saying there's no involvement
then you come up here and say we it's
still going on so it's come tuesday the
judge gonna tell me oh it was it was no
involvement you get 20 years rick get
life so what are we supposed to do
if i could just i want to just be very
clear
uh please allow him to answer so that
you can hear his answer perhaps you
might have a question once his answer
has been stated i want to be very clear
the judge asked for an affidavit from
the central intelligence agency whether
any one of five individuals by name
had ever had any association with the
central intelligence agency let me
please let me finish first of all we
answered that question but it's a public
available answer the record of that
affidavit is available anybody wants to
see it and we found that none of the
five named individuals had never been
had ever had any association with a
central intelligence agency how come we
were able to do that i will tell you how
we're able to do that because we keep
very close records
on the people
just a minute i'm going to have to ask
that we dismiss those who are unwilling
and unable to listen to the others who
want questions answered
because we keep very close records of
those people with which we've ever done
business or who we're trying to develop
into doing
our assets so in the case of the
question from this judge it was
completely and thoroughly answered and i
want to stress that it was answered in
the public record but on that
declaration it does say
on that declaration it said
you know when manessa was and you guys
knew that he was involved 20 years ago
you see in the declaration said he was a
big wagon mafia
and you guys knew he was selling drugs
but you didn't arrest him you guys were
arresting for one kilo and go and then
gonna say men rick was had a hundred
kilos and didn't even have no cocaine
and he get five years rick looking at
life my first offense i'm looking at 20
and he he's on his way out and blandon
is out of jail and you pay them 166
thousand dollars
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
again we're trying to get questions
answered for your benefit and my benefit
up i'm sorry i'm sorry now
i have got to represent you and
washington i've got to know the answers
if you don't know the answers so please
let us have your undivided attention
the gentleman in the burgundy jacket
uh mr mr dortch are you finished with
your answer of the question that was
raised
[Music]
the question that the judge put to the
cia was whether blandon or any one of
four other individuals were ever
associated with the cia that question
was answered the answer's a matter of
public record it is absolutely the case
that glandone was a informant for the
dea that is a question though that which
the dea is answering not a question
which asks the cia
let me say this please let me say this
the director of central intelligence has
said this is a matter of
public record
if you want this record
call my office and i will see to it that
you have a copy of what the gentleman is
asking about
gary webb
the staff writer for the san jose
mercury news
he published
a search warrant on the internet
this warrant was issued to a special
narcotics squad of the los angeles
county sheriffs
and it was issued to search the home of
a lesser mr lasseter
who was a former police officer from san
diego
when this uh the sheriffs went to the
home
and went in presented the search warrant
this mr lasseter said hold it hold it
you better call cia headquarters in
washington
because
they're going to cure me
you better talk to a special agent
alexander because i'm working with him
okay now when there are epidemic court
documents that say that some of the
sheriffs had said that the evidence they
took from that home were put in the
evidence room and that the cia went to
the evidence room and consticated that
evidence and made it disappear the cia
took that evidence where is this
evidence that who is this mr alexander
special agent alexander of the cia who
cleared that mr uh lasseter who was
dealing with mr blandon
mr lasseter
was never associated with the central
intelligence agency he did not tell the
truth
all right the gentleman in the
pink shirt and then cal burke and then
this gentleman over here
yeah you can be next after i've gotten
these people here please please
wait a minute
wait a minute if you wish to
raise a question i will be coming back
across and i'll get those of you so
please sit down
and then as i come back across raise
your hand i see some of you and i will
already point you out as i come back
question is for across
director
my name is clinton bailey i'm an
attorney i'm also a member of baypac
an inspector general was not adequate to
investigate a suicide of a white house
official it was not adequate to
investigate the white house travel
office neither was the fbi
why is this uh investigation adequate to
be handled by an independent inspector
general
why shouldn't the independent council be
appointed by the president to
investigate these charges
there are there are two reasons
uh first of all we have a set of
allegations
uh none of which none of which are
specific enough to lead to a criminal
referral to the department of justice on
any particular investigation matter were
that the case there should be a separate
investigation secondly as i tried to
describe
as i tried to describe there are several
reasons why the inspector general is the
right place to begin
and all i'm saying is wait until you see
the inspector general report it's going
to be made public
so you can see whether it's adequate or
not but the inspector general has access
the inspector general has people
inspector general has the knowledge
about how to do these investigations the
inspector general is a good track record
those are all reasons for starting there
the problem with investigating the white
house on simple matters like the travel
office was the problem of public
perception this woman asked the question
before about public perception
acknowledging all these resources these
resources of the inspector general could
be used by an independent council in an
investigation why don't you turn it over
to an independent council
mr george you wanted to answer
do you listen
as i said before the reason for not
using an independent council is there's
been no criminal complaint filed here
okay fine
just a minute
just a minute
cal burton and then the gentleman next
to him and then i will come back across
now you have had an opportunity to raise
your question sir
cal burton from baypack
one of the chairpersons i have a
question mr deutsch you're a specialist
you're a specialist in chemistry and has
a phd in chemistry i'd like to ask you
this question first of all
the cia has been mentioned earlier is
investigating itself through the
inspector general back in the 70s and
the 80s charlie rango a congressman out
of new york was the chairman of the
oversight committee of drug enforcement
as well as the cia operations yet we
find ourselves in dire straits here in
the 90s i am asking and i think the
community is asking today
who are the black elected officials that
will be sitting on the committees and
have access to any knowledge of drug
sales
or other illicit activities undertaken
by the constituers and the cia so that
we can have specific input and so that
our people when they want to divulge
some information
won't go to the cia they'll go to our
people who will then pass it on to you
but we want to know today
who from the black elected officials is
it congressman uh julian dixon is it
going to be our beloved juanita mcdonald
we want a specific answer
[Applause]
congressman dixon will answer that thank
you uh thank you cal for answering the
question that you know the answer to
there was a meeting prior to this one of
elected and community leaders there's no
secret about that and i think juanita
mcdonald did a very good job for bay
pack and others in spelling out that she
would take the lead for this community
she feels that responsibility in
spelling out that the congressional
black caucus has started its own
investigation i spelled out that i am a
senior member of the house intelligence
committee and i pledge to you
and the other people in that room
that there would be a thorough
investigation but not only that that we
would make public disclosure of all the
supporting evidence that would support
our conclusion so i thank you for
answering that asking that question for
the rest of the people in the room
let me just follow up on what
congressman dixon has said
in addition to his being the senior
member who sits on the permanent select
committee on intelligence and will be
doing the independent investigation
outside of the cea inspector general
outside of the inspector general of the
department of justice the congressional
black caucus has appointed congresswoman
maxine waters is the chair
vice chair juanita mcdonald to launch
our own
investigation with congressman louis
stokes
heading up that investigation and going
back and looking to the records so there
are more than just two agencies
launching an investigation there are
numerous other investigations going on
when we get them all together we will be
able to discern who has really done an
in-depth investigation and who has just
really done an esoteric type of
investigation sir the man in the in the
leather jacket
i will be coming back over alcatel i am
a former los angeles police narcotics
detective and i work south central los
angeles and i will tell you director
deutsch emphatically and
further into the mic sir these mics
don't seem to be
i i will tell you director deutsch as a
former los angeles police narcotics
detective that the agency has dealt
drugs throughout this country for a long
time
[Applause]
all right
all right
all right obviously that is an answer
for a lot of you now can you please i
refer all right now can you please
i refer directly
wait wait
wait a minute
wait a minute
wait a minute here
wait a minute if you don't like what's
going on here please leave now
no no
no no no leave now because there are
others who do want to hear what's going
on in this room
will you please take your seats i will
come back to you as we roll back across
to the center section
[Music]
director deutsch i will refer you to
three specific agency operations known
as amadeus pegasus and watchtower i have
watchtower documents heavily redacted by
the agency i was personally exposed to
cia operations and recruited by cia
personnel who attempted to recruit me in
the late 70s to become involved in
protecting agency drug operations in
this country i have been trying to get
this out for 18 years and i have the
evidence my question for you is very
specific sir
if in the course of the ig's
investigations and fred hits his work
you come across evidence of severely
criminal activity
and it's classified will you use that
classification to hide the criminal
activity or will you tell the american
people the truth
[Applause]
all right you want to hear the response
first from congressman julian dixon and
then from the director
[Applause]
wait
wait a minute from york from your
i'm sorry
sir
i will allow the director to speak first
and then congressman julian dixon
if you have information
about cia illegal activity
in drugs
you should immediately bring that
information
to wherever you want but let me suggest
three places the los angeles police
[Music]
[Applause]
department please
i'm if i'm sorry others want to hear
this answer
i am sorry others want to hear this
answer it it is your choice
the los angeles police department the
inspector general or
office of one of your congress uh
persons from this
18 years
wait a minute wait a minute sir and sir
you have not gotten the mic yet you are
not but wait a minute then don't speak
out of turn let me say something else if
this information
turns up wrongdoing
if it turns up wrongdoing
we will
bring the people to justice and make
them accountable
all right congressman dixon
thank you uh thank you sir for coming
wait wait wait a minute here
i thought you did not want to be here
but now that you are here please let us
hear and listen
thank you very much
uh
sir i want to thank you for coming you
were at the last meeting uh the staff
probably had the spelling of your name
wrong but we
we would like to talk to you
we have been looking for a couple of
days for you
and we want to
[Music]
we we want to make sure that you contact
the committee because obviously you have
some valuable information
if you want to give it to me privately
if you want to hand it to that aid where
i can contact you this evening
please do it don't let us get away
without getting a contact for you
thank you sir
now so everyone can see that i got it
that would be fine thank you sir and for
the record for the record mike
please please keep the noise down so
that we can hear
and we can get answers for the record my
name is mike rupert r-u-p-p-e-r-t
i did bring this information out 18
years ago and i got shot at and forced
out of lapd because of it i've been on
the record for 18 years non-stop and
i'll be happy to give you congressman
anything that i have thank you
[Applause]
the gentleman in the beige shirt back
there in the back you sir who's looking
around
will you please get a mic to the
gentleman in the back right away
thank you congresswoman can you hear me
yes just talking to the mic please okay
is that better
my name is james otis i'm currently
making a documentary on the cia and
we're interviewing seven former agents
one was sent down to murder the head of
cuba fidel castro another gentleman
colonel phillip redinger was sent down
to guatemala to overthrow the government
of guatemala in 1954. the third agent
was actually a spy on iowa state
university campus where he spied on
students dark-skinned students
foreigners and people from other
countries he was then sent down to cuba
to poison the food supply in havana
poison the children of cuba for whatever
reason so we all i believe already know
this information mr deutsch my question
to you is if we know all of this stuff
that the agency has done historically
then why certainly should we believe you
today when you say certainly this could
never happen in in los angeles when it's
happened all over the world
[Applause]
i i'm not i underst i understand
that uh i am not going i did not come
here
thinking that everybody here was going
to believe me i came here for a much
simpler task i came here to stand up on
my legs and tell you
what i was doing to investigate horrible
allegations
all you can do is
listen to what i have to say and wait
and read the results but i did not
expect to come here and find everybody
applauding the remarks that i made but i
want you to know i've come here and told
you unlike the other cases that you've
mentioned
where there was nobody who came here and
told you there was no director of
central intelligence who came out and
told you there's going to be an
investigation that's something
all right please please
have you finished mr dork
all right fine this gentleman here in
this jacket over here sir you've had
your time once i think this one right
here uh stephen the white jack whitehead
okay fine thank you you'll be next uh mr
deutsch uh you and the dea's uh former
um director had a conflict and he
resigned what happened to that ton of
cocaine that you were supposed to be
watching coming from both of colombia
i don't know what you're referring to
sir
uh there was a conflict between the dea
and the cia whereas you guys were
watching a ton of cocaine flying out of
bogota of columbia for a sting operation
the director of the c.i.a didn't agree
on your tactics and you superseded him
and went over and he resigned the form i
don't know his name but the former dea
director the one who just resigned
because you wouldn't give him the
information on the ton of cocaine that
you were supposed to be watching coming
from bogota colombia whatever happened
to the ton of cocaine
i don't know the case you're referring
to i just don't know the question
okay fine the young man there the one
that's right excuse me can i just say
something no no no you have to wait your
turn and after that i'll come to you
i'll come back to you i'll come to you
after this one
excuse me um
this young man is waiting to be heard
throughout my life very uncomfortable i
have um a question for you guys you're
talking about the south central you come
down here with all your cameras and your
meters and all these the police
department you just throw out our
neighborhood killed our kids my brother
a lot of other kids i put together a
proposal for anybody that want to come
and help our kids we need a media we
need cameras right in the heart of south
central letting these kids know that
they are loved and they need they got
somebody want to take care of them
okay we have a lot of talent here
we have a lot of hard-working people in
this community that's working with these
kids that's on drugs that you guys never
talk to
okay it's time for y'all to bring the
cameras back to our community and let
everybody in other part of the world
know that we are
all not on drugs we are not gang bangers
we are not murderers give the kids
that's trying to make a difference a
chance anybody want to challenge this i
have put together a budget and a
proposal very very cheap okay for a
national televised tv show
key in on this
thank you
thank you so much
if for nothing else
we have brought the cameras in for this
young man to state what he just said
well do you want to give me that
proposal young man please to my staff
all right i'm coming back over with the
the young man in the stripy shirt i told
him he would be next
then we're coming back we're coming back
as soon as i get him i'm coming to you
good evening mr douche did you cut the
mic on
douche
mr duke deutsch my name is malik
spellman
i'm formerly a news reporter for fox
races news first of all
second of all
i'd like to say this as a former street
chemist you know and i know that there
are certain chemicals that's required to
break down the derivatives in cocaine
will mobile gasoline be brought up on
charges for supplying these chemicals to
the nicaraguans for their access to the
cocaine and breaking it down and second
of all
how fair does this here particular story
or should i say how does this story that
you're bringing us square with the
illuminati society that we have today
and third of all can i ask you in the
name of god to please take hands off
minister farrakhan so he can raise us up
[Applause]
any comments
[Music]
all right
i think yours was more of a statement
young man than a question
no no you were you were given the mic to
i thought to raise a question you guys
are going to have to raise questions if
you want answers because you're the time
is going what is your question sir
is mr john
you the person you are as the traveler
that you are will you be able to stand
here on the square and tell us that you
wholeheartedly support the rebirth of
south central
yes
thank you
this gentleman right here in the blue
shirt
director deutsch i have a very simple
way
that you can prove to us
that you intend to get to the bottom of
these
allegations
and that is
the cia in 81
was overrided
under the reagan administration when
president ronald reagan signed executive
order 12333
he set up a parallel government headed
by george bush for which ali north also
worked and they privatized u.s
intelligence
for example the gentleman that he
brought up weekly not alexander but
weekly
who scott weekley who was said by the
government to not be involved with the
government it turns out he was involved
in a private operation
as part of what's called the bush
asteroids but that you have a private
network run by george bush and ollie
north not the cia you won't find the
records in the cia they're not there
they're in these private
privatized intelligence agencies will
you pursue that will you pursue ali
north and george bush and the ev the
massive documentation
you're all these gentlemen like this
gentleman here the co-defendant of ricky
ross ricky ross is doing george bush's
time
okay
all right
fine i will have to tell you because
i cannot get some type of
of leverage here uh um
and some type of quietness here
i'm gonna have to just take four more
questions
so that i can then
you are you are not responding to me
you are not responding to me at all
therefore i cannot respond to you
the gentleman in the back back there the
one who hasn't
i will instruct
our
inspector general to investigate any
allegation in this matter that is
brought forward
if you bring forward an allegation to me
i will see that it's investigated
[Applause]
okay okay hey
one second one second please
sir one second please that was intended
for the guy in the khaki jacket and then
you are next the one who has the mic at
this time can i go ahead and go and have
the mic now
all right fine fine if you've agreed to
that thank you very much
please quiet one second first of all i
have to let everybody knowing here the
only reason that we're getting this
information is because we live in an
information age and we're getting it
through the internet there's gary webb
in the house the first thing i want to
ask is gary webb in here
gary webb is a reporter for the san jose
mercury news who broke the story wide
open and my suggestion is simple
allow gary webb to have full access to
the uh the investigator general's
full documentation and as he goes
through the process of investigating
them allow gary webb to be there along
with him to investigate along with him
with his documentation and comparatively
go through it as the investigation goes
on that's it that will solve this
point blank we want to be here yelling
and we'll have a representative of us
who actually broke the story there on
top of it from the beginning to the end
thank you
[Applause]
the report will be made available to all
members of the media when it's completed
um sir once the report has been
established you will not have a meeting
behind closed doors you will have a
public meeting on that
all right uh please
yes yes
sir
[Applause]
sir you and then the lady who's been
over here with this this sweater this is
what i want to say yes
my name is joey johnson i'm a
revolutionary activist against police
brutality in los angeles the first thing
i want to say is i don't know why dixon
is saluting deutsche's courage for
coming here today when everybody knows
this building's got hundreds of pigs in
it there's pigs behind those curtains
pigs on top of the roof is trained
assassin
so what courage are you talking about
this whole thing is orchestrated this
whole thing is orchestrated and then
they're going to say oh the public got
to say their mind we know that the
deutsche's first point was that he
understood the terrible pain that these
drugs had inflicted they also understood
the terrible pain that the countries
were inflicted on the villages in
nicaragua where they were bombing the
harbors murdering peasants and they used
the conscience to destabilize nicaragua
and they use the crack that they brought
back on those planes to destabilize
south central and destabilize the youth
here because ever since and especially
since the la rebellion in 1992 they know
what these youth can do if they go in a
revolutionary direction against the
system instead of being beaten up and
beaten down and brutalized by this
that's the second thing the drugs and he
turned around and incarcerated these
youth when are the doors gonna open and
all the kids that were convicted on
these racist crack laws what are they
gonna walk out of those prisons when
it's not going to happen we're not going
to get no justice here today we're going
to need a revolution to sweep all this
way and really get some justice and that
game then these things like to see
exactly wait wait wait wait wait wait a
minute
you cannot just hog that mic like that
sir you're gonna have to ask your
question make your statement or whatever
now i gave you an opportunity to speak
and now you're yelling out you know you
know better than that you know better
than that
all right just a minute
i would like to have richie ross's uh
brother to speak please
curious right here
uh yes um thank you please cut into the
mic sir thank you uh senator dart i
would like to ask you a question
um on national tv on espn you made a
statement to the senators that was
asking you certain questions about the
cia
in return these are the words that came
out your mouth the senator asked you
how long
do you think that it would take you to
do your investigation
and you replied sir
60 days
60 days
how can you do
evaluation on an investigation of
cocaine in 60 days and you can't even
stand here and tell these people
that the united states government turned
their head and let this cocaine come
into the united states of america
we are sick and tired of your excuses
that's an excuse that's the cop-out
because if you can go over to
kuwait
if you can go over to vietnam
and you can go all these other places
and start a war
you can control this dope war
[Applause]
all right i promised a lady over here
who's been standing for a long time i'll
give her the mic over there
all right
first of all i have a sad commentary
all right
first of all i have a very sad
commentary to make
i lost a wonderful grandson who was
perfectly innocent i want to preface
this
perfectly innocent
through
a
drug dealing the gang wars fighting over
territory and whatnot and my my grandson
was totally innocent but he was slayed
and i'll take that pain to my grave the
pain that that this kind of stuff is
brought about but mainly i want to know
how can we know
how many uh
viable documents have been shredded
and how can we be
uh
certain
that more documents won't be shredded
[Applause]
i don't know that anybody has found any
loss of documents in the operational
files which involved the directorate of
operations
activities in latin america during this
period of time i know nobody has found
any gaps in any sequences any missing
files any missing papers from any of
this period of time that may come up if
so will be pursued but right now in the
written record there's absolutely no
indication that anybody's fiddled with
it
i will only take
two more questions it will be the lady
over here in the beige blouse and the
gentleman who has the white cap on
let me ask
you let me ask you is terry watkins in
the house
all right
this young woman here and then the
gentleman here i think it's pretty
evident that the sentiment of in this
room is that of pain anger and
especially that of mistrust i must echo
a lot of the statements that have been
made regards to the way that you're
conducting you're going to conduct this
investigation how can we feel
comfortable with an investigation that's
going to be conducted by someone who's
on the government payroll to investigate
the cia and his wrongdoing i think what
we also need to consider is if the con
if the congressional black caucus is
going to conduct an investigation at the
end which one is going to be the one
that's going to be accepted by the
administration
it's going to be the one that's that's
going to be the one favoring
the cia
and i believe that what we need to do is
have a joint effort as opposed to one
investigation
being conducted on one end and another
one being conducted on another because
we're not going to have any justice
prevail
sir sir
[Music]
sir
sir
[Music]
[Music]
wait
wait no no
wait a minute you get out of here if you
cannot if you have to use that language
you leave out of this auditorium sir i'm
not going to allow you to use this
language in my community
i'm sorry anyone who uses that type of
language does not deserve that answer
that's fine sir
that might be fine sir but you're happy
wait a minute wait wait wait a minute
wait a minute
i did not disrespect you for one time
and you are not going to disrespect me
to your today's server
sir over here in the white cap
yes uh turn the mic up please
could you turn up the mic please so i
can okay please turn the mics up so this
gentleman can get his question with all
due disrespect sir mr deutsch who is the
head of the chemical weapons research
before you got this job is that not
right
you were the head of chemical weapons
research for this for the military
is that is that now correct i was deputy
secretary of defense and you were in
charge of chemical weapons that were
used in this in the gulf war is that not
correct
that's incorrect is that incorrect yes
okay
that's incorrect and it's also is this
it also correct that the oss
which was started by
wild bill donovan and reinhard galen in
the 1940s when the nazis were brought
over here in operation paperclip
excu hey could you let me finish please
you see
you see you coming in this community
today in this way
is nothing more than a public relations
move for the white people of this
country because you know as well as
everyone else that the cia has been
dealing drugs throughout the world and
bringing drugs into this country since
vietnam's war you brought them in here
in body bags you were in the golden
triangle so you're going to come in this
community and insult us and tell us that
you're going to investigate yourself you
got to be crazy
[Applause]
it is now time for me to close wait no
no no no no no no no no no
no wait a minute no wait a minute
wait a minute no no wait wait
i cannot get mad
wait just a minute here i'm sorry
i am sorry
wait a minute
wait a minute wait a minute
wait a minute wait a minute
wait a minute
i would like to thank
or he just told the director of central
intelligence
mr don george
you're right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i would like to thank the director of
central intelligence for being here
today
i would like to also thank my colleagues
congressman julian dixon and
congresswoman jane harmon
can i say a word i would like to thank
the community for being here today
[Applause]
i would like to thank the community for
being here today
and hopefully some of you got
if not all of you got your questions
answered can i say a word
i will not have the director of central
intelligence to make his last remarks
[Music]
sorry
you know what i hear your cry i hear
your cry wait a minute wait a minute
i have just been i have just wait a
minute wait wait wait wait wait
wait a minute
wait a minute
wait a minute
i do hear your cry
i understand you are tired of crying
i've just gotten here five months i will
be willing to work with you
and with you
too
i will have
i will work i will work with
will work with those of you who are
willing to work with me
now may i have the director of central
intelligence to say the last words
thank you
thank you for uh
thank you for uh letting me come here
today
uh
you know i have uh
i've learned something
i've learned how important it is uh
for our government and for our agency
to get on top of this problem and stop
it
i just want to say uh
that i came today to try and describe
the approach that i'm taking the
approach that i'm taking
to
address these serious charges but i go
away
with a better appreciation of what's on
your mind and i go away with a
conviction
that we're going to do more to stop
drugs from coming into the united states
thank you very much
[Applause]
later today at about 2 20 national drug
control policy director barry mccaffrey
discusses president clinton's drug
control policy during remarks at
american university in washington d.c
turning to tomorrow at 10 a.m eastern
time 7 pacific we'll have live january
9th
okay thank you for joining us thank you
it's about 10 o'clock here in washington
we're going to go now to the heart
building on capitol hill where the
senate select committee on intelligence
is about to
hold the hearing concerning allegations
of c.i.a contra drug trafficking this is
a
follow-up to those stories that we have
been hearing about concerning part of
the inner cities america the man on the
left side of the screen with his back
sort of to the camera there is arnold
inspector there he is right there with
the white handkerchief
he's a republican of pennsylvania
chairing this committee some of the
other members there
the man who just walked out of the
screen to the left is adolfo calero the
former contra leader and we're also
going to hear from aiden pastora the
former southern front leader and that
looks like why you say
the former maryland congressman who is
now head of the naacp so this uh hearing
should be starting in just a couple
minutes we'll look on as they get ready
used
so
the committee will now proceed
mr calero and mr prestor we appreciate
your uh being with us if you take your
chairs
the
hearing of the senate select committee
on intelligence will proceed
on our
inquiry
into
the allegations of possible connections
by with the cia on the
sale of narcotics in
west los angeles
on the allegation of use of funds to
support the contras
in the nicaraguan war
these hearings have been prompted by
a series of articles which recently
appeared in the san jose mercury news
on these allegations and the
committee thought it was important to
pursue these matters to determine
whether there was any substance to them
we proceeded on october 23rd with
testimony from the inspectors general of
the
cia and the
department of justice
and also mr jack bloom who was counsel
for a senate subcommittee which made
a similar inquiry in the late 1980s
the
san jose mercury news identified
a number of individuals
as
being involved in the drug trade and of
having possible connections with the cia
and we have
proceeded to try to determine
uh
what the evidence is and what the what
the facts are
mr norwin meneses who was a key figure
mentioned in the series of articles
is in a jail in nicaragua on
drug convictions and to this moment has
declined to cooperate with the committee
another individual
rick ross has recently been sentenced
had been in detention in a san diego
jail
and we are making efforts to contact him
a committee yesterday in closed session
uh took uh
from
mr blandon for about an hour and a half
senator dewine and i
did
and uh we are seeking the testimony
of certain key members
from the cia allen fryers and
dwayne
dewey clarets which we have not yet been
able to obtain
and our
committee is proceeding
although there are independent
inquiries being undertaken by the
inspector generals of inspectors general
of the cia and the department of of
justice
we may yet have mr bland and testify in
an open session but for the time being
we proceeded to take his testimony
in a closed session that at his request
and for purposes of the record i will
summarize what mr blandon testified to
he
described how he met
norman manesses in california in late
1981
became involved in drug trafficking as
he put it out of the desire to earn
money for the contras
mr blandon testified that he was active
at the time in
local efforts to secure support for the
nicaraguan resistance and these efforts
included
organizing fundraising parties and
political rallies
according to mr blandon he accepted
manessa's proposition to sell cocaine
in los angeles because he wanted to make
more money for the contras
mr blandon told the committee
that he had a difficult time breaking
into the market because he had no
previous experience selling cocaine
he testified that prior to
late 1982 or 1983 he sent the profits
from the drug sales less his own
expenses to mr meneses
who according to mr blandon was
providing
assistance to the contracts
mr blandon testified that when he
suffered his ties with mr meneses in
late 1982 or
1983 he owed mr meneses 100 000
at this point mr blandon testified that
he went in the business for himself
his association with the contra support
group in california ceased
and according to his testimony none of
the proceeds from his sale
of cocaine went to the funding of the
contras
it was at this time that blandin began
selling cocaine as he put it to freeway
ricky ross
mr blandon stated that he did not share
profits from his cocaine sale
to ross with the contras
and it was for this narcotics
trafficking that mr blandon was arrested
and convicted and spent
28 months in jail
the one exception to mr blanson's
continuation of support for the
conquerors was his meeting
in 1994 with eden pastor military
commander of the contra southern front
where he
gave mr pastor six thousand dollars
and the use of a home in costa rica at
least according to the testimony of mr
blandin
the total amount of
funds which he channeled to the contras
according to his testimony was between
sixty thousand
and sixty five thousand dollars
in direct in response to direct
questions from the committee mr blandon
stated
that he had never had any contact with
the cia
and that the cia was not involved in his
drug trafficking business in any way
he also testified that the contra
organization officials with whom he met
such as enrico bermudez and eden pastor
had no knowledge
of his involvement in drug trafficking
and that he never discussed with them
the idea of selling cocaine as a way to
make money for the conference
this morning we are going to continue
our
testimony and hear from the
witnesses uh uh mr
uh calero is a businessman who was
recently elected to the nicaraguan
parliament
in 1983 mr calera became a member of the
directorate of the nicaraguan
democratic force fdn
and soon became its president and
commander-in-chief
prior to his joining the nicaraguan
resistance mr calero worked openly
against the regime of the former
nicaraguan
president
samosa and was jailed by the samosa
regime in
1978.
mr eden pastora also known as commander
zero was the sandinistas most popular
hero and a senior official of their
government until he distanced himself
from them
in 1981.
in 1982 he
publicly announced his opposition to the
sandinista regime
in 1983 he took up arms against the
sandinistas and became the
preeminent leader of the nicaraguan
resistance
the so-called southern front
after leaving the resistance he operated
a fishing cooperative in costa rica
returning to nicaragua
where he was a candidate for mayor in
this fall's national elections
i'd like to yield now to my
distinguished colleague
senator shelby thank you mr chairman
chairman i want to commend you as the
chairman of the intelligence committee
for convening this hearing and also
uh
making a public hearing there are so
many hearings that we cannot
make public but this is this is a
serious uh effort i believe on your part
to
to uh get to the truth on some serious
very serious allegations in dealing with
crack cocaine and a cia connection if
any
i look forward to hearing these
distinguished witnesses here today and
other testimony as we pursue this
interest on behalf of not only our
committee but the american people
well thank you very much senator shelby
to the
maximum extent possible whatever the
committee does on the subject will be
done publicly there's a great deal of
public concern about
about these allegations in
conducting these hearings as i said at
the october 23rd
uh hearing we do not uh
subscribe to or in any way support what
the
san jose mercury news has said nor do we
disagree with anything that they have
said our job is to make an impartial
determination as to as to what the facts
are
mr pastor and mr calero would you please
stand and so i can minister the oath to
you
raise your right hands
do you solemnly swear that the testimony
that you will give before the
senate select committee on intelligence
will be the truth the whole truth
and nothing but the truth to the best of
your knowledge information and belief
uh mr calero uh we will begin with your
testimony
uh would you
tell us
where you were born raised your early
education and your early
activities
i was born in managua nicaragua
december 22nd of 1931
into a family steeped
in the judeo-christian tradition
a highly
reputed
well-known
and
my
initial education was at home
my grandparents
my own home
then i went on to the christian brothers
school for grammar school
then on to
holy cross high school new orleans
when i where i finished in
1949
was there from 45 to 49
then
i entered the university of notre dame
in 1949
graduated
in
1953
and
lou holtz said last saturday his
farewell address
i mean the best thing that
could have happened or happened to him
had been that he had he's had his
children graduate from notre dame and he
spoke
of
notre dame's
morals
principles
and purpose
which is something i carry
with me very dearly
i worked in nicaragua
for
in central america for the
first five years after graduation then i
joined
with the
american company the wr grace peter
grace was the chairman of it
then i joined the
coca-cola battling company
and i was
hired as general manager and
and i was in that position for 24 years
until i
decided in 19 december of 1982
that
life in nicaragua
was impossible
that
my duty was to
see how
we could liberate nicaragua and that's
immediately after i left
i joined the what was called
the fdn nicaraguan democratic force
which was
dedicated
to
the ousting
of the sandinistas
which were
trying to
change
nicaragua
trying to deny our nationality
in the sense
that they did everything against our
culture our religion
our way of being
and so i joined the
what was called
the contras
and i was with the fdm
throughout
that operated in
northern nicaragua throughout
until
1989 i would say
how long did the active fighting go on
mr clara well the active fighting began
before i joined
the first
actual
impressive
action
was one in march of 1982
i was still in nicaragua
and uh were you involved in that
fighting
no no i i was i was connected with these
people i had uh contacts when you say
when you say connected what do you mean
by that
that i used to come to miami
and
visit
with
those that belong to the organization
that were in it
and exchanged views they were trying to
convince me to join
and i traveled to honduras to see
what was going on what they had who were
the who were heading the organization
what kind of people they were
and i did all this to to see if i i went
to costa rica too
where i remember having a meeting with
with ellen
pastora
and uh when was that meeting in 1982 and
where was the meeting in san
and
jose
purpose of the meeting the purpose of
meeting was to i was
i had decided to go and fight that i had
no alternative but to go and fight the
sandalistas and to fight him in the only
way that they could
understand that they wouldn't allow and
so
my trip to costa rica my trip to
honduras were to see where i was needed
where i could be of better service to my
country so after visiting both places i
decided that i could be of better
service in the north and that's where i
joined
and precisely what did your efforts
involve in the aid of the contra effort
well they needed
expertise
they needed
people who
had an education
who
had a reputation
who
could be trusted
and i seem to have
combined those
qualifications that they needed
and so i joined what was called the
directorate
which was a seven person directorate
and then
that was in january of 83 and in october
of 83
it was decided that there needed to be
one
person
in command
when the president
and as
happens in democratic countries this
president will be commander-in-chief of
the
armed forces and uh
and i was elected by my peer
to be such a person
he became the commander-in-chief of the
contra forces in october of 1983.
yeah
of the fdm of the nicaraguan democratic
force
uh
in october of 1983 did you have did you
have any battlefield activities in
connection with that position no sir my
activity was
practically
a political activity organization
authority
and
you had you had responsibilities to
raise money for the fdn well
when i first joined
we did not
need to raise any money
and there were no efforts made to raise
any money because we were being financed
by the united states government
by congressional
with congressional approval
i think there was a 14 million dollar
initial
output was the financing which you got
from the united states government
adequate
why did you have did you have enough
money i didn't it was never adequate it
was never constant
and it was an on-and-off situation
it was pretty unreliable i would say
well i i asked that from the point of
view of whether you made any efforts to
raise any money other than from the
official sources from the united states
government no at the time no
did you at any other time when we were
cut off
and it seemed that
it would be a while before we could get
u.s financing again
then we started thinking about uh
raising money
and you did you do more than think about
it did you actually try to raise more
money we were very fortunate
to have had a
a considerable contribution
from
i
later learned from saudi arabia
that gave us 30 million dollars when did
you when did saudi arabia give you the
30 million dollars well i believe it was
in 84.
and you did not learn about it at that
time well i
i learned about the 30 million because i
was asked to provide a bank account
where it could be deposited
and i had a
nicaraguan
friend was a lawyer who'd been a banker
and he
handled
all the
financial matters
on the other hand we started to contact
people
here in washington
who could help us out in raising
money
and
if i remember correctly there was a man
by the name of carl's pit channel
who handled
the the money racing activities
and uh carl channel and then some other
fellows who might don't remember
and then there was an organized effort
where we contacted
people like of mrs helen garwood from
texas a rich
lady from texas
mr joe coors
and
[Music]
a few other people who
donated
money for specific purposes for instance
how much how much money if you recollect
that they donate
well i i did not handle that money
i believe that channel raised through
mailings raised about a
million two hundred million four
thousand dollars that we got
i don't know how much he raised exactly
uh and uh then
mrs garwood donated a uh
the money for a helicopter that i don't
remember who bought it but the thing is
that we got it down there and mr cools
donated for a
stall airplane that is a short takeoff
and landing plane that we needed to uh
to rescue the wounded
testified about this 30 million dollars
from saudi arabia
uh you said you didn't know
that it was from saudi arabia at the
time no no
how is it that you could get such a
large sum of money and not know the
source
well
because
i heard
to begin with
the one who notified me about it was
colonel north oliver north
that i was going to get the money and
so right then and there i knew that it
was something
which was
an official
i would they send an official
of an official
uh request you know and then
i later colonel north told you about the
30 million dollars yes he said that we
were going to receive the amount of
money from a friendly government i
didn't tell you which government he
didn't tell me which government and you
didn't ask him no no i didn't ask him no
no why not
why not because
uh
no curiosity on your part about who's
giving you 30 million dollars no i
i suspect that it could be uh
some countries and i suspect it could be
it could have been taiwan it could have
been saudi arabia it could have been
kuwait
but you didn't ask what i didn't ask
them
and when did you find out that it was
saudi arabia
oh it came out in the papers
or
you didn't hear about it officially or
from colonel north not not that i
remember i mean i don't remember which
moment i learned it was saudi arabia
in connection with your duties as
commander-in-chief did you have contacts
with the cia central intelligence agency
oh yes at the beginning
but right at the beginning i did have a
contact with the cia i remember that
what was your initial contact with the
cia
on this matter
on any matter on any matter relating to
your duties this is commander in chief
of the congress on this matter
specifically because i knew cia people
from before
i mean uh i'm talking about your contact
with the cia
on financing of the contras effort in
the nicaraguan war
well with the cia we never talked about
financing because they were never
i mean the the only money that they uh
they did handle the money that was given
by the united states government
and uh it was through them
that it was received
and at first we used to get the money
from the argentine military who were
established in honduras and then the
contact
or the money
dealing and the
acquiring the materials we needed
everything was
with the cia once the argentinians left
well when
did the money come from the
argentinians as you put it the
argentinians
in honduras at what point in time
when i arrive when i first arrived in
early 1983 was the argent themes who
were in charge and how long did that
last uh only a few months and then it
was the united states that took cover
directly
and when the united states took over
directly as you put it
uh who handled it for the united states
uh the uh
the cia used to uh make payments i i uh
we had a threshold we had a man in
charge of financing
so i never did get any any money to pay
for it
for goods that were purchased in
honduras
did you have any personal contact with
anybody from the cia oh yes i knew who
did you deal with
the first
person was a agent in manawa
who requested that i come to washington
to meet
a very important person
in washington and that very important
person turned out to be the
the commander
in chief of the honduran military forces
who needed to know
what kind of people were going to be
involved in this operation
and
and he asked me are you going to be
involved and i said well
i have not come out of nicaragua yet
but
i
i am serious thinking about it
that must been in august of 82
and
i
i left in december
hondurans wanted to know if they were
responsible people and people who were
not tainted with somocismo
and who had
good
reputations
and because they wanted to to associate
themselves with people who were
responsible so on that occasion you met
with an official from the honduran
government yes going back to the
question as to
any of your contacts with the cia did
you have contacts with specific people
in the cia yeah well this man who was in
the car i don't remember the name now
is for once from the cia he was the one
who who
got this contact here
well
was it your understanding that he was in
the c.i.a
yes i mean he did not show me a batch
you know but
we knew
i mean
we knew in nicaragua that
in the u.s embassy the political
attitude or one of the political
attaches would always be
a man
working for
the
cia for u.s intelligence where did you
meet that man who identified himself as
being a honduran
thought you met him in the united states
oh you now
coming in the honduran the general
alvarez yes i met here in washington at
the watergate
hotel
and i also i don't want just one meeting
we had one meeting yes yes yes yes yes
yes
and then i also met
cia officials
here
some of them use
names that weren't necessarily theirs
how did you how did you know that the
names weren't theirs well because i
later learned what their real names were
what
names did they use
i i remember the first man who talked to
me a whole great deal
was called tony
did he have a last name no i don't know
i don't remember the last name and then
it turned out that he was someone else
what was his real name i don't remember
his real name because he left he was
just at the beginning then i met the
how many how many people did you meet
who didn't give you their real names
oh
my gosh
wayne clary's for instance
he went by another name when i met him
then i found out in the paper that he
was going clarice and wayne clarks
misrepresented his identity to you
he used another name what name did he
use i don't remember him i don't
remember did you meet alan friars alpha
alpharest he used another name too and
then we
with time i found out that he was all
fire soon
well let's start
with
duane dewey clarice uh
uh when did you first meet him as best
of your recollection
in miami
when
must have been in 1982
and where before i left specifically
where in miami at uh
at a hotel
uh
trying to think of the name of the hotel
but uh
and what was the purpose of that meeting
i would say they were trying to convince
me to get out of nicaragua and come out
and
and
help them out in this situation and what
did you say
well i said that i was inclined to do to
do it but that i wasn't ready for it yet
and what name did mr claridge use at
that time
i have it down some place in a few notes
that i but you're sure it wasn't doing
clearage as the name he used oh yeah i'm
sure
i'm yeah i'm sure he wasn't
that mean
sure he didn't use his right name no no
no no do you have any idea why he would
misrepresent his name well because
cia
officials in central america when they
come to serve
as u.s government officials use their
real name
but here in the united states when they
are not
officials
before
any foreign government then they tend to
to use
other names when did you next meet mr
claridge
oh i met him a number of times i
wouldn't remember i mean i met him in
miami and then i met him in washington
and met him in miami again
[Music]
and uh yeah what was the purpose of all
these meetings well this map well it was
a matter of of our our joint uh
purpose did he ever use his right name
oh yeah later on after he used his
correct name when he used his correct
name did you ask him why he had been
using no bigger same name because i was
sort of familiar with that kind of thing
besides we in the resistance or
in the contrast
we a lot of us also use the
other names
did you ever use another name no because
i was so obvious that i i mean nobody
would ever believe me
and when did you meet uh mr alan fires
up fires
i don't remember exactly what year but
but he took cover after someone else
left after this tony i believe who went
to europe then he became
the man in charge of central america
when where was it that you met mr fires
for the first time i don't remember it
could have been in honduras could have
been
here in washington what was the purpose
of your meetings with mr fires
to discuss
this
joint operation did you ever discuss
with mr fires or mr claridge financing
of the contras
well
they tended to uh keep away from that
and they tended not to speak of
ways
that
we could use
to
uh
lobby congress because they said that
was against the law
so when i when we ran out of money i
remember i began coming to washington in
1984
to lobby
for for
for u.s
financial support
did you talk to colonel north about
funding for the contras
oh yes he was aware uh
that we were in bad shape and that we
needed to uh to to raise money and and
uh
he uh
he was uh helpful to us
does the name oscar danilo bland and
riaz mean anything to you
no
it didn't mean anything to me
until
i read
his name
in the washington post i believe it was
or in the
or in the san jose mercury news
article that was brought down by a
washington post reporter to nicaragua
and then i saw his name blandon reyes
and uh
until then i realized
that
that he's who his father was and who his
mother
did you ever know
mr blandon no i could have seen him as a
child in nicaragua did you know his
parents i knew his father i don't know
his mother yes very nice people very
good people
does the name name juan norvin
meneses
cantarero mean anything to you
norway meneses was the brother of uh
of a general in the nicaraguan army well
known
and he was a cousin of another general
in the caribbean army so the name was
familiar
and
uh i never met him in nicaragua
did you ever meet mr vanessa's any place
other than nicaragua
we
of the resistance used to visit
a cities in the united states
where there were
heavy concentrations of nicaraguans
in order to obtain their political
support
i used to hear from congressmen
that you know that they needed in order
to vote for us
that their left was pretty tough on them
the system which was the salvadorian
communist outfit had a lot of
synthesizers
and
and we needed
this and some of these congressmen
needed the political support so we used
to go to cities where there were lots of
nicaraguans and tell them about this
need
that congressmen had
so
for them to to do something not to go to
rallies or to uh prosecute was it in
that connection that you met mr manesses
in that connection where where did you
meet mr minister i met mr meneses in san
francisco california
maybe in the year 1984
maybe 1985
i
met him on two occasions
maybe more
no
on two occasions and they were in
connection with this
gatherings of nicaraguans that we had
how long did the first meeting last
well i did not meet with him personally
i met with a whole lot of people how
long did the meeting with a whole lot of
people last i don't know it was uh it
was it was the first time it was a
dinner
could last two and a half hours
did you have some conversation with mr
meneses i must have what i don't
remember
and when uh
how long did the second meeting last
no
i
don't remember but but it was
some kind of a seminar
that we had at the drake hotel or
something in california
and
it was uh
i was there with a bishop from el
salvador who used to support
the
the
rightist cause in el salvador do you
recollect you recollect having a
specific conversation with mr manesses
at that time
i i i
i
i talked to you know i talked to all of
them everybody had questions to ask me
mostly how are things going you know
what are you doing did mr meneses ever
provide any money for the conference not
not one cent
are you sure of that
i am sure of that i heard from erlich
bermudez who is now there
that uh and who had reason to nominesses
because bermudez was a member of
nicaraguan army and so was vanessa's
brother
and bermudez told me that meneses had
come to honduras
in 1982
and had brought with him a crossbow
and some uh sporting goods
for the troops to uh
to enjoy
and uh that's the only conversation that
i remember ever having with
meneses i mean with bermudez about
meneses
and uh
and i can because i've read lots of
things on this i can tell you that
vanessa was never appointed
any
thing in
in
[Music]
in san francisco well precisely what did
mr bermudez say that mr manesses did
that he had come down to honduras had
brought in this crossbow
and brought in what
a crossbow you know those that both
crossbones crossbows yeah they used to
use in the middle ages and what was the
purpose of bringing in crossbows across
bowman thoughts would serve for for
for a special operations or something
like that but mother said and he laughed
it off you know they used as a weapon as
a weapon yeah but it wasn't it was
unrealistic
totally unrealistic
i mean bermuda's left laughed it off i
remember and that's all mr bermude has
said that mr meneses did that's all
bermuda said that mr minnesota did yes
did you know that mr vanessa's was
engaged in drug trafficking
i had no idea
that he was
engaged in drug trafficking
i saw him as another nicaraguan
moving freely
within the united states in and out of
the united states
so i had no reason
to believe
nor suspect nor imagine
that he was
in any kind of an illegal
activity
i
as a matter of fact he's not he was he
was the only [ __ ] i was not in the
united states did you know that uh mr
blandon was engaged in drug trafficking
i never heard blandon
and brandon's name never came up around
the 80s did you ever hear any discussion
in any way with anyone
about drug trafficking to provide money
to support the contras
never hurt i never never did and and if
i ever if i ever i can tell you one
thing if i ever would have had
knowledge or a notion
that something like that
could have been going on
i would have denounced it
i
i certainly was not
going to
join
in
such a crime
which was absolutely foreign to my way
of being to my
way of life
i would have never never never
covered
or
or abetted or or
or looked the other way or something
like that
did you ever know of or hear anything
about
anybody from the cia being involved or
turning the
uh
looking away when
drugs were being sold to finance the
contras never
i must say that
i have a very high opinion of the cia
people
that i dealt with
i
knew
some of their families
i knew them personally of course
and
they seem to me as
god-fearing
family men
very much dedicated to a cause
which they considered
important
for this country
and
so
[Music]
i
i never could i could have never
suspected
nor never imagined
that any
of the cia officials
that i met
that i worked with
would be
capable
of ever
going into into such into any kind of
illegal
or or or immoral
or criminal
activities aside from the issue of drug
sales did you know of the cia making any
effort of any kind in any way to
provide funding for the contras when
the official united states funding was
cut off
no
they were very careful
uh
we used to joke about it you know this
we used to call them the siacos you know
the cia and cic or
they're always asking questions and
never giving any answers was our
what we used to comment
they always want to know everything
and they seldom inform you of anything
uh
we never and as far as fundraising
i remember
clearly
that adam fires would say i don't want
to hear about that you know if we
started to talk about something that
they were not supposed to be involved in
i don't want to hear anything
now what was it that alan fires didn't
want to hear about
anything that would uh let's say that
would involve our lobbying or or or
efforts we we were making uh
to to raise funds well when you say he
didn't want to hear about it was that a
statement that it was okay to do it as
long as he didn't hear well
well my my impression was
that they wanted to keep
away or
keep out of
anything that did not involve
their
orders or their
their well keeping out of it is one
thing if it's going on
stopping it from going on if it's
improper or something else are you
saying that they
wanted to stop it from going on or only
wait let me finish the question or only
that if it was going on
they didn't want to know anything about
it wanted to look the other way but
allow it to go on
well there was nothing wrong about our
lobbying uh in the u.s congress
yet they didn't want to know about it
but was that why why why did they take
that attitude uh if there was nothing
wrong with your lobbying i don't know i
don't know i don't know but clara's you
doubtless know one of the uh
charges is
uh that although the cia might not have
been involved in the drug dealing they
might have known about it and
might have
looked away but allowed it to go on with
tacit approval i'm not saying they did
that
but i'm just asking you the question in
some detail to clarify
your own testimony that they just didn't
look the other way knowing what was
going on
you're saying that they wanted to stop
anything from going on that was illegal
no what i said i answered you you asked
me
if
they were involved in
fun collecting
and i told you
that when
we would talk about fun racing
then they said look
that's fundraising in
in
in the
common ordinary way that it was done
or
fundraising or or trying to
get u.s
congressional approval for
funds
they would not
want to hear about that
i have not said that you know we were
talking about other things that they
didn't want to hear about no no justice
those are two specific things
cause that was out of there
excuse me that was out of their of their
uh
it was out of their line to be involved
what the congress did on fundraising yes
fundraising finding funds for the cup
for the conference yeah fundraising was
out of their nine and so was uh lobbying
the us congress
senator shelby thank you
senator spector's been over some of
these questions but i'm going to
continue if you'll be patient
uh to your knowledge mr claro
did the central intelligence agency the
drug enforcement agency or any other
government agency
of the united states
promote drug trafficking as a means to
raise funds for resistance efforts in
nicaragua in the 80s
not only they did not
to my knowledge they did not ever
promote
any
such thing
but
did not promote
anything else
that
that would
be uh
wrong or okay or out of their
out of their line of duty
did you
or any member of your organizations
that were involved in
trying to get rid of the government in
nicaragua
promote the trafficking
of narcotics as a means of fundraising
in any way or anywhere
especially in the united states
i need anybody officially connecting
with
your organization
excuse me you go there
my knowledge no one
look at that one or non-liquor i would
ever
connected with the organization
promoted in
any way
any criminal activity and had they done
it
i would have been the first
to
call
them to order or
to denounce the uh the thing because we
could not afford
to have we here we were trying to look
our best
trying to appeal
to
some
400
somewhat or 500 somewhat u.s government
congressional
representatives who had the same about
the funding you were basically trying to
promote democracy in your country we
were we were promoting them we were
promote promoting democracy we were
promoting honesty i will tell you i mean
not because i did it but when i had to
appear before congress
or before the independent council
judge watches
i talked to the mayor miami and some
other friends in miami i said
i've been you know i've been cited for a
grand jury i need a lawyer because i
don't know
much about
what happens here
and
so this young men you know they look for
a young lawyer you know able
he says well my first recommendation is
that you
er
appeal to the fifth amendment
and uh and i say like hell i said
if i'm going to do that i don't need a
lawyer you had nothing to hide i have
nothing i'm going to come before these
people
and i'm going to answer all questions
i'm going to turn in
all records and i did that with uh
with i turned that into senator orrin
hatch i remember
sir would you be in a position as in
your
organization the contract one of the
contra organization
to know
if there was drug trafficking involved
or an effort by some people in your
organization to sell drugs to raise
money for
the overall effort to overthrow the
government
well i can tell you
money you cannot if there's anything you
cannot do is hide money you know money
shows
if anybody is handling it um and
we always had
people
asking offer money
for needs
for for for
human italian needs
to help family members to help
themselves to have
to get medicines to get medical
attention when we didn't have much of
that
and i never
i never saw
anyone you know showing up with
money or going to bar rooms or driving
new vehicles or or
or using new clothes or anything like
that which can give you an idea that
something's wrong
let me ask you this sir
uh
senator spector talked to you about mr
blandin and ministers ministers is that
as you say isn't it london
menaces is that oh meneses manasses yeah
in their
role was mr blandon one of the founders
of the fdn in the state of california
the founder knowledge the founders of
the fda was it was founded before before
i arrived absolutely the founders of the
fdm
were
disenchanted
sandinista fighters
who left
nicaragua okay and went into honduras
and joined up with former
national guardsmen
uh
and made up
the
and
organization and then got help from uh
from uh
the argentines and then it went up to
washington got some help when i came to
the fda 1983
there was already u.s funding for the
for the effort
did you ever uh pose for a photograph
with uh mr blandon or mr menaces
nessus well i tell you
and if so where did this take place and
when
i i appeared on tv okay
constantly
in newspapers here in this country in
other countries
and i became whether i liked it or not
sort of
a celebrity
i used to be stopped
in the streets in stores in
many places
and people in airplanes if anybody who
had a camera with him you want to have a
picture taken with me
and when i came to these meetings of
nicaraguans in in
in
san francisco new orleans los angeles
chicago and whatnot
everybody wanted to have a picture taken
with me
and so i had hundreds and hundreds of
pictures taken
with nicaraguans
with people that i didn't know
but i will never see again but that was
the usual and i think that's very very
much american uh
to you know movie actors and this not
you know what everybody wants to have
picture taken with them did you know
this gentleman personally mr meneses
i met him in california
in san francisco personally do you
remember what year that was 85 maybe 84
86
i never met him in nicaragua did you
talk to him when you met him in
california i talked to him about having
an extended conversation about your role
in the government what you were trying
to do or how you were going to raise
money or how he could raise money no no
no i i never
not even rich nicaraguans ever ever gave
us any money because they said
that the money needed was
so much
that uh that it was impossible for them
to to to uh
besides nikkei i was aware in the united
states were not in good economic shape
you know most of them had left all their
belongings and things back home
the only nicaraguan that i remember
specifically
gave me and gave it to me personally
money was mr lakayo the president of the
coca-cola company i used to work for
he gave me ten thousand dollars to open
up the office here
in uh
[Music]
where did that ten thousand dollars come
from out of his own pocket i know his
own pocket yeah is he a businessman or
something he was yeah very
good reputation a businessman with a lot
of money i mean okay
he was the owner of the coca-cola
franchise in nicaragua that i worked for
did either one of these men uh
manesses and blandon did they ever hold
to your knowledge any official position
uh with your organization
to my knowledge i never heard any
official position we used to have
a representative in each nicaraguan
community in
in
in this cities you know and and the one
and usually we would pick the leader
of the nicaraguans we will pick the
person who had been there
longer the person who had the facility
who was known by everyone
and
to have gatherings or to have meetings
in san francisco that person
and i told
mr cummings uh
tony navarro is the name
and he's been there
he he went to
there was a big [ __ ] that was migration
in the 40s to california so he went
there in the 40s and he's been there for
a long time and he has a
a body shop there which is very very
successful i understand
sir did did you or anyone in the higher
echelons of your organization ever
discuss ever
discuss any possibility of using money
raised from the cell trafficking and
drugs to overthrow the government in
nicaragua
was it ever brought up in any type of
discussion when you were trying to raise
money before
my in my presence
there was never
any
such discussion have you ever heard
of any other discussions that were not
made in your presence or inklings that
this may have been discussed in your
organization
the only thing i heard about drugs
is
the fact that some of our troops inside
nicaragua
at times would come
upon
marijuana patches you know
growing in the country yeah growing in
the country yeah so they would they
would cut some
for themselves and
and use it
at some point you know
during their surgery because some of
them used to stay two three four months
inside [ __ ]
so that's the only thing i ever heard
connected with with
with drugs
and then i read in the papers also
allegations about about
about drugs but
when did you first read this in in the
papers and what papers
again
about this about allegations of drugs oh
way back in
after my after my second trip to san
francisco was this be back in the 80s
back in the year oh yeah 1895 86 87 i
don't remember exactly and what did you
hear read or hear
uh
some newspapermen from the chronicle or
san francisco chronicle or or or maybe
the other paper
called me about
this fellow meneses
so the there must have been something
uh and what he called you about that
what was what what was the conversation
i don't remember exactly what but he
wanted to find out about him about that
man about this man what was our
our tie
do you have any link to him another what
link we had
why and so i told him exactly what i've
said here you know
and because they had them
i think that the press or the media
already had meneses uh
in the eye you know i mean they they
they uh
they
suspected excuse me suspected something
about it
they were focusing on him anyway yeah
right
and i never saw him after that i never
saw him
nor would i have ever want to see him
because the least thing i needed
were at the time were problems
do you believe of your own knowledge in
the
positions you've held
in the contra organization
that the cia was
ever involved in any official capacity
or unofficial capacity in promoting drug
trafficking to raise money
uh
i mean i i
if you allow me the use of an american
slang
you're going to
i uh
i would say that uh
that all of this story but
rather
than about crack
is about
crap
that's my crap yes rather than crack is
crap
that's the way i look at it
it's a preposterous
unfounded unfounded
uh ridiculous
or what prebuster is ridiculous uh
absurd
uh
you if you have anything you would like
to tell the committee
if you have anything you would like to
tell the community
we will be
we will be glad to receive it
[Applause]
we
[Music]
are proceeding
[Applause]
[Music]
they know about what happened they have
documents that they sent to
[Applause]
we are going to have to proceed with
this hearing if there is anything you
have to tell the committee
we will be glad to hear from you we have
talked to mr
officer officer stand aside officer
stand aside
officers stand aside
that's right
well what's going on right now
[Music]
[Applause]
we are calling every relevant
witness who is who is called
we will be glad to talk to you to get
your suggestions and we will call
we will call
mr calero would you would you proceed
[Music]
quite
[Applause]
[Music]
yes
[Applause]
to investigate george bush and here's
the evidence in this special report if
anybody cares to find out what the truth
is
a young
[Applause]
if
anybody if anybody if anybody has any
information to present to this committee
we are interested in receiving it
we we understand we understand the high
level of emotional involvement
and we are we are prepared to allow some
leeway
to have you express yourselves although
this is not in accordance with the
regular rules we are prepared to listen
to you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and solutions from the communities that
are being affected by this yeah we are
[Applause]
we are
we are prepared
we are prepared
to listen to anyone who has anything to
say on this subject
this meeting
this meeting was
this meeting
this meeting was not called suddenly
this meeting was scheduled
three weeks ago and notice was given
this committee is treating this issue as
a very serious matter now we'll proceed
with mr calero anybody anybody who wants
to talk to us may do so
mr calero will you proceed we'll hear
from congresswoman waters in a moment or
two let us finish with mr calero all
right
senator shelby
mr well chairman i just uh no i i just
believe that
as i said earlier
i wanted to commend you again for
calling and i know this is probably the
first of many hearings an open hearing
not a closed hearing but i do believe
that we ought to hear from these other
people you know that they've got a right
to testify here
before us and we need to
we need to get to the bottom
of this and i suppose that today's
hearings is just the beginning of a
number of hearings that you would have
i'd hope well as i said at the outset
senator shelby we convened the first
hearing
promptly upon the adjournment of the
congress in response to the san jose
newspapers
we have then been proceeding to talk to
everyone who was identified in that
newspaper article
we have met with leaders of the
african-american community congressman
waters and i talked before the last
hearings
congresswoman waters just stood up and
we'd be we'd be glad to hear
what you have to say congresswoman
waters
well you're invited to come join us
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen let me let me say
let me say to you
that
when the officers approached the man who
was standing i'm not going to have the
conclusion of this hearing
that people who were
expressing themselves were ousted by the
capitol police i'm not going to have
that happen
i can understand that the emotions are
running very high
this committee has responded very
promptly
and in an intense way to get to the
bottom of this matter and to find out
what is going on
we convened the first hearing on october
23rd
and we heard from jack bloom who had
been the council for a
senate subcommittee in 1989
and we heard from the inspector general
of the cia and the inspector general of
the department of justice
and as we said on the record
senator kerry and i we were not
satisfied with their authority without
the subpoena power
and at that time congressman waters was
here and we had a brief conversation
as i just did with uh mr fumay head of
the naacp and congressman cummings
and if congresswoman waters has a
question that she would like to ask line
of questions she is
welcome to do so it is not
the regular proceeding but we are glad
to expand it
when you stand up and speak out it does
not help us get to the facts anybody
who has any witness or anybody you think
we ought to be talking to
we are interested in your suggestions
and now we'd be pleased to hear from our
colleague on the house side
congresswoman waters
thank you very much senator spector i
i do appreciate the opportunity to um
raise some questions
uh that i have formulated i know this is
an unusual um
way of doing business as a member of the
other house
this is not normally done but i
certainly respect the fact that you
understand that there is high interest
and that you have allowed uh some of the
members of this audience to express
themselves and you have made it clear
that you are about the business of
getting to the bottom of information and
not about the business of ejecting or
having to use police so i'm real pleased
i think this is good this is a good
start
and i wish to raise a number of
questions first of all to make sure that
we have the right person
um
mr adolfo calero
you are a 1953 graduate of notre dame is
that correct
you were the manager of the coca-cola
botland plant in managua before the
sandinista revolution correct
you did meet with mr norman meneses you
have said that you were
in a meeting with him maybe two times
uh and you didn't remember quite what
year but would you agree that that was
1984
could have been
were you recruited by the cia
to serve on the fdn directorate in 1983
no
the first
invitation i received
to join the uh
movement was
extended to me
by
mr enrique bermudez who was the military
chief
at the time
uh through
a newsman newspaperman who had been to
honduras and came to nicaragua
and
was mr bermudez a cia operative had you
ever heard that before
no he was a member of the nicaraguan
national guard and he was
for a number of years the military
attache
of the nicaraguan government in
washington dc
had you ever heard that he was a cia
operative
i'm supposed to be one too and anybody
but no i'm not i'm not you right now i
want to know about what i'm trying to
say is that that
that
anyone who has anything or any relation
with americans in many of these
countries many other countries is called
the cia operative i mean so it's a so
you heard that you did hear the rumor
that he was a cia operative i heard yeah
i've heard as i said i've heard of me or
did you become the president and
commander-in-chief of the fdn
directorate
did what
did you become
the president and
in chief of the fdn directorate
yes in october of 1983
did you ever work for the cia and nick
warger prior to
even becoming the
president of the directory
i have
never worked
for
any government
not even my government
i have never
been under the employ
of
any government and my only
employments have been with private
enterprise did you work with the embassy
in nicaragua i never worked for
not as a paid employee as a citizen who
helped to distribute funds that were
given to service organizations in
nicaragua did you serve that role for
the embassy i have been
consulted a number of times
by the united states embassy
as to what's my idea my opinion
about
certain people or about certain
organizations did you have to direct
funds from the embassy to certain
organizations in nicuaqua
i would say that maybe on account of the
fact that i uh
that i recommended
a worthy cost that funds might have gone
to that
organization did you work in conjunction
with the cia designated person of the
embassy in distributing those funds
i did not work i assisted not work you
weren't on the payroll but you were a
citizen
who worked with i was let's say i was i
was a sort of a consultant i was a sort
of an advisor
to
many
many
u.s government
representatives yes
all right so there was a connection with
the embassy
the persons that you worked with could
or could not have been cia connected
uh and you helped to give them advice
about who to give funds to
uh in nick wag or those service
organizations are we correct in
concluding i would to this day if i come
if america to begin with
i
i am
very much
appreciative of this country i consider
this my second country
and anything i can do for this country
for the good of it i will always do and
uh oh no and i appreciate that i just
wanted to establish the connection so
that we understand
uh that we're talking on the same
wavelength here
uh now mr norman meneses
was a known drug dealer in nick wagoy
you did you know that
you do not know that he was called the
kingpin of narcotics traffickers in nick
wager prior to the fall of samosa
no never heard of him before i never
i heard of him before uh but
in a matter of some automobiles i
remember something came out in the paper
but i just no that was in san francisco
where he owned an automobile dealership
but prior to coming to the united states
he was very well known
in nicuagua he was a drug dealer before
he ever came to the united states and
you knew his brother-in-law didn't you
uh-uh did you know his brother-in-law
his brother who was his brother did you
know any of his relatives uh
i knew of his brother who was a general
but i don't remember ever met him
meeting him
do you know carlos
akasa carlos yes
a nick wagon attorney
carlos casa yeah nicaragua an attorney
yes
uh
i i know him yes he did he ever
represent you
he used to work with us in the uh in the
effort yes
did you know he was the son-in-law of
manesses
of uh yeah well i he had been divorced
by the time that he he was married to
someone else
[Applause]
and don't say meneses because we're
talking about many menaces here
carlos igasa
was married
to a lady
the daughter of
a man by the name of meneses who was the
nicaraguan ambassador in guatemala
and
[Music]
this ambassador was assassinated in 1978
and
i believe at the time mr casa
whose legal advice i have used
throughout the years sometimes
was divorced of this menace's woman and
was married to someone else
and then married someone else and then
he's been married four times
i guess what i'm trying to establish
here is that
manesses was known
his relatives were known
you knew some meneses
and i'm trying to understand whether or
not
you knew anything about mr meneses while
you were in nickwagon had his name come
up did you know he was a drug dealer did
you know his relatives uh was this
absolutely foreign to you until you
first met him in san francisco the name
meneses is well known
in nicaragua uh they come from the
northern part of nicaragua from genotega
or some place and there were two general
menaces in the nicaraguan army
that were
well known one of them was ambassador of
nicaragua to guatemala
so the name meneses was known to me
and the public activities of some of the
members of that family were known to me
about the clandestine and delinquent
activities
of any other member of the family was
not known to me
all right do you know mr peanut cabrera
pina cabrera pena yes
cabrera c-a-b-r-e-r-a
he was with the fdn
pena cabrera kenya yeah did you know him
kenya
i don't remember the name doesn't strike
me did you know any member of the fdn in
san francisco that was arrested in 1984
on drug trafficking charges
no
not to my knowledge i don't know who was
arrested
and
we had no members of such of fdn
in the united states i mean we had
delegates or representatives
who would help us out
politically as i said at the beginning
did mr bermudez ever tell you
that he had given mr meneses
responsibility
uh for intelligence and security in
california
he never told me that
and
as far as i'm concerned
we did not need any
security or intelligence
in
san francisco
or in new orleans or in
chicago for that matter
when you met with mr
meneses
in san francisco
was there any discussion
with mr meneses
about receiving help
money resources for your work for the
fdn
never
never offered a penny
never gave us a penny
and
if there was anyone to have received
that
it would have been me because people
tend to want to give the money
to the head men
they want
the head men to know that they are
contributing
and so
if there had been any such
donation it it would have come to me i
imagine and it never came to me
from an ss not from anybody in san
francisco we never got a penny there
are you aware of
a money trail
that was identified by the dea and the
fbi
from the drug ring in los angeles
through a mr lister and morello to a
bank in miami and from there to the
contras
do you know who mr lister is lister yes
listed
from los angeles
were you aware of a bank in miami that
was identified as a bank
uh that um the money passed through
to the congress
no i we
uh
the we we used in miami
uh
one two three banks they were all uh
foreign banks but most of the
money that
all the transactions
that took place
were mostly at the banco the america
central called back
and i turned over to senator orrin hatch
back in 1987 i believe
all
our bank accounts how did how did the
money for example if an organization
wanted to give money to the contras
in los angeles or san francisco where
would they take that money and who would
they give it to
our
they would have given it to tony navarro
and shiva i mean who was
the guy known in in uh
entrusted and with a good reputation in
san francisco
uh
or they would have uh
answered maybe one of these
mail
mailings that
went out and and
and asked for funds you know through
the nicaraguan american development
foundation
which was established in washington or
through
uh
spitz channel which i don't remember
what the name
of his organization was called
otherwise there was no way because we
didn't have any bank accounts in
california
mr calero as you explained
when you went into los angeles and other
areas you were connected with the nick
wagon community
they would hold events rallies or
fundraisers
and i suppose there would be talk and
discussion about
the nickel organs that had uh come to
this country what they were doing how
they were progressing because you had a
lot of families here involved people who
left
who came here
and so in these nick warwin communities
as these discussions went on did you
hear any discussions about any of those
who had come from nicaragua who may have
been
arrested or who had gotten in trouble or
who had sought some help because they
had gotten in trouble no
i never heard of uh
of
such problems or
or nobody ever asked me
to help him out in that regard did you
ever hear about the blandone drug ring
there were two hundred nickel arguments
involved
there was a big raid in los angeles on
fourteen properties
of danio blandones
drugs supplied to him by manessas
it was a big deal
the la county sheriff's
raided these 14 properties
and that's where mr um
lister identified his connection with
the cia
and that's where they found
drug scales
small amounts of drugs cutting agents
and other kinds of things with that many
nick wagons involved and a big drug raid
are you saying that you never heard
about it no one ever discussed it no
never heard about it never discussed it
with me i can answer maybe with other
people they could have disgusted
whatever they want to but with me never
i never never anyone
approached me to discuss
any uh drug related matter
have you talked to mr meneses uh since
he's been in prison in nicaragua
no i have no reason to speak to him nor
would i want to speak to him did you
hear that he was in jail and did you
know why he's in jail i read in the
paper that he was in jail and i was
happy for it
why were you happy for him because any
delinquent should be in jail delinquent
delinquents delinquents criminals should
be in jail why did you think he was a
criminal well because anybody who deals
in drugs is a criminal when did you
learn he was dealing in drugs
when
when i saw that he was capturing manawa
about two years ago about two and a half
years ago i don't know
well mr chairman i um
i want to raise that information with mr
calero because
the drug ring in los angeles
was a drug ring
and the drugs were basically supplied by
mr meneses who was a drug smuggler
before he left managua he was dealing in
drugs before he left
the interesting question mr chairman is
how did he get into this country
not only was he a known drug dealer in
managua he was also associated with a
murder there before he ever came into
this country how did he walk into the
united states
undetected as a drug dealer and operate
for almost 10 years without ever being
arrested
any uh any
any line of inquiry that uh you have
to suggest congressman waters uh the
committee would be glad to entertain
and uh that was the conversation which
you and i had here
on october 23rd
and we appreciate
any suggestions you have or any
suggestions which uh
which which anyone may have
i can understand the very deep concern
which is present in this country about
these charges
and that is why this committee is
proceeding to conduct this inquiry
and if anybody has any suggestion as to
whom ought to be talked to
we want to hear about it
we
heard saw the reports about director
deutsch's appearance
in los angeles on november 15th and we
heard people in that audience and we
have talked to them to get any
information which uh which they may have
do you have anyone here from the dea mr
chairman
today
they have extensive files on uh from
the dea the d.a has extensive files
let's let's see what i talked about
we have contacted the dea and we are
dealing to obtain
information from them and we have
representatives of the department of
justice here today well let us proceed
now uh with mr pastor
what about the guns oh yeah uh let us
let us proceed and see how far we get
and if there's someone here from dea i'm
going to press on that because i've
talked with the inspector general and he
told me they had a room full of files on
the blandone meneses drug dealing
operation and we'll see where we can
find out but let's let's follow the
chairman for a minute here
we now turn to uh
uh mr
uh ed pastora
uh who is known as commander zero of the
effort
sandinista's most
popular war hero and the senior official
of their government
until he distanced themselves from them
in 1981
and in april of
1982 he publicly announced his
opposition to the
sandinista regime
in april 1983 he took up arms against
the sandonites
sandinistas and became the preeminent
leader of the nicaragua resistance on
the so-called
southern front
before proceeding to mr pasteur's
testimony
the committee would like to thank our
two interpreters mr stephanie van
riegensberg and ms patricia arizu from
the department of state who are
providing the translation here for mr
pastora
mr pastor let us proceed now to
hear from you as to
your general background where were you
born where were you educated give us
your
chronological history until you finished
your education please
in january i will be 60.
i am the son of an artisan
louisiana
new orleans
elsa gomez who was educated in new
orleans
until she was 25.
my father was pamphilo pastora he was
i
did high school in a jesuit high school
in granada nicaragua
when i was seven i lost my father he was
murdered by the samosa regime
i studied medicine for five years in the
university in guadalajara in mexico
i was unable to finish my medical
studies because i joined the armed
resistance against the fascist regime of
somosa
abrasion
from a very young age from the age of 20
i embraced the revolutionary ideas of
the sandinistas
um i still considered myself to be
a great sandinista and a good
revolutionary
cause
in defense
for these causes i have fought in three
guerrilla conflicts and three wars for
freedom democracy and revolution in my
i had problems in the year 1984 with the
central intelligence agency of the
united states
when i founded the revolutionary
democratic alliance in the south of
nicaragua
because of lack of financial resources
we withdrew from the armed conflict in
may of 1986
in 1959 i founded the sandino
revolutionary front what year was that
in queens
in 1961 and 62 i was the co-founder of
the sandinis the sandinista
revolutionary front or front for
national liberation excuse me
after the triumph of the revolution in
1979 i was the founder of the popular
militia the sandinista popular or
people's militia
commandant
i was a guerrilla comandante i was a
brigade commander
vice minister interior minister
and i was vice minister of the interior
and vice minister of defense of the
sandinista
government cristiano catholico i'm a
christian i'm a catholic
educator
i was educated in a very conservative
family a family with conservative
traditions
i do not have a home of my own no
mobile i do not own a car
i do not own any business
i am a fisherman
political
my political enemies have called me
every name
except for thief
coward
liar
or drug addict
no
in the years 1990 to 1996 i have founded
a political party in nicaragua
it's the party of democratic action or
the democratic action party
i was
registered as a candidate of my party in
the elections of 1996.
el quincenton
and on june 15th of 1996 the supreme
electoral tribunal prevented me from
participating
patriotic despite the fact that i'm a
patriot who has fought for 40 years for
the freedom of my people
i am here at your invitation
i thank you for that
i thank you for the fact that you have
promised me that this investigation will
go to the bottom
of the
discussion on drug trafficking
i come here to tell you for political
reasons and those are the reasons that i
have fought my whole life long
i come here to say to u.s
politicians
i am going to speak without
fear that's something which has
characterized me my whole life long
i am going to speak with sincerity
i used to think that was a virtue but
now i realize it's a defect
henry
patrick henry oh patrick henry
uh i would parody your hero patrick
henry when i say
that
saying to
my enemies give me liberty or give me
death
and either put the handcuffs on us and
take us to jail
or give our honor back to us
it is intolerable for an honest man
to be in this situation
thank you very much uh thank you very
much uh mr pastor we appreciate your
coming here today
mr pastor according to an october 31
1996 washington post article
two of your representatives octavio
cesar and adolfo popo chamorro
said they asked a cia official
if they could accept the offer of
airplanes and cash from a miami-based
drug dealer
george morales
chamorro is quoted as saying that
i called our contact at the c.i.a of
course i did
and they said
morales was fine
first of all do you understand the uh
the question
do you understand that
information
yes i understand perfectly well do you
have any knowledge
of uh
of the miami-based drug dealer george
morales
i don't know if they had this contact
with george morales with or without the
authorization of the central
intelligence agency of the united states
well have have you ever heard of george
morales
yes i have and
what do you know about george morales
after 1984 when i no longer had contact
with the cia and after
the united states government had stopped
assisting us uh octaviano cesar gave me
a contribution of twenty thousand
dollars who who gave the contribution
this was a contribution
i'll finish what he said before uh of
twenty thousand dollars followed by a
later contribution of twenty thousand
dollars and i think a third one of
perhaps thirty thousand dollars
uh from a contact which they had with an
american air transport millionaire whose
name was george morales
what
later this millionaire in air
transportation sent a gift
in the form of a titan 304 aircraft
which was on the
apron at the pavas airport and it was in
the name of popo chamorro
we had no money any longer at this point
i'm talking about the middle toward the
end of 1984.
not only did the cia not provide us with
any financial assistance but it also
blocked economic assistance from
reaching us
during those months i got money dollar
for dollar from the cuban factory over
the course of this period forty to fifty
thousand dollars
at that same time george morales gave us
as a gift another aircraft this one a
dc3 which he sent to ilopango airport in
san salvador
octaviano
may participate
in
told me that this millionaire
george morales wanted to meet the canal
commander in chief
eden pastora
[Music]
on a trip that i made to miami octaviano
cesar and popo chamorro took me
to the
home of chamorro's first wife
where i met this george
morales
it was early in the evening i can't
remember if it was seven or eight and
george morales came into this group can
you fix the approximate date of that
meeting
it was the end of 84 or the first few
months of 85.
[Music]
i realized that george morales i
couldn't get him into a
real in-depth conversation a political
conversation or an ideological
conversation
as i wanted him too
i found his bearing and
his way of being very strange
he talked about small boats
launches and insisted on maintaining a
very superficial kind of conversation
i took advantage of the fact that he got
a telephone call to go to poco
chamorro's former wife
and i asked who is this guy
she was very surprised that i didn't
realize that he was the drug trafficker
george morales
she said that she was very
frightened of him because
he had just killed
her
her husband
that he was a pilot and he knew a lot
george morales
and at that point i realized the danger
i was in
a trauma
trafficking
i suspected that it might have been a
trap to get me involved in drug
trafficking because i had an independent
spirit
mandia marpur telephoning
and they came right away
i complained uh bitterly about this and
they acted surprised and said that they
didn't know
i said that i didn't know that george
morales was a drug trafficker and what
did uh popo chamorro on octavio cesar
said
[Music]
question is
did chamorro and cesar know that uh
they
accepted
that he was a drug trafficker
from me let us let us come back
to the
citation that i started with from the
october 31st 1996 washington post
article
which
said that
cesar and chamorro
asked a cia official if they could
accept the offer of airplanes and cash
from morales a
miami-based drug dealer
chamorro is quoted as saying that
shamuro
called the contact
at the cia
who said that morales was fine
now do you know anything about
a cia contact who dealt with
either chamorro or seizure
no no
no i do not know
had you
seen that
article in the washington post on
october 31st 1996
i have not read it myself but i've been
told about it it had been called to your
attention
that is right did you make any effort to
find out if that article
was correct which quotes
uh cesar and samara as
contacting a cia
representative to check on morales
in these months we were in the
excitement of the political campaign in
nicaragua and i really didn't have time
well when did the campaign end
juan
the campaign had just ended when your
two representatives came to talk to us
and we accepted the invitation to come
here
did you instruct your associates to
check
with the cia before accepting
contributions from
individuals believed to be narcotics
traffickers
no we had completely broken off uh
broken relations with the cia
you testified that in 1984 you had
problems with the cia when you started
your testimony
what were those problems with the cia
eminently
the us government and the nicaraguan
government had negotiated in the city of
manzanillo
in 13 rounds of negotiation they
negotiated an end to
the
war in nicaragua from east to west
salvador and the end to the contra
war in nicaragua
one
group was being managed by one
group and the other by the other or
another
the only independent front
was the southern front that was us
yes
this
jeopardized the
position of the cia from a political
point of view because they couldn't
control the south
podium
and as we were proceeding with our
guerrilla war in the south they could
not openly just stop the war in the
north so you disagreed with the
settlement which was made
by the parties to the negotiations
right we disagreed with this settlement
and you wanted to carry on the
war
nosotros
a war to win not a war to be negotiated
out
was that the
totality of your problems with the cia
the rest of it is false the rest of it
are lies
uh what are you referring to as the lies
now
all the lies that were told at the time
that they cut the aid off because we
were drug traffickers because we were
communists because we were part of the
front
all of those lies which were propounded
at that time did
who said that the aid was cut off
because you were drug traffickers
[Music]
i heard that alan fires said that they
were cutting off aid to the southern
front to arde
because some of the people of the den
pastors were drug traffickers
i want to say clearly
that up to may of 1984
that the cia in defense of the united
states
that the cia had all the money in the
world money that it got from the u.s
congress and the u.s government
and
up to that point and i'm talking about
1982 83
and half of 84 all they gave us was six
million dollars
did you have personal dealings with mr
fires
i think i met him but he was using a
different name what name was he using
solo
numbers
i don't remember i just remember the
name uh
that dewey clearage used he called
himself mr maroni
well let's
let's let's finish with mr fryers first
how many times did you meet mr fyres
i don't know perhaps once or twice and
what did you talk about
we talked about the political and
military situation
i do want to make one thing clear i was
a field commander and i spent most of my
time in the mountains uh directing our
battles
the city person so to speak was alfonso
robelo
and from during 1983 until 1984 when we
broke off with him he was the one that
handled the money i spent 90 percent of
my time in the mountains in the field
how many how many times did you meet
with mr
dwayne dewey claridge
two three four perhaps even five times
and what did you talk to mr claridge
about
the problem
armada
we spoke about the political problems of
nicaragua we talked about the need for a
policy to
further the armed struggle how to devel
develop that
policy
the political differences that we had
with the united states
the negotiations that were ongoing
and we also talked about the the problem
of the very small amount of money we
were getting did you do you know do you
know why mr uh clarence used the name
rooney
it's a habit that security and
intelligence people have to conceal
their real names
during the fall of 1984 did you
instruct several of the arde
representatives to travel to the united
states to try to get private funding
no
no
did you ever send anybody to the united
states to try to get private funding
no
no
do you know uh did you ever know mr
manesses
i ran into him once by chance around the
time of the triumph of the sandinista
revolution in 1979
and another time by coincidence in
costa rica around 87. and this is juan
norvin
we're talking about the norman meneses
who's in prison in nicaragua
and when did you first meet
norvin meneses
it was just by chance so in a meeting
with some women friends i've never had a
friendly relationship with mr meneses
and then you met him on a second
occasion you say
this was again a coincidence i was with
a friend and i think this was in 1988 we
were in costa rica and it was
in a business which
roasted beans
do you have any knowledge as to whether
or not norman
norven vanessa's was or was not a drug
dealer
[Music]
marijuana
norman meneses i recall that it was said
already in nicaragua that he was
involved in illicit or dirty
uh business i think he had motels and it
was also said that he was involved in
the sales of cocaine
in those days uh cocaine sales was not
very common
marijuana was much more common
did you know that norm meneses
involved in drug sales in california
no
no
did you know that norman manesses was
allegedly trying to support
no i did not know did you ever have any
conversations with norvin vanessa's
about
helping to support the contra's war
effort
these two coincidental meetings that
i've described one of them happened way
before the contras and the other one way
after nov lava
and we did not discuss this at all
uh do you know uh oscar danielo blandon
reyes
yes i know him and when did you first
meet him
i don't remember whether it was in miami
where i was introduced to him or in san
francisco or if it was in san francisco
how many times did you meet mr blandin
perhaps some three or four times and
what did you talk to him about
nicaragua
um
um
[Music]
we talked about the situation in
nicaragua
he was
he presented himself as an
anti-sandinista patriotic man i had the
impression that his family was uh
somosista
so i asked him for help and i think he
gave me help
once three thousand dollars and another
time three thousand dollars
uh this was 85 86 or even 87 after the
war
and he gave me two pickups
i want to be clear that he gave the six
thousand dollars toward the armed
struggle but the pickup trucks were
personal gifts to me
and i also want to say that in 1985 or
86 we were loaned a house in costa rica
to live in with me and my family which
turned out to be owned by mr blandon
did you know that mr blandon was engaged
in drug trafficking
it was only when he was arrested in san
diego that i discovered that he had
problems with drugs are you saying that
you did not know he was engaged in drug
trafficking when you accepted the six
thousand dollars for your contra war
effort
uh
why did you accept a pickup truck as a
personal gift from mr blandon
i was fishing in costa rica i belonged
to a fisherman's cooperative and i was
in extremely critical
financial straits
and it seemed to me totally natural that
a friend of mine uh who was in very
comfortable financial straits as are the
blandon
uh family in nicaragua it was very
natural to me that a person like that
would offer me or give me as a gift to
pick up trucks was he a good friend of
yours
well from the point of view of him
giving me those gifts yes he was a good
friend
these pickups were worth a thousand or
fifteen hundred dollars
my question uh mr pastor goes to the
point of
whether he was a good enough friend to
accept uh pickups worth a thousand or
fifteen hundred dollars
and whether you knew
that he was uh
what his line of work was what he was
engaged in doing like drug trafficking
for
well it's not unusual for people in
public life or famous people to be
offered all kinds of assistance help
donations
so i found it very logical that a friend
like danilo blandon who had been a
friend since
1985
wood in 1986 88
give me these two used pickup trucks
which were sent from los angeles to
costa rica
well my question to you mr pastora is if
he was a good enough friend of yours to
accept a pickup truck
was he a good enough friend of yours to
know that he was engaged in
drug trafficking
i did not know he was a drug trafficker
but i did consider him a good friend
you knew him well enough to accept the
pickup trucks but not well enough to
know what his business was
definitely that's correct
you testified that there had been
accusations by the cia
about
narcotics trafficking on the southern
front
could you be specific as to what you
heard about the cia's complaints about
such narcotics trafficking
i said that i had heard that it was alan
fires
who made this allegation using it as an
excuse for cutting off assistance to us
was there any basis at all for mr fires
assertion that there was drug
trafficking on the southern front
there was no grounds there was no reason
and that is why i'm here voluntarily
mr pastor there's a los angeles times
article dated october 21st 1996
quoting a source saying that everyone in
nicaragua
knew that
was a trafficker in the 1970s
was it uh an open and notorious
fact
that people knew that meneses was a
trafficker of narcotics in the 1970s
people generally in
nicaragua knew that
well if you judge me as a normal member
of nicaraguan society of that time yes i
should have known that
nicaragua me tell you that i left
nicaragua in 1967
and i was in two guerrilla conflicts
from 66 to 69 when i came back
nicaragua i really didn't live in nor
in normal society in nicaragua
i left later two years later in 1981
should have been 76 to 70.
and i only came back to live a normal
life in nicaragua in nineteen
in other words the
life in society of things that people
know of rumors of stories i just
don't know
mr pastora
octavia cesar
gave a deposition under oath before the
senate subcommittee on
terrorism and narcotics on october 31st
1987 saying quote
pastora had said publicly
that he had received a couple of
helicopters from drug traffickers
had you said
that you received a couple of
helicopters from drug traffickers
in miami
i received a couple of helicopters from
cubans exiled in miami
jose
received
i received the promise
informal promise
later mariano monte allegri
was the person who actually received the
two helicopters
did you know that the people giving the
helicopters were engaged in drug
trafficking
no
no
so that cesar is wrong when he said
under oath that
pastora had publicly
said that he had received a couple of
helicopters from drug traffickers
afterwards that it was discovered that
they were drug traffickers and i did say
so
but you didn't know it at the time you
received the helicopters is that what
your testimony is
when they were received we did not know
it it was not known
marcos aguado the head of your air force
also gave a deposition under oath before
that subcommittee on october 31st 1987
and stated quote
i understand that many of our
many of the collections and a lot of the
work that we have done to help the
southern front
they might have used the same for the
traffic of drugs the same connections
the same airstrips the same people
and maybe they said that it was weapons
for indian pastora and it was actually
drugs
that would later go to the united states
they took advantage of the
anti-communist sentiment
which existed in central america
honduras and salvador
costa rica and panama
and they undoubtedly used it for drug
trafficking they fooled people
was marcos aguado correct in that
statement
i think what marcos aguado says is very
true that there were many drug
traffickers who took advantage who were
opportunists who were opportunists
but
neither were were you or any of your
companions engage in any such drug
trafficking
neither any of my companions nor i were
involved in any of that
carol prado
arde's chief of communications gave a
deposition on october 31st
also under oath stating that quote
on the one hand drug traffickers that
approach political groups like arde
trying to make deals that would somehow
camouflage or cover up their activities
on the other hand
i believe that there were people from
the cia
that they set up traps for some of our
ideological colleagues that got them
excited
that maybe were promised that if the
store was removed they would
end up being left
is there any truth to that
i'm afraid i didn't follow the last
sentence of that
well the drug traffickers according to
carol prado approach political groups
like arde trying to make deals
that would camouflage their drug
trafficking activities
and there were people from the cia
here
that set up traps for some of
prado's ideological colleagues
that got them excited and said that they
were promised that if pasteur would
remove
they would end up being left i'm not
sure precisely what he means by being
left but
i'd like your comment about that sworn
testimony of carroll prado
the idea that we have in our day is that
they used cesar and chamorro in this
relationship with george morales
to
compromise us either directly or
indirectly
with drug trafficking
yes
and this is a kind of political death
why do we have this feeling
because when the whole
business of drug trafficking
came out in the open in the contras
the when the top came off the kettle so
to speak the cia gave a document to
cesar
poppocha
to chamorro and to marcos aguado too
this is they say that this is a document
document
holding them harmless or
without any responsibility
for having worked in
u.s security
yes
this is what they say
the uh of the matter is that they can
enter the united states freely but they
cannot enter costa rica
that's why we have this
bitter taste in our mouths and the idea
that they wanted to compromise us
those were the times when we were in
confrontation
and that they were trying to stop a den
pastora because
they wanted to stop the combat in the
south
fabio ernesto
carrasco a colombian drug trafficker
turned government witness with immunity
from prosecution
testified in 1990 that he paid
millions of dollars to cesar and
chamorro
[Music]
at the instruction of his then boss
george morales
mention his name
i never
heard his name i never met him and i did
not receive a cent of that money
except for the 20 or 30 that i received
at the outset did you ever see the signs
of substantial sums of money millions of
dollars flowing to arde from
george morales
are they never received or
any such quantities of millions of
dollars
the only serious signal we got was
the
when durant
was caught depositing or trying to
deposit 400
000
in a bank in costa rica
did you know john hall
an american rancher in costa rica
and he
was
known to be the cia representative in
the northern part of costa rica
and i knew another john hall who was the
head of the cia station in costa rica
but that was in 1983.
did you know a john hall who was
involved in drug trafficking during
this time period
i do not think that john hall the
rancher in costa rica was involved in
drug trafficking how about the other
john hall
no the other john hall is a gentleman
i met him in 1983
i say he was a gentleman
because i saw him and dealt with him
three or four times and i saw him as a
person of good upbringing
are you aware
that five witnesses testified before the
senate subcommittee
in 1989 that hull was involved in
cocaine trafficking
i did not know about those sworn
statements
but if they did make such sworn
statements they must have proof
are you aware that in mid-january of
1989
hull was arrested by costa rican
authorities and charged with
drug trafficking and violating costa
rica's neutrality
i also know that he was accused of the
attack at la penca which
in which four journalists were killed
and it has now been demonstrated that
neither the cia nor john hall had
anything to do with the armed attack at
la penca fuer roberto bitalgawini agente
hombre de gorilla
hombre de ventero
[Music]
the
people responsible were vital
roberto vitalgawiny
[Music]
who belonged to the
fifth section during the government of
the front the sandinista front
uh mr pastora
do you have any knowledge at all of any
cia involvement in
the sale of drugs to help finance the
contra effort in the nicaraguan war
video
i have no knowledge of anything of the
sort and please rest assured that if i
had seen
any such thing i would have informed a
senator or a congressman of the united
states
uh mr pastor this committee is
investigating
allegations that the cia
was involved in the
sale of drugs in california los angeles
or
allowed drugs to be sold in los angeles
with the profits being used for the
contras
do you have any knowledge of anything of
that sort whatsoever
i have no knowledge whatever senator
shelby thank you
thank you mr chairman
mr pastor how many people were involved
in the southern front organization
when you were
the commander
roughly how many people yes
military
well
in the military forces we had 7500
warriors and these were people who were
barefoot they were hungry they were sick
they had
no ammunition and they had old guns
it was a peasant revolt
everyone knows this did did you have
good control of these 7 500 people that
were fighting
were you you the commander where were
there
was there a system of control
in
as far as the war is concerned
i was there with them in battle and
until the year 1986 there was absolute
control over them
during this period uh in the 80s
when you were short of money
um
did you get money
wherever you could to help
keep your troops together to kept
keep your troops fed
to keep buying ammunition and
guns
to help
you
achieve your objective which was the
overthrow of the government
siem
my policy has always been to take the
money wherever possible in order to free
my people sure quietly
i want to tell you that in order to
fight against somosa we also got money
from fidel castro
and whoever wanted to help us
and i was never called a communist or a
drug trafficker
did it really matter where the money
came from
obviously
it came to you from many sources
as long as the money kept coming
you got money from cuba you got money
from
various and sundry sources so the
objective was the overthrow of the
regime
the government there
and
so any money from any source would help
you achieve that objective you would
take is that correct
what amounts are really money in a war
helicopter
because except for the two helicopters
we only received a few cents
los
the 30 or 40 000
that george morales provided over a
period of two months
those were cents in the bucket los
we kept these hungry guerrilla warriors
who were blocked by the right and the
left mask
we kept them going more thanks to the
money that was given by the cuban
factory dollar for dollar in miami
i don't recall any donation being over
twenty thousand dollars
could
it be possible
that some people would be working for
your southern front
helping you
in many ways and at the same time
flying drugs out of the area and
bringing them to the u.s
could that have happened
without your knowledge or without your
consent
it was difficult
but it's not impossible isn't it
it was not impossible to do no
impossibility not impossible
but as far as i know the only
travel i knew about was gerardo durans
and i learned of it much later
juan
when they had to justify the four
hundred thousand dollars they caught
gerardo duran depositing in a bank
after the war
this was already in 1988
if norma norvin manesses
was identified by the
drug enforcement agency
back in the 70s as a cocaine supplier in
managua would that been would that have
been pretty well known at that time
in nicaragua
repito que osa nicaragua
i repeat i left nicaragua in 1967 and i
did not go back until 1979.
and then i left again in 1981 and did
not return until 1990 or 91. esotosa
those two years i spent in the country
between 1979 and 1981 was in the middle
of all the bustle of the
it is very difficult for me to know all
the gossip and the comings and goings in
the different towns
we hear rumors
and what were some of those rumors
regarding drug trafficking
[Music]
all kinds of things that he was involved
in illegal business that he had to do
with
some kinds of hotels
um
that he was having a very crazy life
that he was involved with marijuana that
he was the brother of two generals all
kinds of things tambien
it was also rumored that he was a dea
informer
and it's also rumored that he was
captured when he made a trip that was
not authorized by the dea
to your knowledge
did the cia the central intelligence
agency are the drug enforcement agency
or any other
u.s
agency
ever promote drug trafficking
as a means to raise money was that
subject ever brought up
with your organization
seriously this subject was never brought
up
quiero de jar clarocky i want to make
clear here repetitive and i want to
repeat
that i had problems with the cia where
we broke off our relations
on may 30th 1984.
and i left the war on may 16 1986
i went off to fish with a line and a
hook
and the whole scandal
of iran contra and the war broke out in
1987
[Music]
up until late in 1984 485 no drugs were
ever mentioned
not in exile not in the resistance not
in the contras
[Music]
this was a boom that took place after
1987.
and it's going to be recurring every
four years
in every election here in the united
states they're going to get into all
kinds of domestic political problems
with us in nicaragua
as a politician that i am i'm absolutely
convinced
that we're here talking today because of
internal political reasons in the united
states
for the national security of the united
states
has all the money in the world at its
disposal
and if the congress were to deny it any
money
i'm sure all they need to do is move
their pinky finger and general motors in
brazil
coca-cola or any international company
in nicaragua not the little war in
nicaragua
the gulf war is what they could finance
some politicos we're politicians
and we politicians understand these
things
well you understand the
the reason that the chairman's call
these hearings that there have been
serious very serious allegations
that the cia was involved in in a
conspiracy to bring in cocaine into the
u.s
that is wasting our youth in this
country
and
these these are serious problems very
serious and they demand serious answers
and an exhaustive investigation as
people have demanded and they should
demand it
sir i'm fully aware of the need for this
investigation
this is harming the youth of the united
states
the youth of all the world absolutely
it is also damaging the democratic
system of the world
and it is also damaging we the few
honest politicians who are left
when in the daily la nacion of costa
rica i read that the cia financed me
through drug trafficking
criminal this is a criminal statement
they are delegitimizing the sacrifice of
tens of thousands of people who've died
that's right
thank you mr chairman thank you very
much senator shelby
congresswoman
mr
pastora
it has been explained to you
the reason we're here
in these hearings
the san jose mercury news identified a
drug ring operating in los angeles
mr dinelio blandone
was one of the principals
and
he was being supplied drugs by mr nolan
meneses
mr norwin manesses comes from nicaragua
he was a drug dealer before he came to
the united states
no one can answer how he got into the
united states given his history and his
record
you knew him
mr calero knew him
he was a well-known drug dealer
before he came to the united states
and we are very much interested in
knowing
what you knew about him
and whether you knew
[Music]
he was a drug dealer so let me ask in
some other ways because you've been
asked
this several times today
are you familiar with the colleague
cartel
drug cartel
you ever hear of the colleague drug
cartels
all the dailies in the world mention it
well i'm not interested in knowing about
it from the dailies i'm interested
in knowing whether you knew
anything about their drug trafficking
and anybody associated with them any
discussions about them
in nicaragua or
in any of your uh
work that you were doing did you know
anything did you hear anything did you
understand what they do and how they do
it
i had no direct knowledge whatsoever the
narcotraffic
of the dal of the kali
or of the drug trafficking of any other
cartel
and with regard to what that newspaper
stated i would like to know the date of
that report
so you would have no way of knowing that
mr meneses was connected to the
colleague cartel
but your son-in-law was is that correct
no say
i don't know
is your son-in-law mr marcos aguado
is
look the relationship between meniscus
and marcos aguado i think goes back to
88 89 sorry 88 90 or 91 i'm not exactly
sure when
a question
familiar
i want to state here that the term
son-in-law is an internal moral family
problem
and i'm going to tell you the story
behind this
my daughter eloped with him without my
consent
for us latin americans this is a serious
thing
for those of us with conservative
customs and who have very strong morals
it's a very serious
perhaps you don't understand what i'm
trying to say
[Music]
and that relationship was broken off
1987 88 89 90 91 all the way up until
1995 or 96 when they finally got married
i am not trying to assign
anything to this relationship
the fact of the matter is
he was married to your daughter with or
without your consent and i have an
appreciation that maybe you didn't like
it you didn't want it but the fact of
the matter is uh he was married to your
daughter is that correct
foreign
yes i understand that and i am trying to
explain that as a result of these
actions all ties of friendship that i
had with marcos aguado were broken off i
have no knowledge of what he has done
and i have no responsibility for
whatever actions he may have taken i see
but was he also chief of the nicaraguan
contra air force
el salvador
he was not the chief of the contra air
force because we in the south were never
contrast
we fought against the political mistakes
that were made by the leadership at the
time
and aguado in 1995 1996
was the chief
but there was no structure at that time
they had stolen from us what aircraft we
had to be able to evacuate our people
who were wounded and this is something
that the cia knows
let me be the first to admit
that none of us may understand the
complications
of the organization of the contras
and we don't even have an appreciation
for
the fact that you would not fold in
uh with mr colero's
organization when the cia wanted you to
and this is what caused the rift between
you and the cia
but given we don't know all of the
nuances what we're trying to do is
establish some relationships
and when i refer to him
as your son-in-law and then i refer to
him as having a role such as chief
of the air force
i may not have all of the details
but what i'm trying to ask you is
did he have some kind of relationship
did you know of him
uh because of his leadership
uh with
an organization that may or may not have
been direct contra
etc you knew about him and what he did
you can be assured that up until 1990
94 95 up until 96 he had no relationship
with any cartel
no no
no no no
let him
was as surprised as i was yes
that is my belief
that is the way i see it
oh i'm sorry so what you're saying is
that
marcos aguado was surprised
when he learned about the drug dealing
of popo shimaru
and mr cesar
but what you did not know was
marcos aguado's connection to meneses is
that correct
uh
now the thing is that
marcos aguado's connection with meneses
was in 1988 89 90.
okay
when i talk about
marcos aguado surprised i'm referring to
the connection of popo and octaviano
with george morales
let me ask
did you know about
a business deal between marcos aguado
and mr meneses
where marcos aguado sold
mr meneses an auto transport trailer
were you familiar with the business deal
between the two of them
is
that was back in 1988 1989 at that time
we had broken off relations we were not
speaking to each other we had no contact
whatsoever with each other and this is
something i learned about
through newspapers and through
comments that i heard
in san juan
guanacaste costa rica i was fishing with
the lion and hook in manchester in costa
rica
all right well let me
let me go back and
restate a few things
we all know for sure without a doubt
that mr danilio blandone was selling
drugs in los angeles
we all know about the raids on the
properties and we all know that he is a
dea informant we all know this and he's
been for a long time
you knew mr danilo blandon
he gave you some money
and he gave you some pickup trucks
we know that he was a drug dealer
we can reasonably conclude that
the money that you got from him
was drug money
profits from drugs that were sold
in south central and other places
unless of course you know
about
another way that mr danilo blandone was
earning money
if you
know that he had
income
from other sources maybe legitimate
sources perhaps you can share them with
us or we will continue to
believe and understand and know
that this drug dealer
made profits from drugs and he gave you
some of it to help you out
do you know anything different
you know where he got his money from
yo
when i would go through los angeles
we're talking about
very quick visits i would make through
the city i would stay for one maybe two
at most three days
and
people
people as everyone knows would have to
live there to really know what's going
on in a city to know what people are
discussing to know things about other
people who live there
i did not talk with everyone when i was
in the city of los angeles
when i saw blandon in la this was a man
who had a business going he had a car
dealership
and in the three to four years that i
knew him
all the money that he gave me was a
total of six thousand dollars three
thousand and three thousand this was not
an abnormal sum it was not a sum that
was out of the ordinary in any way
when he helped me out in 1987 or 88 i
was working in a fishing cooperative
and i was in very dire straits i was
really really in in a very bad situation
he gave me two pickups each of them
worth at most fifteen hundred dollars in
fact i used one of them simply to pay
off debts
this to me at the time was normal it was
explainable
i don't know what his situation was
actually all i can say is that when i
saw him in his business he had a
dealership and i saw 20 30 maybe 50 cars
in that dealership it looked like he was
doing well
and we knew of him as a man who had
always had money in fact he was regarded
in nicaragua as a millionaire he was a
member of the blandon family a family
that had always been very well to do
if his
contributions to me had been sixty or a
hundred thousand dollars that would have
been a very different story but with
three and three thousand dollars we're
talking about peanuts and his story was
not unlike that of many other people who
gave us small contributions simply so
that they could brag that they had made
contributions to us and they could say
we gave money to comandante
all right let me just try and wrap this
up um
you knew mr danielio blandon you lived
in
one of his houses you knew mr meneses
your
relative
was somehow associated with him but it
was after
your association with your relative long
after you had parted ways
uh but uh
he was involved in some kind of business
with him to buy some transport and i'll
just inform you uh that the testimony on
record is that that transport was for
the purposes of of uh transporting drugs
but let me just add another to the list
of people that you knew
who everybody understands or drug
dealers have been convicted or
identified mr john
hall the american
rancher did he not have an airstrip
see
yes
i did not say yes to everything i just
used the expression yes
but you knew mr john oh now wait a
minute
yes
i knew john hall
i knew of that airstrip but when i say i
knew or knew of i'm simply saying that
these are things that i saw
a normal business
we are not friends i do not know him and
we've never had any kind of relationship
uh
john hall the farmer rancher landowner
no tengo por quementiro cultural godel i
have no reason to lie about him or hide
anything about him aquiver
he came here many times to propose that
i had to be done away with and i don't
want to use any foul language here mel
diabla
he hated me deciated
but coming here and saying that i know
that him being involved with drug
trafficking is something i cannot do i
am not aware of that
last two questions you volunteered
that you
knew about or heard about
danielle blandon's relationship to the
dea
and or manesses
which one of them did you refer to
as taking an unauthorized trip
to the united states
for the purposes of drug dealing who
were you referring to
in nicaragua all of this story about
norven meneses came out
danilo blandon
and with regard to danilo blandon
contodo
and on top of everything he was even
even able to save money
that's something that leads to comment
among people
and to statements
all of this is gossip hearsay
tales none of this has any kind of
objective backing whatsoever
finally did you hear the gossip and the
tales about the airstrip and what do you
understand
was
coming into that airstrip and going out
of that airstrip of john hulls in costa
rica
in los angeles
well at that time we're talking about
1986 87 88 89.
there was talk about two airstrips
john hall's airstrip
in guanacaste costa rica and one
airstrip that had been built in
guanacaste costa rica
la pista
john hall's airstrip was shut down
because he uh
he was being persecuted by the costa
rican authorities
so
[Music]
it was used in 1984 85 and 86.
the other airstrip
voyager was built
it was built for political reasons
as we in ardee had an airstrip in the
south
resistance
in guanacaste the other resistance
movement was obliged to build an
airstrip in guanacaste
i am not aware of any information on
those two airstrips
i have had absolutely no dealings with
the cia i know nothing at all of their
movement since 1984.
and as of mid 1986 i have had no
dealings with anything or anyone at all
and all i have been doing is fishing
with a line and a hook in the seat
mr chairman if you're just indulge me
one last according to witnesses
congressman waters like to bring it to a
close we have been over this ground
considerably but if you have another
question proceed
thank you according to witnesses before
the carey committee
octavio cesar and
mr chamarro participated in arranging
the smuggling of two shipments of
cocaine
400 kilos each from costa rica
by way of the dirt airstrip of john hall
to florida
in the late summer of 1984
according to the testimony of witnesses
and participants one of those flights
that landed at a public airport in south
florida
due to the fact that according to the
co-pilots
uh both um
octaviano
and popo
had assured morales that the flight was
to be protected by the cia
can you comment
and have you heard anything regarding
their activities with mr morales in the
summer and early fall of 1984.
that's it this is your last chance mr
pesto
no
thank you very much thank you very much
congresswoman waters
the intelligence committee will be
proceeding
uh with our inquiries further this has
been a very unusual hearing
and this is a very unusual matter
and
we have heard a number of comments from
people in the audience and
anybody who wants to come forward we'd
be glad to take whatever information you
have or whatever suggestions you have
there were some comments about a number
of witnesses
when director deutsch was in los angeles
a number of people made comments from
the audience and we are pursuing
issues which they have raised
what we are trying to do is to separate
the gossip the hearsay and the tales
from
from what the facts are
i was determined at our hearing on
october 23rd when we had
a much bigger audience and a good bit
more response not to have the story of
the hearing uh the people were this was
a closed-up hearing or there was a
cover-up or people were excluded
and as you saw when the police officers
came forward i wanted to move away don't
want to have the conclusion of this
hearing
that anybody was uh tossed out or
anybody didn't have a full say
and congressman waters has done a lot of
work on this matter which i know and
respect
and when she said she wanted to
have some questions
we invited her here we do have
proceedings where there are joint
hearings with the house and the senate
she is a member of the united states
congress and
in my discretion seemed to me
appropriate to
have congresswoman waters join us and
she had quite a lot to say and a lot of
latitude on questions and comments and
her own views and
she's entitled to them as my friend uh
congress senator simpson used
everybody's entitled their own opinions
not their own facts necessarily and
that's what we want to try to try to
find out
what the facts are but if anybody here
has anything further
that they want to call to our attention
step forward and we will listen to you
thank you very much and that concludes
our hearing you've got somebody coming
forward just come forward and the staff
will talk to you thank you
okay
oh yeah
um
[Music]
patrick moynihan will begin at 11 a.m
next allegations of cia drug trafficking
monday the house select committee on
intelligence heard testimony concerning
a report alleging the agency's
involvement in trafficking cocaine to
the los angeles area
florida congressman porter goss chaired
yesterday's hearing which includes
testimony from california
representatives maxine waters and
juanita millander mcdonald
okay
[Music]
[Music]
committee will be in order
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen the
committee house permanent sect committee
on intelligence
is here today to review the report of
the cia inspector general regarding
allegations made in a 1996 newspaper
series
that the cia was involved in the
trafficking of crack cocaine california
during the 1980s
before we begin i'd like to advise
members of the public today of how we
intend to proceed with a hearing
the house national security committee
has graciously allowed us the use of
this room this afternoon and we
appreciate it and say thank you for that
we have been advised however that our
lease on this base does expire
at approximately five o'clock and so
we're planning that our proceedings will
end accordingly
at the conclusion of my opening
statement i will recognize my colleagues
on the committee for any opening remarks
they wish to make and i'm advised they
do
then we will proceed to hear from
members of congress who are not on our
committee who have indicated their
interest in sharing their assessment
of the cia ig report we will then
proceed with the testimony of mr
frederick p hitz the inspector general
of the cia
beginning his presentation no later than
4 pm
i thank all president here today for
assisting us in
sticking to this schedule
today's hearing marks an important step
in the ongoing process of inquiry the
intelligence committee has undertaken to
assess the validity of highly serious
allegations presented in a three-part
series
of newspaper articles published in the
san jose mercury news at the end of the
summer of 1996.
those articles detailed allegations that
the cia was involved
with or was somehow complicit in the
trafficking of crack cocaine to
california during the 1980s
the articles further alleged that
proceeds from those transactions were
used to assist in financing the
activities of the resistance movement in
nicaragua known to most of us simply as
the contras
this committee undertook an
investigation into these charges in the
fall of 1996.
since that time we have interviewed more
than two dozen individuals who may have
knowledge or information relevant to the
allegations put forth in the san jose
mercury news stories
in addition we have reviewed many
thousands of pages of original documents
from the cia
that have direct relevance to our
inquiry
during this time two separate inspector
general investigations have been
conducted
the cia ig's review which is the subject
of today's hearing resulted in the
public release in january of this year
of volume one of an expected two-volume
report a second volume which goes beyond
the allegations relating to the
california story
is we are told nearing completion
there has also been an investigation
conducted by the inspector general of
department of justice
although that inquiry isn't concluded we
are told we have also been advised that
the attorney general the department of
uh doj is for the time being withholding
public release of the ig's report
based on law enforcement concerns
as we proceed with our own inquiry our
committee is grateful for the work of
the ciaig
on the matter before us it is my
judgment based on a careful reading of
volume one of the report which is a
public document
that it is thorough and it represents
months of careful review of the
allegations and relevant facts
pertaining to the allegations raised in
the san jose mercury news
given the serious nature of the
allegations that had been raised this
investigation has to be especially
thorough and persistent
of course we are continuing to conduct
our own independent inquiry into this
matter as part of our proper oversight
responsibilities
we are keenly aware that this entire
episode has fueled suspicion some people
have about the advent of the scourge of
crack cocaine in the united states
any suggestion of government complicity
and that terrible outcome
is one that must be seriously considered
and answered
it is our obligation as the committee
charged with the responsibility of
overseeing the cia to address these
concerns to examine the facts as
exhaustively as possible
it will be extremely difficult to come
up with an absolute answer that will
remove all doubt
such as the nature of these cases
that said i believe the american people
have a right to expect us to do a
conscientious job in understanding the
facts and in offering conclusions from
this committee about the charges that
have been made
i believe that the ciaig has presented
our committee with a solid body of work
that will assist us in that regard
and we intend to consider his
conclusions very carefully
that is exactly what we are doing today
and what we will continue to do until we
are satisfied that we have fully
reviewed this matter
our inquiry will continue as we proceed
to conduct interviews and research as
necessary we will review the additional
work product of the ciaig when it
becomes available to us as well as the
doj ig report when the attorney general
releases it
additional hearings and public
statements by this committee as to the
progress of our work will be forthcoming
as we deem appropriate in the committee
with that let me again welcome our
witness today my colleagues
and i yield to mr dicks for opening
remarks he wished may wish to make and
other members as well we welcome mrs
herman
and mr gibbons who have come in since
the gavel went down mr dicks
mr chairman
it would be difficult to overstate the
seriousness of the allegations generated
by the series of articles that appeared
in the san jose mercury news in august
of 1996
that any agency of government would be
charged with being associated with
illegal activity is bad enough that the
allegations would involve the cia whose
activities must necessarily take place
in secret and are therefore not
generally scrutinized by the public make
it worse
add the fact that the illegal activity
involved narcotics trafficking one of
the chief law enforcement and security
challenges facing the nation
and the reason for concern in congress
within the administration to include the
president and in the country should be
obvious
early in september of 1996
after being assured by director of
central intelligence john deutsch that
the cia's inspector general would
conduct a thorough investigation of the
issues raised by the mercury news ish
series i asked the committee's former
chairman congressman larry combust that
our panel conduct its own inquiry i
commend mr conbess for his decision to
authorize a committee review and i
commend our current chairman mr goss for
his decision in march of 1997 when he
became chairman to to rededicate the
committee to this effort as a priority
in the 105th congress
i continue to believe that as important
as reports of the cia and the justice
department inspector generals are the
committee's independent inquiry is
essential
i've seen mr hitz's investigation
characterized as the most extensive
undertaken by the inspector general the
statistics on numbers of pages of
documents reviewed and numbers of people
interviewed are impressive the task of
proving a negative is always daunting at
least in part because you begin with a
certain knowledge that you cannot reach
conclusions with which everyone will
agree
the best defense against unjustifiable
criticism of an investigation of this
kind however is to ensure that it is and
as exhaustive as possible
in the two-page summary of volume one
released by the cia on january 29th 1998
the phrase no information has been found
was used nine times
i want to be assured that this phrase
was meant to convey the message that no
information was found on a certain point
because none existed rather than the
message that the information not was not
found because the effort to find it was
not thorough enough the public's
judgment about the adequacy of the work
of the inspector general's investigators
will be what ultimately sustains or
calls into question the conclusions of
this report there have been published
criticisms by at least one of those
contacted by mr hitz's staff that the
interview seemed to be designed to go
through the motions i want mr hitz who
i've known and have great respect for to
assure us that he is satisfied that the
investigation was as thorough as
necessary to uncover the facts on the
matter at hand
i understand that a number of persons
almost all of them former cia officials
either refused to be interviewed or
sought to limit the interviews at least
one of the individuals who refused to be
interviewed by the inspector general
showed no similar reluctance to be
interviewed by the press
i consider the failure of these people
to assist the inspector general in this
investigation to be inexcusable the
president the attorney general and the
director of central intelligence
promised the american people in 1996
that the executive branch's inquiry
would get to the bottom of the mercury
news related charges
that effort has not been helped by the
decision by some individuals not to be
cooperative i look forward to discussing
with these individuals soon the reasons
for their decisions and the information
they may have about the subject of the
inspector general's inquiry when dci
tenant released the volume one report on
january 29th he noted that the concern
at the cia that the allegations had left
an indelible impression that the cia was
somehow responsible for the inner city
drug scourge and that nothing could be
done to undo that damage caused by that
false impression it is regrettable
indeed that what was at stake for the
cia's reputation in this matter was not
more clearly seen by all of those from
whom the inspector general sought
cooperation
one of my chief concerns in this matter
has been that the investigation not be
too narrowly focused i wrote to dci
deutsch in september of 1996 advising
him that i was particularly interested
in the extent of knowledge by cia
officials of any involvement of members
of the nicaraguan contras
or individuals associated with them in
in drug running activities when that
knowledge was obtained and what was done
with the information i was assured by
the by a c i a official on september
17th that the director shares your view
that the extent and disposition of any
knowledge by c i a officials of contra
involvement and drug trafficking must be
assessed i understand that much of that
assessment takes place in volume two and
i look forward to discussing it with the
inspector general when that volume is
made available to us mr chairman i look
forward as well to the comments our
congressional committee will have on mr
hitz's work i encourage them to make
available to us any information they may
have on the matters before us i welcome
them and i welcome mr hitz and his
presentation
thank you mr chairman
thank you mr dicks very much
i have been advised other members wish
to have opening remarks uh at this time
i recognize distinguished gentleman from
california mr julian
dixon thank you very much mr chairman i
join you and the ranking minority member
in welcoming members of congress and mr
fred hitz inspector general of the
intelligence central intelligence agency
let me begin by saying that i've read
the inspector general's report entitled
allegations of connections between the
cia and the contras
in cocaine trafficking in the united
states volume one the california story
i find the section of the report that
chronicles the political history of
nicaragua from 1912 when u.s marines
occupied nicaragua to protect u.s
economic interests until the elections
of viola shimura on february 25th 1990
was extremely valuable and insightful
for it's important to know that the
contrast never were a single unitary
organization
the term contrast meaning
counter-revolutionaries
was one used to identify organized
forces opposed to the sandinista regime
my view one cannot begin to understand
the forces that play in nicaragua's
revolution without having this
historical recounting as a foundation
it is apparent to me that nicaraguans of
various political persuasions made
financial contributions to the contras
and to the sandinistas
some of these contributions were
undoubtedly were the results of proceeds
from illegal activities such as
narcotics trafficking
nevertheless the mere fact that an
organization receives support from the
fruits of illegal activities does not
necessarily mean that the organization
itself nor its causes are illegitimate
for example ricky ross acknowledges
donating some of his crack proceeds to
inner city community programs these
programs provide alternative
after-school activities for our youth
and are worthwhile and valuable and in
no way diminish are diminished by the
fact that some drug proceeds contributed
to the operating capabilities
as has been said by the chairman and the
ranking member we're here today as a
result of a three-part series of
articles entitled dark alliance
published in the san jose mercury news
this series of articles alleged that the
cia in conjunction with nicaraguan drug
network introduced crack cocaine into
los angeles and then funneled proceeds
from the sales of crack to contrast to
help fund their war against the ruling
sandinista government
in the high speed of the digital age of
information technology the dark alliance
series quickly spread from beyond the
mercury news readers
the series was placed on the paper's
website of the internet where according
to the mercury news it received more
than a thousand hits a week
additionally talk show stations made it
their leading story for weeks
and network television gave considerable
time to reporting the story on the
evening news
the fact that the story has result
resonated so powerfully outside the
minority communities should not come as
a surprise
the plague of crack is no different from
the way that alcohol and other drugs
have infiltrated communities across
america leaving a path of death and
destruction in its wake
there are no sole alliances between
crack cocaine and minority communities
the spread of crack cocaine and
predominantly majority suburban
communities is well documented and no
longer remains a secret
whether drug use occurs in minority or
majority communities is not the issue
i firmly believe that we in congress as
well as the administration have placed a
tremendous amount of emphasis
as well as dedicated resources to
efforts designed to combat narcotics
drugs tear at the very fiber of our
nation the family structure
caucasian
asian african-american and hispanic
families have begun to destab be
destabilized by drugs resulting in lost
generations of our youth and raising
drug related crimes the allegation that
an entity of the federal government may
have been involved in the trafficking of
crack cocaine in any community of
america are serious charges and deserve
the attentious detention of the highest
level of government
as a demonstration of the seriousness
attached to the mercury news allegations
as mr
dicks has indicated the former director
of central intelligence agency john
dortch made an appearance in south
central los angeles to reaffirm his
commitment to undertake a thorough
internal investigation
and to definitively respond to all
questions surrounding this matter
today's hearing hearing is an extension
of this committee's commitment to
effectively discharge our oversight
responsibility and independently invest
investigate the allegations raised by
this series of articles
in the aftermath of the mercury news
series a number of newspapers initiated
their own investigation of the
allegations of cia involvement in drug
trafficking in support of the contras
the los angeles times was one newspaper
and concluded and i quote that crack
epidemic in los angeles followed no
blueprint or master plan it was not
orchestrated by the contrast or the cia
or any single drug ring
no one trafficker even the king
pins who sold thousands of kilos and
pocketed millions of dollars ever came
close to monopolizing the trade end of
quote the new york times and the
washington post to reach similar
conclusions as a result of their own
independent investigation
after allegations raised by a postscript
mercury news article
is that within 48 hours of the execution
of a search warrant by the los angeles
county sheriff's department on a number
of alleged contra sympathizers cia
agents showed up at the sheriff's
department and removed evidence that had
been seized the sheriff's department of
los angeles county has investigated
these allegations
along with assertions that local
narcotics agents knew that a drug ring
operated by nicaraguan control rebels
was selling large amounts of cocaine and
using the profits to support the armed
conflict in nicaragua
the sheriff's department's investigation
concluded that no evidence had been
found
and that no materials had been removed
from their custody by anybody and that
there was no evidence to support the
claim that local law enforcement
officers knew of a nicaraguan-backed
cocaine ring
the house intelligence committee is in
possession of a four-volume sheriff's
report totaling more than four thousand
papers on sunday may 11 the san jose
mercury news executive editor
jerry sepps wrote an article entitled to
the readers of our dark alliance series
that identified certain shortcoming
comings in the dark alliance article
specifically mr sepps asserted that
quote in a few instances we presented
only one interpretation of complicated
sometimes conflicting pieces of evidence
in one instance we did not include
information that contradicted a central
assertion of the series
we made our best estimate of how much
money was involved but we failed to
label it as an estimate and instead
reported it as fact
we oversimplified the complex issue of
how crack
epidemic in america grew and through the
in precise language and graphics we
created impressions that were open to
misinterpretation
notwithstanding the conclusions mr
chairman by various newspapers the sex
article the sheriff's department
internal investigation and the cia
inspector general this committee
firmly has a responsibility
to
independently review the dark alliance
series
our investigator our investigations are
no substitute for the role this
committee has
has in reviewing these serious
allegations
we have convened today this hearing is
one step only one step in our
investigatory process
and we are determined to discharge our
oversight responsibility in a thorough
and professional manner
to that end i recognize that no matter
how thorough any investigation may be
there will be skeptics who will
challenge whatever conclusions are
reached it is not possible to persuade
every individual with preordained
conclusions to change them
we will do
what we will do is present the facts as
we find them and then make conclusions
based on these facts
mr chairman has earlier stated although
the san jose mercury news dark line
series deals with the african-american
community in south central los angeles
this imp this issue impacts all
americans the possibility that the
government may have been involved in
drug trafficking activities threatens
the credibility of all government
agencies and entities a government of
the people and by the people must not be
permitted to engage in such activities
when allegations of government abuse
come to our attention we're obligated to
use whatever resources necessary to
fully and professionally investigate the
charges and finally mr chairman i would
like to thank the committee staff who
have in my view diligently worked on
this investigation to date
there is a lot of work to be done but i
appreciate the cooperation that we have
received from our staffs
thank you mr dixon i would like to point
out that i too am grateful for the
particular attention you have given this
matter surely uh with your many duties
the extra work you've put in on this is
well noticed and much appreciated
i'd like to advise members who came in
late that
we have uh two speakers i know of who
two of our colleagues who wish to
address us and they've been advised they
will have about 10 minutes each we are
trying to start mr hitz at four o'clock
if you look at the clock on the wall you
will understand my admonition that the
opening statements be kept within reason
please mr skelton
thanks mr chairman i joined my
colleagues in welcoming our
congressional witnesses
and the inspector general of the central
intelligence agency mr fred hintz
to our committee this afternoon
as a ranking democratic committee of the
national security committee i'm well
aware of the commitment that our
nation's defense establishment has made
to combating the importation of drugs
into our country
an allegation that an agency of the
federal government is alleged to have
been involved in trafficking cocaine
into the united states
while other federal agencies including
the defense department
are dedicating personnel and resources
to fighting a war against drugs mr
chairman is horrendous
i am pleased that this committee is
investigating these allegations
and to the greatest extent possible
holding hearings in a public forum so
that the american public can review our
proceedings it's important that any
inquiry to first obtain
all the facts is necessary once the
facts are collected they can be analyzed
and conclusions can be reached today's
hearing is part of the information
gathering process
the facts brought out by this hearing
will become part of the factual basis
that this committee uses to reach a
final conclusion
as has already been stated by my
colleagues the cia inspector general is
working on volume two of his report that
addresses matters related to cia's
knowledge of drug trafficking by the
contras or persons associated with a
contra movement
additionally the justice department
inspector general has completed his
report and the committee is awaiting its
receipt i do not believe it's possible
to reach conclusions
until all the facts have been received i
look forward to today's testimony in the
hopes that it will shed additional light
on this matter i also want to commend mr
fred hitz and thank him for his service
and dedication as the cia's inspector
general
and possession of inspector general is
often a lonely one
frequently inspectors generally are
criticized by the public when their
reports do not verify alleged misconduct
and their objectivity is then called
into question
within an agency inspector general is
sometimes viewed as the villain who is
out to harm the image and reputation of
the agency mr hitz you've weathered all
types of criticism and have always
maintained a professional attitude
i wish you all the best and whatever the
future holds for you and again thank you
for your service mr chairman thank you
thank you mr skelton ms harman of
california
thank you mr chairman i have a statement
which i'd like to submit for the record
but i
i would however like to make a couple of
summary points
first
i'd like to point out to the audience
that a majority of the committee members
are here and i think that that uh speaks
to the
importance that we give to this issue
and i too would like to commend our
colleague mr dixon for his enormous
personal attention
on behalf of all of us
second point uh i did participate in two
community forums hosted by our colleague
miss melender mcdonald i'd like to
commend her for
uh the work that she did and and uh the
abuse that she took and
um the the effect it had on this member
to clarify for me how
really explosive this issue is in a
community
that has been wracked by cocaine abuse
and
i want to state to her and to all of you
how seriously i take this issue finally
mr chairman i i just want to say that at
the root of all this is
is one word trust
a democratic society simply cannot
function if the people believe that
government agencies and officials
participate in or condone illegal
activities
and restoring trust
will not be easy but it is nonetheless
an essential exercise for this committee
speaking for one member
we cannot shirk from that responsibility
nor do i fear
feel
we will and i want to thank you for a
few minutes of time yield back
thank you ms harmon very much ms pelosi
thank you very much mr chairman i want
to commend you and our ranking member
for having this uh public hearing
unusual one for us on this committee and
i too want to commend mr dixon for the
attention uh that he the leadership that
he has provided on this issue i still
have many questions and i look forward
to the inspector general's
presentation as well as the other
witnesses here today
this is an issue of great concern in my
community san francisco that i represent
in the congress for a long time before
this issue ever came to the forefront
there was a suspicion uh in our
community that the african-american
community was a target particularly
women in the african-american uh
community were a target of a of a
campaign to provide crack to them the
suspicions were that this would be to
lead to undermining the african-american
community by undermining the family it's
a terrible terrible thought but people
did come together in large meetings
in our community on this subject long
before this issue that we're dealing
with today was involved add to that
around the same time
the the contra issue was debate was
raging in the congress of the united
states we know how long the iran contra
hearings went on to see if there was a
sale of weapons to iran profits of which
to be diverted to the
uh contra circumventing congress on that
issue so
when this issue became public there was
already a foundation of distrust and
while we all know many of us know more
about uh the valuable contribution the
central intelligence agency has made we
also know of some shortcomings in the
trust department between the american
people
and the agency so you have a climate
where people are saying what's happening
to our community
crack the cheapness of it the
availability of is undermining our
community who's doing this to us
secondly why isn't somebody how can we
stop it
therefore when this story hit it had
there was a climate that made it a
credible story i myself do not think
that the reach so-called retraction of
the san jose american news was of the
was that weighty it was you know a few
instances we did this we made an assert
we did not include an assertion that
contradicted where an error about the
money and oversimplified
that's not exactly a major retraction so
i still have and my constituents more
importantly my constituents still have
some serious questions about this as
well as the um
particular interest uh that we have in
the um
the frog man the uh
the um uh
less attention has been paid to
allegations concerning northern
california particularly so-called
frogman case during the prosecution of
this case the u s attorney for northern
district of california agreed to return
approximately thirty six thousand
dollars in cash seized from one
defendant in this narcotic prosecution
after two exiled contra supporters wrote
letters filed with the court that the
money was for the reinstatement of
democracy uh in nicaragua and that is in
quote so therefore i look forward uh to
hearing from the inspector general uh
concerning his findings that there's no
information that the cia had any
connection with the defendants in the
frogman case and that there's no
information that the contras benefited
from the drug crafting trafficking of
the frogman case and i also
anticipate questions whether officials
of the cia hampered in any way the
investigation of the prosecution of this
matter because it hits us so directly at
home
in our community in northern california
i still have some questions even though
i have reviewed the report once again mr
chairman thank you for allowing us to
have these questions out in the open
thank you miss closing mr skaggs
thank you mr chairman i'll be very brief
i join in thanking the chair for
calling these hearings what as well to
express my respect and appreciation for
mr dixon's contribution to this effort
but want to make a special point of
recognizing the public service of fred
hitz to the country and to the central
intelligence agency
uh i've known him for some time
independent of his current position
and what i have to say i think really
picks up on ms harmon's
comment about trust
even this committee
authorized and
assisted as we are by able staff to look
into the workings of the intelligence
community
ultimately have
to rely on trust ourselves
in sorting out fact from fiction from
innuendo
the key individual
with regard to the central intelligence
agency in
establishing and nurturing a sense of
trustworthiness in all of this
is the inspector general in the person
of mr hitz
i believe his conduct in office and his
execution of his responsibilities have
been absolutely key
during my service on the committee to
establishing the kind of
trustworthiness in both directions that
enables us to do our work for our
colleagues and for the american people
and fred i just want to say thank you
very much and godspeed
thank you mrs
miss gibbons
thank you mr chairman and i joined my
colleagues in uh commending you for
having this hearing today and i want to
thank you for bringing it before the
public as well
the importance and the seriousness of
the allegations that have been before
this committee on this issue merit this
type of a hearing
and
especially the proper resolution that
this hearing can give this matter is
critical critical both to the confidence
of the american people in their agencies
critical to this oversight committee in
its work that it must do in looking at
and deciding these types of issues
you know our nation
depends upon this
information
and it must have the confidence in the
information
that it is not tainted
tainted by any illegal act
an act that might undermine
our ability to rely on this information
and it must not
have any taint of illegality for the
agency
itself
those agencies that provide valuable
intelligence for anti-drug economic or
military information must themselves as
i've said earlier be untainted by
illegal acts or even the innuendo of an
illegality the importance of this
hearing today will hopefully clear the
air on these issues rebuild the
confidence between the citizens of this
country and our intelligence agencies
and finally
help
in an equally important matter to
rebuild the credibility
and our confidence in the information
and intelligence that we receive from
these agencies the men and women of our
intelligence gathering
agencies deserve no less than our
complete confidence in their work to
promote a better america i look forward
to the testimony of the witnesses
welcoming them here today thank you mr
chairman
thank you mr gibbons
opening statements are completed it's at
this time that we welcome colleagues who
are not on the committee for
their commentary on the report that is
the subject of this hearing it is the
report of the investigation allegations
of connections between cia and the
contras in cocaine trafficking to the
united states volume one the california
story january 29
1998 as presented by frederick p hitz
who we were hearing from
it had been my intention to call members
in order of seniority but i have been
advised
that the senior member of the two that
we
expected to hear from has deferred
to
juanita melinda mcdonald to come forward
first
since you have been out front in trying
to help us on this matter and come to
grips with it
and that indeed have had hearings in
your district
and have had direct involvement and we
welcome you today we welcome your
commentary on the report and the
observations you may have for us
thank you
thank you mr chairman and members of the
committee
before i began my testimony please allow
me a moment to express my appreciation
to you chairman goss
and you rankin member dix
for your efforts and those of your
colleagues on the house permanent select
committee of intelligence
to wait through the moross of
allegations
stemming from press reports of the
central intelligence agency's
involvement in drug trafficking in south
central los angeles
i would especially like to acknowledge
my southern california colleagues on the
committee
congress members jerry lewis
julian dixon and jane harman
as well as congressional black caucus
chairwoman maxine waters
and california delegation co-chairwoman
lucille ralbal allard
their support of my efforts to give
voice to the concerns of my constituents
in the immediate aftermath
of the controversial press reports
alleging cia wrongdoing
was encouraging and meant a great deal
to me and the residents of california's
37th congressional district
mr chairman and committee members
i commend the chairman for fulfilling
his commitment to hold this hearing
like the chairman i too was deeply
disturbed by the allegations as reported
in the san jose mercury news in august
of 1996
of the central intelligence agency's
involvement in the introduction
financing and distribution of crack
cocaine in the 1980s
consequently i contacted administration
officials
the appropriate leaders of the house of
representatives
and even the former u.n secretary
general
to ask their respective organizations to
look into these allegations
i also wrote to the mayors of major
urban cities
many of whom responded by confirming
that their cities
witnessed a significant increase in drug
trafficking and proliferation of cocaine
use and abuse during the same time
period
on september 11th
i introduce house resolution 518
to establish a special select committee
to look into these allegations
i did so mr chairman not with any intent
to slay the permanent select committee
but because i believe the persistence of
issues raised by this and other
controversies about the cia's
accountability the agency's ability to
investigate itself
the public's desire and need for the
truth
and the agency's mission in a post-cold
war world
require much broader congressional
involvement
in these important proceedings
as many of you are aware i convened two
town hall meetings in the fall of 1996
in response to the widespread feelings
of anxiety public outrage and concern
throughout my district
in the wake of news accounts which
seemed to implicate the cia and drug
trafficking in the early and mid 1980s
in south central los angeles and urban
america
the first town hall meeting at compton
community college on october 19 1996
was attended by hundreds of residents
from my drug ravaged community
the purpose of the compton congressional
inquiry was to educate myself
and other members of congress about the
pacific issues raised by allegations of
u.s government involvement in
and knowledge of drug trafficking in
south central los angeles i also sought
out
how the local community responded to the
widespread harm caused by the scourge of
substance abuse regardless of the source
or cause and allowed them to seek
answers to these allegations
i invited the
justice inspector general michael
bromwich to come and meet with leaders
and members of the community so that
they could express their concerns mr
brownwick observed the proceedings of
the congressional inquiry and took notes
with a number of panelists testifying
including ricky ross mother and ricky
ross himself via telephone from the san
jose detention center
on november 15th in response to my
invitation then director of central
intelligence john dortch made an
unprecedented visit to allen locke high
school in the watts section of my
district to directly address the
concerns raised by my constituents and
me
gender generated by these allegations
during a public town hall meeting
his visit illustrated a new openness
within the agency to wrestle with the
issues
raised by the san jose mercury news
press reports as well as the persistent
skepticism with which the cia denials of
wrongdoing have been met by the public
those media reports some of which have
since been retracted suggested that the
crack cocaine trade which has devastated
whole communities was promulgated by
official government activities under the
aegis of the central intelligence
committee agency i'm sorry while the
public forum received widespread media
coverage
a private meeting with community leaders
activists and elected officials provided
them with an opportunity to express
their concerns and pose our questions
directly to former director deutsch
i am here today to articulate some of
the concerns my constituents and i have
about this report and the ongoing
controversy
first this report is merely the first
volume of two and focuses on the
allegations of connections between the
cia and the contras as alleged in the
san jose mercury news
a second unpublished volume presumes to
address the findings
related to the cia's knowledge of any
other alleged drug trafficking by the
countries or other persons associated
with the contra operation
release of a third report prepared by
the inspector general of the department
of justice has been withheld on order of
the the attorney general
consequently the results of the internal
investigations by the cia and the
department of justice have yet to
materialize
therefore the report is limited in scope
nevertheless several questions related
to this first volume continue to be
raised did cia personnel or assets have
any involvement in supplying or
assisting drug traffickers in south
central los angeles and or elsewhere
the report answers this question in the
negative however what are we to make of
the questions raised by defense attorney
howard harold braun a panelist at the
october 19th inquiry who maintains that
a suspect in the custody of the los
angeles county
deputy sheriff's was allowed to make a
long-distance telephone call to virginia
after asserting he worked for the cia
what evidence do we have in this report
that this allegation was or is being
pursued given the report does not
mention investigation of telephone logs
and if so
why
that the cia aggressively pursue its
role concluding the charge to collect
produce and disseminate intelligence on
foreign aspects of narcotics production
and trafficking when it received
information about possible contra
involvement in drug trafficking
we apparently have to wait until volume
2 to know the answer to this question
however the information provided in this
report suggests that the cia turned a
blind eye at best to information that
suggests drug trafficking by contra
operatives
did the cia personnel intercede on
behalf of any nicaraguan
nicaraguan contra figures or nationals
opposed to the sandinistas government
and any drug related investigation or
prosecution by local state or federal
personnel
this report responds to specific
allegations but the report does not
address what the cia could or should
have done in pursuing the portion of the
agency's charge that relates to
collecting producing and disseminating
intelligence on far foreign aspects of
narcotics production and trafficking
it remains unclear to me what the cia
actually did to investigate or direct
its intelligence assets to determine
whether any countries were engaged in
drug trafficking
ship the quarter of a million pages of
documents reviewed for this first volume
be declassified and made available for
public inspection
and the ultimate question is can the cia
investigate itself
the central intelligence is unique among
government agencies by its very nature
the cia's secrets and the rules of
confidentiality make investigations
difficult
investigations into wrongdoing start at
a disadvantage which turns the usual
rules of american justice on its head
as the presumption of innocence is com
compromised by the agency's secrecy and
the classification of documents
we are being asked to trust career
employees of the agency to sort out and
report the truth in the name of national
security indeed news reports which
followed leaks regarding the content of
this report last december suggest that
some cia personnels were neither nor
seriously interviewed nor
nor not questioned at all about what
they knew
as a result the public remains skeptical
some will perceive that this hearing is
premature and that this report by itself
does not adequately address the
allegations of the san jose mercury news
that prompted the public outcry
to its credit the series shed light on
some very real problems that require
real solutions from substance abuse to
cia accountability
i look forward to subsequent hearings by
this committee upon release of the other
reports at which time we may all be in a
better position to make judgments
nevertheless i hope that the select
committee will give their content
methodologies and findings the scrutiny
they deserve and in a similar spirit of
openness make themselves available to my
constituents to respond to any questions
these reports generate i believe such
openness is critical to restoration of
the credibility and public trust
necessary to allow intelligence
gathering activities which by their
nature are security to coexist with
democracy thank you mr chairman and
members
thank you very much mr milan mcdonald
that was a refined statement and you've
raised some specific questions for the
committee to take under consideration
and we shall
just needed to advise you uh your
observation that some may consider this
hearing premature uh interestingly
enough there are some who consider it to
be late as well uh it's hard to get it
all right all the time uh one of the
reasons we felt it was important to have
this hearing at this time is because mr
hitz is
on to greater glories
with new employment we are advised and
we wanted to make sure we had the
opportunity for him to has explained his
report to us uh as he could and that is
why we decided to do this to stay and mr
chairman this is some of the problems
that my constituents have they say by
the time they get accustomed to one
person he then leaves and there's a new
person on their horizon and therefore
they are not just truth they're not
really sure whether or not those persons
really have their teeth into the
feelings and the emotions that have been
raised by my constituents
it's a fair observation i'm sure from
your constituents point of view i assure
you we intend to keep our teeth in this
until we finish and i don't plan to
leave
i don't think any of my other colleagues
well
none of my other colleagues are planning
to leave except it seems that is also
premature
to stay involved in in any way they uh
profitably can for the good of public
service thank you so much for the
testimony thank you very much ma'am uh
at this time then i would call of maxine
waters
from california's 35th district and we
are pleased to have you
before us today maxine to talk about
the report that is being provided to us
by mr hitz
thank you very much mr chairman um
[Music]
and members i'd like to thank you for
holding this hearing um certainly
it's not expected of the intelligence
committee and i'm very pleased that
we have so many members present today
and i'd like to beg your indulgence i
know you spoke of a time limit but it is
very difficult to
to talk about all of this information in
10 minutes but i'm going to try and do
it as quickly as i possibly can
mr chairman and members of the committee
i'm here today to testify about the
failure of the central intelligence
agency to conduct a serious and thorough
investigation into the allegations of
cia involvement and cocaine trafficking
to fund its contra war activities
unfortunately my fear that the cia would
be unable to investigate itself has been
confirmed with this report the inspector
general's report lacks credibility
it is fraught with contradictions and
illogical conclusions
in a september 3rd
1996 memo
then cia director john deutch laid out
the framework for this investigation
in his instructions to cia inspector
general frederick
p hetz
director deutsch stated i have no reason
to believe that there is any substance
to the allegations published in the
mercury news
despite his premature conclusion a
serious substantial and credible
investigation in interview process
would have proven him wrong if the cia
director's premature conclusion was
meant to direct the final inca outcome
he has succeeded this report sweeping
denial of the cia's knowledge of drug
trafficking related to the contras
defies the evidence and the logic that
the cia should have known
from the days of the cia's first
response to the allegations raised in
the dark alliance series many skeptics
believe that the cia could never produce
a credible or truthful review of
wrongdoings by its own agency these
skeptics could point
if they'd like to this sunday's los
angeles times to confirm their fears the
times reported in another case
that after 37 years the cia
finally admitted publicly the most
profound deception imaginable on an
american family
thomas pete ray and his top secret
squadron of national guard bombers were
shot down during a cia bombing mission
in the bay of pigs debacle for 37 years
the cia denied that mr ray and his
squadron even existed much less were
shot down by cuban troops in 1961.
only this month faced with a document
obtained by freedom of information act
request by the national security
archives that the cia finally admit the
truth 37 years later my deep concern
about the allegations raised in the dark
alliance series that my government could
have in any way been involved in or had
knowledge of drug trafficking has caused
me to spend
much of my own time and resources to
find out more about these allegations
after reading the darker lines series i
interviewed gary webb the writer of the
series and by the way mr chairman and
members mr gary webb is here today uh
he's sitting right here in this seat and
i invited him to come
uh he's put a lot of time and work uh
into this investigation and i have been
working with him since the first day
that i read it and i think that he
should be privy to all information as he
continues his work in this area
i interviewed gary webb the writer of
the series i invited him to come to my
district in south central los angeles to
respond to questions from local
residents my community encouraged my
investigation and supported me and my
efforts to delve deeper into these
allegations
i personally interviewed a number of key
figures in the dark alliance series i
first met with and interviewed mr alan
fenster who was the attorney for rickett
ross then i drove to san diego to the
metropolitan detention center where i
interviewed mr ricky ross
the young man who was trafficking in
drugs in south central los angeles that
were being sold to him by mr norwin
manesses and mr dinelio blandone
he was being held in the metropolitan
detention center facility on drug
charges i also then drove to a
restaurant in the valley where i met
with mr
celerino castillo the dea agent who had
investigated the drug trafficking
operation at illipongo airfield in el
salvador castillo had documented that
the cia directed this drug trafficking
operation out of two hangars using
contra supply network as a route for
shipping drugs into the united states i
then interviewed former lapd officer
officer mike rupert who states he was
forced to leave the lapd after he
uncovered a connection between the cia
and narcotic trafficking operations in
california and louisiana mr rupert also
was interviewed by the cia for its
report i met and had numerous telephone
conversations with mr jerry gazetta a
detective with the city of bell and a
key member of the multi-agency task
force working with the los angeles
sheriff's department investigating the
blind dome narcotics operation gazetta
was a level one informant whose
information was the basis of the
affidavit of la sheriff tom garton that
resulted in the october 1986 raid of the
blandone operations 14 sites in southern
california i visited the records
division of the los angeles sheriff's
department and uncovered the sheriff's
reports regarding the october 1986 drug
bust i was the first to obtain the
copies of the documentation regarding
the raids they had said prior to that
time that they did not exist they could
not be found and i literally went in and
by accident
i was able to access these documents and
they quickly tried to retrieve them from
me and of course i refused to leave
until
i had copies of what should have been
public documents on january 3rd 1997
using my own personal funds i flew to
nicaragua to meet with enrique miranda
jaime a former san diego official and
drug partner of norway meneses a central
figure in the allegations in the dark
alliance series i was contacted by
someone who had information about the
colombian cartels and their connection
to norway manesses when i arrived in
nicaragua i was taken to the prison in
the town of grenada by state department
representatives where i met with miranda
himself mr miranda told me some of the
information that he gave to the c i a in
this investigation which is reported on
pages 54 and 55 of the ig's report mr
randa currently is in prison after being
convicted for smuggling
764 kilos of cocaine with his partner
norwin meneses manesses told miranda in
detail that manesses worked for the
contras and that his drug trafficking
operation had the support
of the cia manesses also told miranda
that he was receiving
support directly from oliver north and
passing on the funds to support country
groups i met with mr thomas borge a
former sandinista interior minister and
head of intelligence mr borge came to
meet with me from nick wagner to south
central los angeles and waited for hours
until i completed a day-long schedule
and i then spent some four hours with
him i have also had numerous telephone
conversations with corel talavera baca
the girlfriend of rafael cornejo who was
a relative and part of norway manessa's
drug trafficking organization as well as
a long-time business partner of denilio
blandone another central figure in the
dark alliance series i received
information from miss baca and mr conejo
who were connected to carlos ledera a
colombian drug dealer and co-founder of
the meddling cartel it was through
letters private island that the middling
cartel moved massive amounts of co-tech
cocaine to miami and the united states
miss baca had visited college later as
private island and have information
regarding the connection between mr
lederer and norman manesses i've had
over a half dozen telephone
conversations with her and she has sent
me information relative to that
operation i have looked into many of the
main allegations raised in gary webb's
series and i've thoroughly reviewed the
inspector general's report in addition i
have read many letters and reviewed
volumes of information sent to me and
have visited a large number of people
who have claimed to have information
about the drug dealing in south central
los angeles in my informed opinion mr
chairman
the cia ig report
and the investigation lacks credibility
and its conclusions
must be dismissed let me turn to some of
the specifics of the inspector general's
report
the average reader likely will find the
structure of this report bizarre and
confusing i also question the report's
methodology it's sweeping conclusions
it's cleverly worded denials and a
selective quoting of documents the
report states that 365 interviews were
conducted but only summer summarize a
statement from 12 individuals connected
to the south central los angeles
specific allegations i have a list
of over 70 individuals
who should have been interviewed under
oath by the cia if the investigation was
to be considered credible did the cia
interview all of these people because
the report fails to list who was
actually interviewed we have no way of
knowing in addition
only 40 pages of this report titled the
california story actually deal with the
allegations of the south central crack
cocaine country connection the report
mentions a half dozen other cia and
contra officials interviewed but does
not offer even a cursory summary of
their testimony so let me do what the
report failed to do
the following individuals associate
associated with the contras
are or were either
ci agents or cia assets
now i'm going to name these individuals
and i'm going to say to you mr chairman
and members that even though the report
cleverly refers to agents we should be
talking about
agents and or assets
i am going to say to you today in no
uncertain terms mr adolfo calero was a
cia
asset and he didn't just start with
norway meneses he started
working with the american embassy
uh
as a cia asset and many of the funds for
aid were funded through him mr enrique
bermudez was a cia asset mr marcos
aguado
a contra pilot and accused drug dealer
mr francisco avilas
a contra official in costa rica
in fro in the frogman case mr ivan gomez
ci agent who accepted drug money from mr
manesses mr dugoberto
nunes who ran a shrimp company for the
oliver north in costa rica
renee carvalho a cuban american who
worked with the contras in uh countries
in costa rica mr francisco sean's owner
of the shrimp company for oliver north
and costa rica mr edmundo meneses
american trained nick organ general and
norway meneses brother mr sebastian
gonzalez contralita in costa rica and
drug partner of manesses
i
assert here today
that these are all cia assets and i
would challenge this committee
to ask
the inspector general
and others perhaps in the cia
to document for you my whether or not my
allegations are true they should give
you sworn testimony as to whether or not
they have knowledge about the people
that i'm submitting to you been assets
of the cia today i'm asking this
committee to obtain the written response
from the cia
that either categorically confirms or
denies they are or were cia assets or
agents another major problem with the
investigation underlying the report was
the cia's lack of subpoena power this
meant that some of the most important
cia and other officials were never
interviewed three former unnamed senior
cia managers would only respond in
writing six other
key cia personnel and former de agent
castillo refused to be interviewed the
cia agents included dwayne claridge
joseph fernandez and claire george all
of these senior cia officials had major
responsibilities for the cia's contra
operation
there can be no thorough investigation
without sworn testimony from each of
these individuals they should be
subpoenaed jose fernandez was the former
cia station chief in costa rica while
the meneses drug organization was
operating from there dwayne dewey
claridge was the cia officer who helped
create the contras at a time when the
monesses ring first began dealing
cocaine for the fdn his name also
appeared in oliver north's notebooks as
being responsible for making quid pro
quo deals with known drug king manuel
noriega claret summed up how serious he
thought this investigation was when he
told reporters in december 1997 that the
cia quote sent me questions that were
[ __ ] and i wrote back they were a
bunch of [ __ ] when i spoke with
journalists following the release of the
report this past january much to my
surprise they had to admit to me they
had not even read the entire report they
admitted they had only read the glossy
eight-page summary which offered up
unsubstantiated conclusions of the cia's
innocent
innocence and blanket denials of the
dark aligned serious allegations had
they only read the report in its
entirety as i did they would have
learned that allegations of drug
trafficking and connections between the
contras and the cia were not new in fact
the report even lists and summarizes
some of the other investigations that
found
contra involvement in drug trafficking
for example the senate subcommittee on
terrorism narcotics and international
operations
chaired by senator john curry conducted
a two-year investigation into
allegations of contrainvolvement in
drugs and arms trafficking the cia
inspector general report summarizes some
of the carry commissions one thousand
one hundred and sixty six page reports
devastating findings on page thirty five
through thirty eight
these are some of the admissions
drug traffickers used the contra war and
their ties to the contra as cover for
their criminal enterprises in honduras
and costa rica assistance from the drug
laws was crucial to the
contrast and the traffickers in turn
promoted and protected their operations
by associating with the contra movement
drug traffickers provided support to the
contras and used the supply network of
the contrast contrast knowingly received
both financial and material assistance
from the drug traffickers in each case
one or another u.s government agency had
information regarding these matters
either while they were occurring or
immediately thereafter members of the
contra movement were involved in drug
trafficking including pilots who flew
surprise for the contrast mercenaries
who work for the contras and contra
supporters throughout central america
drug traffickers helped in the contra
supply operations through business
relations with contra groups drug
traffickers contribute cash
weapons planes pilots air supply
services and other materials to the
contras u.s department funds authorized
by congress
for humanitarian assistance was paid to
drug traffickers in some cases these
drug traffickers received the state
department's funds
after having been indicted by federal
law enforcement agencies on drug charges
in other cases where the subject of
pending investigations by those agencies
the fdn
country group moved contra funds through
a narcotics drug trafficking and money
laundering operation drug trafficking
for the contra movement was done by some
because they were told that their
actions were either on behalf of or
sanctioned by the u.s government not
included in the cia ig report or other
key findings by the carry committee
despite widespread trafficking through
the war zones of northern costa rica the
kerry committee was unable to find
a single case
which was made on the basis of a tip
or a report by an official
of a u.s intelligence agency this
despite an executive order requiring
intelligence agencies to report drug
trafficking to law enforcement officials
and despite direct testimony that drug
trafficking on the
southern front was reported
to the cia officials u.s officials
involved with the contras knew
that drug traffickers were using the
country infrastructure and that the
countries were receiving assistance from
drug profits yet they turned a blind eye
and did not report these individuals to
the appropriate law enforcement agencies
how can this report
include these incriminating findings by
elected officials including senators
kerry
brock and monahan while others
summer summarily while and others while
summarily dismissing any cia knowledge
of or involvement in contra drug
trafficking into the u.s
this is an outrageous contradiction
moreover the report is littered with
damaging admissions
this report
admits norway manesses was one of the
biggest drug dealers in america either
north and south
and he supplied denio blandone blandone
in turn was the source who supplied
ricky ross and blandone and manesses did
so unhindered by the cia it is
unreasonable to think meneses was
connected to the cia
given the contras were a cia
creation
and that the cia handle every aspect
of the contra operation
pages 20 through
24 this report confirms that the cia
essentially created
funded supplied and trained the contras
and that the cia was intimately involved
in determining their strategy and
running their operations monesses was
never arrested by u s law enforcement he
was permitted free entrance to the
united states and even issued a visa how
was this allowed and why was it allowed
to
continue let me just say that manesses
dealt drugs
in the united states for over 10 years
or more
starting back in 1974 he was a drug
dealer before he came to the united
states he was even involved in a murder
in nicaragua
he dealt drugs
without any interference without any
intervention he had assets and
businesses in san francisco as a matter
of fact
congresswoman pelosi referred to the
frogman case
when they tracked down
some of manessa's people they tracked
them to the very house
that was connected with the frogman case
where many of those people were involved
meneses was well known by the cia
the dea
the dia and everybody in the united
states as a drug dealer who was
supplying denilio blandone who was
supplying ricky ross
how he stayed in the united states
all of those years being known from 1974
selling drugs that ended up helping to
support the contras and nobody but
nobody knew it
is absolutely amazing
meneses was never arrested by the u s
enforcement he was permitted free
interest again to the united states and
even issued a visa how was this allowed
and why was it allowed to continue the
cia and dea records are full of
knowledge about vanessa's drug dealing
operation this knowledge was
substantiated in this report
even this report the cia knew of his
drug trafficking
by 1984 and the dea
had known of his trafficking activities
as early as 1974
incredibly the report fails to mention
anything about the activities of adolfo
calero only mentioning that he was
interviewed he was the key contra leader
and cia agent on the southern front
damning public information ties calero
to drug trafficking in a december 1986
interview colero told the costa rican
newspaper la nacion
that he met with drug kingpin norwood
meneses at least six times
and that he knew meneses was involved in
drug trafficking
now
in our investigations we had found out
that vanessa's had met with
adolfo calera and that vanessa and
blandone have been going to these
meetings both in san francisco and in
los angeles despite the fact that these
conclusions of uh
these drug dealers having no connection
to the contras
thank goodness your report did identify
six visits we only knew about two
we have a picture
of meneses
and adolfo calera
and others at one of these contra
meetings that were going on all over
california
in addition there are many other key
facts that were confirmed by this report
drug kingpin norway meneses supported
and was involved with the contracts on
page 7677
drug dealer norwin meneses admitted
given money to the california chapter of
the fdn contrast and that he was
involved in the 1985 attempt to obtain
material support medical and general
supplies for the contra movement now
there are a lot of discrepancies about
how much
you will find
in your report it differs somewhat
with information that was testified to
over on the senate side when they held
the semblance of a hearing over there
i have maintained that it does not
matter
how much money
it does not matter
whether or not it was as eden uh pastor
testified on that side that he only got
a few thousand dollars in a couple of
trucks or it is in a mission that norway
nessus supplied about forty thousand
dollars plus medical supplies and other
things the fact of the matter is the
reason i'm so interested in this
and the reason i'm so outraged by it as
a public elected officials all of us
must be concerned
that our government could have anyway
been involved in drug trafficking drug
trafficking that's a very very serious
offense against the people of this
nation
we cannot afford to have our government
i don't care under what pretense a
covert operation or any kind of
operation involved in drug trafficking
page 70 to 71 of the report documents
the connection between cia asset
and fdn military leader enrique bermudez
manesses and blandone blandone and
manesses traveled to bolivia in 1982 to
make a drug deal and stopped enroute to
honduras
while in honduras blandon and manesses
met bermudez for the second time
bermudez asked blandone and manesses to
help raise money and supplies for the
fdn he let the drug traffickers know
that their support would be welcome
because i quote in everybody quotes even
your reported quote that he said the
ends justifies the means blandone then
describes how he and manesses were
escorted to airport by armed contras
after the meeting with bermudez blandon
left the meeting
he left this meeting with 100
dollars in a bag
to buy drugs
the profits from the sell of these drugs
were to be used to buy supplies and fund
the contras blandon tells of how he ran
into trouble at the airport in honduras
when he was caught with the one hundred
thousand dollars
but guess what
just like in the frogman case
where they caught them with the dope and
the money
and they returned the 36 thousand
dollars
based on that attorney general that you
had in san francisco having been told
that it was contra money
this man would 100 000 in drug money
to buy more drugs for more supplies
was assisted by the contrast at the
airport
and even though it had stopped him they
had taken 100 000
out of his brief with the intervention
of the conscience they gave it back to
him and he went along his merry way
where did you 100 000
to begin to conclude the remarks yes
very much appreciate we we've been over
generous we're taking away from time for
the i i appreciate mr goss and i i have
written remarks which we will accept for
the record without objection where did
the 100 000 come from did they give back
the 100 000 to blandon because of the
contra cia connection
well mr
chairman and members it's hard to refute
and to help educate in 10 minutes
i'm going to submit this for the record
but i'm going to close by saying this
this report
is not credible
this report does not do the job mr
chairman
we owe it to ourselves as public policy
makers
to do something why do i do all of this
because i want to find
some cia operatives assets or agents and
somehow convict them that's not going to
happen
and i don't believe that and that's not
what i'm trying to do i am trying to
raise the level of this discussion
because we've got some work to do as
public policy makers
the least we could do
the least we could do
is develop public policy that will
indicate
that drug trafficking can never be used
in any covert operation no matter what
is being attempted we cannot continue
to put our heads in the sand
it's a shame what happened with the
kerry report the idea that members of
the congress of the united states on the
senate side could have presented us with
so much documentation and then years
later we have the investigation that was
done by the san jose mercury and we find
more information about drug trafficking
and either the cia absolutely knowing or
turning its head and we still came can't
come up with public policy at the same
time we're spending millions of dollars
talking about a war on drugs give me a
break mr chairman and members
we can do better than this i will not go
away members
i cannot go away my community has been
devastated as many communities across
this nation
as a result of this work i've been in at
least seven or eight states with town
hall meetings including new york and new
jersey and st louis and i continue to
have several requests every week to come
and do town hall meetings and radio
stations because people are outraged and
concerned
about the fact that somehow this drug
problem won't go away and the idea that
the government could be involved i
challenge this committee
to get involved with public policy that
would get our government out of ever
being involved in any way and while
you're doing this why haven't something
been said about general davila
in honduras who also was a cia asset
that was caught
putting a ton of drugs into the airplane
the drugs found its way into the united
states and was sold on the streets and
that was recently and we still haven't
heard a word when i check with the
justice department they tell me they
can't say anything and i suppose you
have information you can't say anything
about but i think somehow
we've got to do better
the lives of our children and our
communities are at stake i thank you and
i submit this for the record and more
information and documents if you would
like to have it
thank the gentlelady very much for her
testimony at this time i would like to
swear in mr hitz mr chairman
sure
i want to commend
congresswoman waters for the obvious
amount of work and effort that she has
made here
and i want you to know that uh
we are certainly willing to meet with
you and and your staff we want as much
information as you have uh so that
because we are in a as you know we're
going to do an investigation of our own
the inspector general is going to
present his report but this committee
has pledged that we will have our own
independent investigation so all the
work that you've done
we would like to to benefit from it and
i complement you for your efforts thank
you very much mr dixon
thank you we would obviously welcome
from
either of our two colleagues who are
here today or any other colleagues who
may see
these proceedings or be interested in
this any observations they have on this
report which is the subject of our
hearing which in fact we are now going
to have officially presented to us by mr
hintz mr hitzman i ask you to raise your
right hand
you swear tell the truth the whole truth
nothing but the truth so help you god i
do
thank you for joining us today i would
advise members that
mr hitz went out of his way to
accommodate our schedule
i believe he has been without sleep for
uh at least a couple of days in order to
travel back here
and we are obliged
for that consideration
well and i floor to you and hope that
you will present uh comments you wish to
on this report
thank you mr chairman and i assure the
committee that uh
i'm happy to be here today and and
hopefully i'll be able to
answer your questions
irrespective of distance travel i feel a
little bit as if we've had
uh dessert first
uh the been a very
uh serious and thorough discussion of
uh by uh the two congress persons about
uh their views of my report
and uh
so i'm happy to
have the occasion now to summarize it
for you and although this is a
a lengthy statement i ask that you uh
bear with me because i think it's
quite important to get it all in the
record
when i appeared before the senate select
committee on intelligence in open
session
on october 23 1996
i reported that at the request of then
director of central intelligence john
deutsch
on september 3rd
1996 i immediately initiated an inquiry
into the allegations that stemmed from a
three-part series called dark alliance
that was published in the san jose
mercury news
in august of 96.
that series discussed the drug
trafficking activities of several
individuals
who had been implicated in cocaine
trafficking in california
as you know the series also suggested
that the nicaraguan contras described as
cia's army
benefited from the drug trafficking
activities of ricky ross
danilo blandon
norwin menises and others
and that these activities were
responsible for the emergence of crack
cocaine in south central los angeles and
elsewhere in america
the series also intimated that cia may
have been involved in drug trafficking
or at least had knowledge of those
activities
and may have given its approval for them
on october 23rd 1996 i promised congress
and the american people to have my
office quote conduct as thorough a
review as possible
of all available information
and report what we find candidly and
completely
i am pleased to be able to come before
this committee today and say that we
have done just that
on december 17 1997 we published our
classified report of investigation of
volume 1 called the california story
that specifically focused on cia
knowledge of
and actions taken regarding the
individuals and events that were the
focus of the mercury news series
a little over a month later on january
twenty ninth of this year
we released this report in an
unclassified version following a
classification review by the agency
i believe those of you on the committee
who have read the classified version of
volume one
and have had the opportunity to compare
it with the unclassified version will
agree
that the information about this matter
that is now publicly available
does not differ in any significant way
from that presented in the classified
report
our purpose is to provide the american
public
with the relevant facts without
compromising information relating to the
national security that the dci is by law
bound to protect
our report presents an exhaustive array
of facts and allows me to reiterate what
i said before the senate select
committee in 96
we will present the unvarnished truth as
we find it and will do so to the best of
our abilities
today i can say that we have done just
that
we reviewed an estimated and 250
thousand pages of documents
and used the information gleaned from
these documents to conduct over three
hundred and sixty five interviews of
persons on four continents
these interviews included current and
former directors and deputy directors of
central intelligence
current and former senior agency staff
personnel
secretaries communicators logistics
personnel
operations officers attorneys present
and former cia assets
contractors law enforcement personnel
former contra leaders convicted drug
traffickers and others
our investigative team went to great
lengths to obtain relevant documents we
sent officers to the national archives
to review records compiled by the office
of independent counsel for iran contra
matters
we examined cia's own iran contra
records that comprised about 300 linear
feet of agency and other executive
branch documents
we work directly with dea
fbi and the department of justice ig to
obtain relevant information
from the files of those organizations
we reviewed reporting from other
intelligence community agencies
including nsa and dia
that had been shared with cia
we contacted d we contacted doj's
national drug intelligence center
and dea's el paso intelligence center to
seek further information
we reviewed available congressional
records including relevant information
compiled by the carry committee
and the intelligence oversight
committees and spoke with individuals
associated with the joint iran contra
investigating committee and office of
independent counsel for iran contra
matters
it is important to note mr chairman that
our investigation was not intended to
prove or disprove allegations of drug
trafficking by specific individuals or
organizations
rather our 17-person team worked some 18
months to identify
let me underscore
number one any information in cia's
possession relating to danilo blandon
norwin menises or ricky ross
number two
any information in cia's possession
relating to possible drug trafficking
activities by the con by the contras in
california and elsewhere in the united
states
and what action if any cia may have
taken upon receiving that information
and third
any contacts between c i a and law
enforcement authorities regarding that
information
i believe our investigation is the most
comprehensive and exhaustive ever
conducted by the c i a office of
inspector general
and that the report of investigation
reflects accurately what was found by
our team
having said that
one may ask if it is possible that there
is some relevant document we did not
find
or some relevant person we did not
interview that would alter our
conclusions
as for the documents
the answer to that is yes it is possible
but i do not believe it is likely
as for individuals the report explains
that six former cia employees
and a former dea agent refused our
request to be interviewed
we had no power to compel them to do so
given the effort i have described
however
i do not believe it is likely that any
significant information that would have
substantially altered the conclusions of
this volume
has escaped our attention
now let me turn to the findings of
volume one
before i go any further i want to make
clear that we found absolutely no
evidence
to indicate that cia as an organization
or its employees
were involved in any conspiracy to bring
drugs into the united states
the first half of volume one
discussed cia knowledge of the
activities of ross blandone and meneses
ross blandon and minises are convicted
drug dealers
our investigation found no information
to indicate that any pr past or present
employee of cia
or anyone else acting on behalf of cia
had any dealings with ross blandon or
monis
or had any knowledge of their drug
trafficking activities
ross was a drug dealer who by his own
admission
says his sole motivation was to derive
personal financial gain from the illegal
trafficking of drugs
during the 1980s ross was a major
cocaine and crack trafficker who says he
made millions in the drug trade
his activities helped to foster the
crack epidemic that erupted in south
central los angeles
however ross told us that he never sold
drugs for the contras or donated any
money to the congress
c i a never had any relationship with
ross
likewise blandon and minises also
trafficked in drugs to derive personal
financial gain
while cia had no relationship with
blandone and minises
our investigation did find that blandone
and minises were affiliated with
california contra support organizations
and each made con made financial
contributions
to those groups
blandone and menises each claim
to have provided between three thousand
and forty thousand dollars worth of
support to the congress
although we found no information to
substantiate these claims
blandon claims
that portions of his contributions were
from the process proceeds of his
narcotics trafficking
blandon states that he gave the
impression when donating money
that it was derived from his legitimate
business activities
while manisi's claims his contributions
were from the proceeds of legitimate
business activities
our investigation found that blandon had
a personal relationship with contralita
eden pastora
and that he provided pastora with
assistance
in the form of rent-free housing in
costa rica
and two used vehicles for personal
transportation
much of this assistance was provided to
pastora after he left the contra
movement
blandon also claims pastora was not
aware he was engaged in drug trafficking
pastora confirmed this when he testified
before the senate select committee in
november of 1996.
blandone also says he met contralita
enrique bermudez on four occasions from
1981 to 1983.
blandone states that one meeting
occurred in honduras in 1982
while he and minises were traveling to
bolivia
to conduct a drug deal
blandon says that bermudez told them
that the contras were having trouble
raising funds and asked that he and
manisy's help
stating that the end justifies the means
blandone adds that it is his belief
bermudez did not know that he and
meneses were engaged in drug trafficking
but was aware of manis's alleged
nicaraguan organized crime connections
this investigation found no further
information on this subject
unfortunately we could not obtain
information from bermudez
since he was murdered in managua in
nineteen ninety one
no information has been found to
indicate that c i a hindered or
otherwise intervened in the
investigation arrest
prosecution conviction or sentencing of
ross
blandone or meneses
additionally
ronald j lister or david scott weekly
who were mentioned in the media in
connection with blandone
had no relationship with cia or its
employees
lister a former police officer
trafficked in drugs for personal benefit
and admits that people may have received
the false impression
that he was connected with cia and that
he have made he that and that he may
have fostered such misconceptions
because it benefited his private
security business
our investigation also found no
information to connect weekly to the
drug trafficking activities of ross
landowne manisis or lister
the second half of our volume one
the northern california story pertains
to a case in san francisco
often referred to as the frogman case
the case got its name
when law enforcement authorities in san
francisco
arrested several swimmers who had come
ashore from a colombian freighter on
january 17
1983
at the time of their arrest the swimmers
had with them some 430 pounds of cocaine
in all some 12 arrests were made on
january 17 and more followed soon
thereafter including the the arrests of
two nicaraguans
uh julio zavala and carlos cabezas
unlike the events relating to ross
blandone or meneses
this was a case where the cia became
involved because it mistakenly thought
it had an interest to protect
cia first learned of the frogman case in
late july 1984
about a year and a half after zavala's
arrest
at that time
cia was informed that two
representatives of the united states
attorney's office in san francisco which
was prosecuting zavala
planned to attend depositions in costa
rica from two members of contra
organizations
who had provided zavala with letters
that claimed that some for thirty six
thousand dollars that the authorities
had seized from zavala at the time of
his arrest
belonged to the contras
cia officials mistakenly identified one
of the contra members
as a former cia asset and there was a
concern that the depositions might
expose a contra support group in which
cia had an operational interest
no information was found to indicate
that the two contra officials who wrote
the letters supporting zavala or the
organizations which with which they were
affiliated were involved in drug
trafficking
moreover
the principal author of the letters
reportedly was later expelled from the
contra group when its leadership learned
he had written a letter in support of
zavala's claim
and he could not satisfactorily explain
the basis for his actions
in any event an attorney from the cia's
office of general counsel
met with the responsible prosecutor and
possibly other representatives from the
u.s attorney's office
prior to the cia attorney's meeting with
the prosecutor
the prosecutor had discussed with one of
zavala's attorneys
the possibility of returning the money
to zavala
rather than expending the time and money
necessary to travel to costa rica in
connection with the depositions
that said
accounts differ as to why the money was
returned to zavala
the ausa who prosecuted zavala
the u.s attorney at the time joseph
russeniello
and
others involved
in the prosecution
state that the decision to return the
money to zavala was not based on any cia
representations
but on their own judgment as to whether
it was worth the time and expense to go
to costa rica for the depositions
however
we found a cia cable that was written
soon after the cia attorney had met with
the responsible prosecutor
the cable indicated the money was
returned to zavala at cia's request
unfortunately the c i a attorney cannot
recall the facts of the case or the
meeting in question
in summary the key points i would
emphasize with regard to the frogman
case are that one
whatever impact the cia attorney may
have ultimately had on the decision of
the u s attorney's office to return the
money to zavala
we have found no evidence to indicate
the return of the money weakened the
prosecution's case against zavala
zavala was convicted and sent to prison
secondly carlos cabezas who was also
arrested and convicted in connection
with the frogman case
claims he was part of a network that
sold cocaine for the contras
we found no information
to support his claim
we found no information as stated in the
mercury news series to connect minises
with the frogman case
menisci says he was never part of the
zavala organization
zavala and cabezas confirm confirm this
assertion
we will soon be issuing volume 2 of our
report
whereas volume 1 focused on drug
traffickers in california
volume 2 will closely examine any other
linkages between cia
drug trafficking the contra program and
contra leaders and organizations
in volume two we will set the background
by describing what at the time were
cia's legal and regulatory
responsibilities
policies and guidelines governing
dealings with people and organizations
that were subject to drug trafficking
allegations
we will also explain the intelligence
collection requirements that existed at
the time concerning drug trafficking
however
the bulk of volume two
and it is bulky approaching six hundred
pages
will be devoted to a detailed treatment
of what was known to c cia regarding
dozens of people and the number of
companies connected in some fashion to
the contra program or the contra
movement that were the subject of any
sort of drug trafficking allegations
each is closely examined in terms of
their relationship with cia
the drug trafficking activity that was
alleged
the actions cia took in response to the
allegations
and the extent of information concerning
the allegations that was shared with u.s
law enforcement
and the congress
as i said earlier
we have found no evidence in the course
of this lengthy investigation of any
conspiracy by cia or its employees
to bring drugs into the united states
however
during the contra era
cia worked with a variety of people to
support the contra program
these included cia assets pilots who
ferried supplies to the contras as well
as contra officials and others
let me be frank about what we are
finding
there are instances where cia did not in
an expeditious or consistent fashion
cut off relationships with individuals
supporting the contra program
who were alleged to have engaged in drug
trafficking activity
or take action to resolve the
allegations i want to underscore the
fact that we're talking about
allegations here
volume 2 will be delivered to the
director of central intelligence
and the intelligence oversight
committees as a classified report near
the end of this month
to the extent possible
we in the agency are committed to
producing an unclassified version of
volume 2 as well
although the time required for that
effort is uncertain
in closing mr chairman i urge the
american public to read volume one
which is available on the internet at
www.odci.gov
cia
that report includes a great deal of
information
and quotes many documents
those who read it will then see the full
weight of our effort
and be in a position to judge for
themselves
about our efforts thank you mr chairman
i'm pleased to
answer your questions
i have
spent a considerable amount of my life
recently reading your materials
and i can tell you that i'm not looking
forward to another 600 pages but i am
looking forward to
getting through this matter as
expeditiously and as thoroughly as we
can so it is good news to hear that
volume 2 is on its way
i would point out to my colleagues as i
said at the beginning that we had the
room until five apparently we've been
able to negotiate an extension of the
lease to 5 15 and if mr hitz could agree
to stay until that time i would be
thankful i can't i would ask that
members try and accommodate with their
questions
keep them as concise as possible
and hope so we give mr hits an
opportunity to respond
i would like to start by asking
characterization if i could mr hitz i'd
like you to characterize the cables and
the materials that were reviewed in
terms of their comments relating to
individuals known to be involved in drug
trafficking
did the cables materials
just acknowledge fact
that the cables and materials instruct
individuals to stay away from these
individuals
were there any warnings or suggestions
that cia officers should stay clear of
individuals trafficking drugs and in
fact should report them accordingly
as you know mr chairman uh at least from
calendar year 1986
there was a prohibition
in force
against
dollars cia money going to individuals
or groups found to be involved
in drug dealing
as a consequence i would have to answer
your question by saying that for the
most part
that tone
is contained in the cables but you have
to recognize that the nature of the
allegations varied on many occasions in
some cases it was sort of wild
hair
uh
rumors that were circulating in the area
and some
of the allegations were more deeply
rooted
and once again i'm afraid you're going
to be hearing this from me
in answer to a number of questions when
we get beyond
the
specific individuals and acts that were
covered in the
volume 1 california story you're just
going to have to be patient and wait for
volume 2 where in fact
the allegations that were
the subject of some of those that cable
chatter if you will are the sen are
central to our investigation
thank you notwithstanding what your
report says for itself and i know it
does speak to this a little bit
generally were the materials used in
your investigation solely produced at
the cia or did they include materials
from other intelligence agencies
no we had very good cooperation as you
know from other agencies particularly
the department of justice
and the dea
in so far as
cia records contained information from
other agencies department of state for
example we were able to review that as
well
with regard to
the individuals who declined to be
interviewed by your office
did they give you any reason for their
unwillingness to participate in this
i presume you do not have the power for
subpoenas no don't have we do not have
the power for uh
subpoena of individuals we do thanks to
the work of this committee and the
congress now have the power to subpoena
documents but we don't have
individual subpoena power i talked to a
number of the individuals there were
only a handful that uh refused to talk
to us in fact i talked to dewey claridge
i think that some of the if i could
characterize the attitude
that
i encountered and that my staff
encountered it was having gone through
the iran contra
investigation that era
several felt that they'd done enough
they'd been through enough they did not
believe that there was any substance to
the mercury accusations and they just
chose not to
participate
in your review how would you
characterize the concerns of cia
managers relating to any potential
dealings with individuals who are
suspected or known to be trafficking
drugs i think the 86 prohibition against
providing monies to anybody
associated with drug trafficking was
uppermost in the minds of
the managers
involved in that period and it seemed to
be reflected in the
cable traffic but again
you'll have to wait for volume 2 because
you will see
that some of the allegations of drug
trafficking appeared to be more
substantial than others and that would
weigh in some of the positions taken
and finally uh for me mr hitz did you uh
interview any of the following uh gary
webb
no we did not
sandra smith
i'm sorry mr chairman who was that
sandra smith sander smith is the lead
off dea agent in the first of the dark
alliance stories the alleged source of
the beginning of this no we did not
uh celerino castillo we attempted to
along with the department of justice to
work out
circumstances under which we could take
uh mr castillo's testimony and we were
unable to do so
thank you very much i will have a
series of further questions and i know
we all will those who have invested the
time and i believe every member of the
committee and obviously colleagues who
are interested in this as well
will be submitting uh record questions
for you in writing if that is agreeable
that is agreeable thank you sir mr dicks
mr hitz i want to uh thank you for your
your outstanding work
over the years uh and your cooperation
with this committee i've had a chance to
work directly with you for i think
almost 20 years now
and
though we're very concerned about the
the uh
this issue
uh
we are also very pl you know pleased
with the the amount of work and effort
that you've made here and
again uh
as i said earlier we're going to take
all the
facts that congresswoman waters has
has put together our committee staff and
the members will look at that
i urge you as i understand it
congresswoman waters has written you a
series of letters
uh so that you've had the benefit to
some extent of of some of her concerns
i've had the pleasure of corresponding
with both of the congresspersons right
to my right and i and i compliment both
of them both both of our
outstanding representatives from
california for their their consistent
effort in this matter
uh i am disturbed about uh
and i thank you for being frank i want
to read this again there are instances
where cia did not in any expeditious or
consistent fashion
cut off relationships with individuals
supporting the contra program who were
alleged to have engaged in drug
trafficking activity or take action to
resolve the allegations
now
that that that is a concern can you give
us any more yes any more sense of that
uh because you're going to be getting
volume 2 before the end of the month i
didn't
deem it appropriate to be
entirely silent on what it is that you
could be
expect to see that's sort of a preview
but i have to be
very careful and i think the key
uh word in the passage that you just
read from my testimony is allegations
that's where it's going to come down mr
dicks
is to how those allegations were weighed
and you were going to pass judgment as
are my colleagues at this table when
they read the report
on whether or not
we respond to whether or not the agency
responded uh appropriately in dealing
with those allegations but
uh that's why they report volume 2 will
be 600 pages long because we wanted to
go into each of these instances in some
detail
and your view is that there wasn't a
consistent policy about how this how
this should be dealt with or handled
well i think the 86 prohibition against
dealing with any uh individuals that is
a making money available uh to any
individuals who were involved in drug
trafficking as i say
was uppermost in the minds of the
managers uh and the correspondence in
headquarters dealing with these
situations but the point is they were
also in god involved in a major effort
as you recall to keep the contra
movement going
and what you will be seeing is a
situation where if the allegation was
flimsy or uh fourth and fifth hand
perhaps uh
the pursuit of running that allegation
to ground wasn't as expeditious as it
might have been i don't want to soft
pedal it but that seems to be the manner
in which these things were treated
was was there an effort to try and
interview oliver north or any of the
other
principles uh
involved during the
reagan administration in the iran contra
affair we did not
seek to interview
oliver north
and we confined our
interviews primarily to
cia officials let me check with my staff
here
yes and and you must understand mr dicks
that we felt we knew a great deal about
what oliver north uh's testimony was
because we had access to all the records
of his testimony before the iran contra
was he ever tested was he ever
questioned on this subject
no
no he was not
i would urge that you know
that it sounds like he'd be one person i
think we ought to go interview or maybe
this committee may have to interview him
but uh
because of the of the
incredible lengths he went to fund this
operation correct
i think it raises a very serious issue
and because of the short time mr
chairman i will i will uh end it there
thank you for your good work and i want
to thank you for your good service to
the cia and to the country
thank you mr dicks mr lois
thank you mr chairman and my colleagues
i i very much appreciate the opportunity
to participate
in this session today as i did the first
of
two hearings in los angeles i want to
complement both my colleagues from los
angeles miss millander mcdonald as well
as maxine waters
for their effort here
mr hitz uh i i too appreciate your
making the effort to come and be with us
today and and want to express our
appreciation for your long service to
the country
uh
the challenge and the problem that we're
faced with here uh dealing with drug
trafficking the united states of course
is a major concern
uh to all of us in the congress i i want
to
uh sign on to the statement of my
colleague mr dixon that says it is not
just a congressional problem but but the
nation's problem for all of our people
are
are impacted by the scourge of drugs in
our society mr hitz i'd i have a number
of questions uh i'll summarize them a
number of questions relative to los
angeles activity and i'd ask you to to
respond
as best you can at this moment and and
you might add to it if you if you feel
it's appropriate
did the cia have knowledge of drug
trafficking by operatives assets
or employees of the cia in los angeles
between the periods of 1979 and 1996 and
did any contra organizations receive any
financial support from drug trafficking
in the united states during
that same period
well as you know mr lewis uh our report
indicates
what uh blandon and minises told us
uh that they made contributions to
contra support groups
of between three thousand and forty
thousand dollars each uh with respect to
the first part of your question
again uh we were concentrating primarily
on the san jose mercury allegations and
the contact the con
the
the contra connection
and with respect to that uh we did not
find any
uh
knowledge by cia of uh
a drug tie to the congress
mr if i could do it just one additional
question and adding to that uh and i may
supplement this if you if you would
mister
uh what were cia's legal and regulatory
responsibilities
from 1979 to 1996 regarding the
reporting of
potential crimes and the maintenance of
relationships with persons suspected of
involvement in drug trafficking
and and what did the cia do with
information concerning suspected drug
trafficking
well it was a a uh
a movable feast so to speak for for part
of the period in which you were speaking
from 76 to 82
it was an issue that was not uh
really addressed
but from 82 to 95
in an agreement as i understand it
hammered out between attorney general
smith
and the reagan administration
there was no requirement
to report on allegations of drug
trafficking
with respect to non-employees
of uh
the intelligence agencies
and during that period non-employees
did not include
agents of cia did not include cia assets
that has been changed
agreement in 1995 superseding the 82-95
period specifically lists narcotics
crimes as reportable
a practical matter
and you'll see once again
in volume 2 there are ample instances
where we
passed word of
allegations of drug trafficking to law
enforcement during that period but that
definitional situation is the one that
i've just described
uh thank you very much mr hitz mr
chairman uh i'll yield back the balance
of my time we've got a long
list of questioners here appreciate the
time thank you mr dixon thank you very
much mr chairman
and mr hitz i am
i join those who are sorry to see you
leave i understand you're off to
princeton university
but with proper notice uh can you remain
available for
consultation or testimony if we give you
enough notice of course and i won't be
going anywhere before the 30th of april
oh good
in your testimony today and in the
frogman case which i note you
devote a lot of time to
you you you say that the
cia became involved
mistakenly as i recall your report
indicates that a
an attorney from the cia traveled to
northern california and had a
conversation with the prosecutor
i believe your testimony today reflects
that there is
you could find no written material by
the
attorney who in fact had that
engagement with the prosecutor
uh what we did find of course and i
believe you're familiar with this mr
dixon is the
write-up that was made by the office of
general counsel commenting on that
particular
uh exchange that intervention with the
assistant u.s attorney the individual
whom we think was involved in the actual
negotiations
in fact doesn't have a recollection of
it right and and the write-up was not
made by the person who was involved well
uh we don't know that
we don't know who it was made by is that
right
he he he has no recollection of it
now you come to the conclusion
that they interceded
because
of a mistake
and i believe the report indicates it's
a mistaken identity
of
someone that the cia did have a
relationship with
that's correct mr dixon one of the
signatories let me back just a bit up a
bit and and
for you and for others who may not have
dug into the uh the detail of this
particular part of the report we did not
the cia was did not get involved in the
frogman case until several years after
the arrest took place
and it came as a consequence of a cable
state department cable from costa rica
saying that
an attorney
a private attorney and
attorneys from the united states
attorney's office in san francisco were
about to come to costa rica to take the
deposition
of two signatories to a letter
which had been directed to i guess the
u.s attorney's office seeking to reclaim
the 36 thousand dollars that had been
confiscated on zavala's arrest
and uh
it the
years we can tell from the way that
matter was reviewed
what the documents show
in the office of general counsel
the letter came from
what appeared to be contra support
groups or on behalf of contra support
groups and one of the signatories
we mistake the agency mistakenly
identified as that of a
an asset
it was a hispanic name that uh was
remarkably close
to uh uh the name of a
an agent that had uh worked for us in
the event uh as it was as you suggested
a case of mistaken identity the other
signatory mr avilas was known to us and
though he was not
a cia agent
he was known to have hold a position in
a contra support group
so
not having uh uh
been able to
locate the
the act the lawyer who was actually
involved in this and therefore not being
able to speak to his mind his or her
mindset it appears what they were trying
to do was to protect the identity of the
contra support group's connection
and
in that way
see if they could keep it from being
revealed
i guess what i'm asking is that
did your investigation make an
independent evaluation that this was a
mistake or is this something that the
cia told you
uh
and in point of fact we were the ones
that discovered that the uh identity of
the agent was mistaken
just let me focus uh on one other
question
and that it in the frogman case
there's a gentleman named
gomez
ivan gomez who your report indicates
that in fact
i guess was a contract employee of the
cia
is that correct yes but i think if i
recall correctly and i'm asking my
associate here to find it i think there
was a mistaken identity with respect to
gomez as well wasn't there well i want
to get to that that's the point me
asking this question here
the fact is that he was
alleged to have been named
by cabasas to have been at a meeting
and uh at least according to the report
you went to great lengths to try to
verify this
that you showed cabasa 16 pictures
yes
and
he failed to identify
the
gentleman well sometime between the
showing of the pictures and in the event
that alleged to occurred
but
do you have any independent information
as to where mr gomez was at the time of
this meeting excuse me miss dixon let me
if you'll pardon me i'll just take a
quick uh read through the
section here
as you recall
mr dixon on in paragraph 233 of the
report on page 86 right we did uh
stipulate that the reason we believed it
wasn't the same ivan gomez was because
he was uh
in the united states and not in costa
rica
during the period when the meeting that
cabezas described
allegedly occurred
now
i mean i think we'll the committee will
pursue this but
on on 85 at 231
in 86
at uh 234
you say that perhaps these people got
this name ivan
gomez because it had been
published in the newspaper
yes
but
it was published in the newspaper
after the statement was made is by
recall
correct i see so i don't understand how
that supports
the fact that they could have picked
this up from the newspaper or are you
suggesting that there was some
underground conversation before it
reached yes uh i'm reminded by
my
associate here that in fact
we were told about this in 1997
when we interviewed cabezas and that of
course as you suggest is not clear from
this paragraph
and finally did you ask mr gomez ivan
gomez if he attended this meeting
yes we did and what was his response
no excuse me
thank you mr chairman
mr gibbons
thank you very much mr chairman mr hitt
let me ask a broad general question to
begin with did your office uncover any
information
which
would have indicated that there was any
authorized or
unauthorized u.s government activity
which would have facilitated narcotics
trafficking
in the united states or overseas
no we did not we did not encounter any
information that would suggest that uh
there was authorized and i the
unauthorized
uh course is the is that is the trigger
there uh
all we we what we're trying to say here
mr gibbons is that for the most part
we're going on the written record the
documentation we're able to find in our
own records that which we're able to
gather from the carry committee files
the walsh committee files
obviously if it was unauthorized in the
purest sense
there wouldn't be a record of it
what we used the documents for also of
course was to shape the way in which we
interrogated the
individuals involved we knew what the
record was so we could ask intelligent
questions that was our methodology
but and we found no evidence of
a scheme to
promote the contra effort by selling
drugs
did you buy cia employees thank you mr
hitz did your investigation cover any
evidence indicating the cia had a
relationship with the los angeles county
sheriff's department
would you pardon me a minute i want to
make sure i'm correct in answering your
question
do you mean mr gibbons in uh
in connection with the contras or just
generally well what i'm after there is
to find out whether the cia
played any pivotal role or any role in a
process whether it's judicial or
administrative
in the prosecution
of
former los angeles county sheriff's
officers or deputies on corruption
charges
no we did not
thank you mr chairman and i'll yield
back the balance of my time thank you
ms pelosi
thank you mr chairman
again i want to compliment you for
having this open hearing but i would
request that we have another opportunity
to question the inspector general on
this report in the
because
the room will not be available long
enough for all of us to ask even
a substantial part of our questions i
concur with that and we will be uh
i concur with the observation we will
not have a chance to ask all the
questions and mr hitch has agreed to
take some in writing and i i know there
will be a lot i have several i know
others will and i said in my opening
remarks that the committee will proceed
as the committee deems appropriate so
the options remain i appreciate that mr
chairman because i do think that uh if
the commit when the committee does it as
the committee does its own investigation
um
the informa the answers to these
questions i think would be very helpful
and indeed might even save time at that
point
mr hitz i'd like to know what the ground
rules were during this period of for
contact between the attorneys in the
office of the council general at the cia
and the offices of the u.s attorneys
when a prosecution could involve
matters related to cia operations
and further to that whether in the in
your own judgment uh the contact between
the cia and the us attorney's office in
this case was appropriate
we were trying to find uh what were the
uh precise
uh guidelines that governed contact uh
during this period and i don't think we
were successful were we
i don't think there were there any
guidelines
except good judgment
and uh
obviously the responsibility of the
cia to report crimes to the department
of justice are
are specific and detailed and have
existed for a long period of time as to
your second question you can see from
our report which is one of the reasons
why we went into it in such detail
that there appears to have been a
difference in interpretation
of the propriety of the contact between
uh the uh
individual attorney who who engaged in
it
and and stated stated in his write-up of
it that he felt he was
getting into an area that could cause
embarrassment to the
president's
covert action activity in the contra
matter and
and drugs
his superior several months later
writing up a status report on this whole
event felt that he was
a calamity howler
i certainly think it would have been uh
it would have been the better uh
more diligent
uh
performance of the task if they had
avoided the initial mistake if they had
known that the
uh
letter writer the the offense the person
who filled out the affidavit that
drew or potentially was going to draw
the u.s attorney to costa rica to
conduct the deposition was not in fact a
cia asset
but in point of fact the concern about
information coming out about a contra
support group
appears to have been
as near as one can tell from the written
record
an honest mistake
you're very generous mr inspector
general uh
i you you made the reference that of
course the cia would have to report any
uh
potential violations of the law to the
justice department i wasn't really
concerned about that direction i was
concerned about whether
the u.s attorney's office would
perhaps not proceed in a manner for for
the reason you just said not to
jeopardize activities of the cia
i'm concerned about the converse well i
think i don't uh i think we're
probably splitting it a little too fine
there i can
my experience with u.s attorney's
offices have has been uh
ms pelosi that if the uh u.s attorney
felt
that he or she had a case in this matter
no intervention from the cia would have
warned them off they would have gone for
it and appropriately so
but in this instance at least what the
written record suggests is that
they were trying to get some
accommodation the office of general
counsel was getting trying to get some
accommodation on the issue of
information coming out about the contra
support group we found no evidence that
that contra support group in this
context was involved in drug trafficking
i appreciate that as long as we're
drawing fine lines uh it was one to
interpret from your response uh to one
of the previous questions asked about
the contact between the cia and the
sheriff's office in los angeles county
you said
generally or in this case
and then you answered specifically to in
this case
one assume from that that generally
there is
well
uh again you'll my experience is not
wide in the area of on the law
enforcement side
how the office of general counsel
relates to
a sheriff's department even one as
important as the los angeles
county so i wanted to be specific on
on that particular issue but frankly uh
the guidelines in the early
uh 80s was probably not as explicit as
it currently is because there's a lot
more interaction on drug matters and
terrorist matters and other law
enforcement questions
uh mr chairman i know that
we don't have much more time so i'm not
going to ask any more questions but i
would like to make a couple of
observations
which would have been reflected in my
questions and that is that uh
i certainly hope uh that that this
report is true because i would hate to
have the conclusion be drawn uh that the
federal our government was involved in
uh drug trafficking to benefit the
contras at the expense of the american
people especially in the vulnerable
communities that were targeted uh but as
i listened to what you say mr heights
and i appreciate your establishing your
limitations you don't have the power of
subpoena
um guidelines weren't clear
certain things were not reportable at
the time for example whether an asset
that we were and get engaged with um was
involved in drug trafficking and that
leads me to conclude that we may have
unwittingly and i use that word
generously have been subsidizing uh
assets who are engaged in drug
trafficking and uh to our own
peril
i i'm glad that the law has changed that
now at least it's reportable but i for
the life of me cannot figure out why as
you say in your statement uh that we
that the um
cia did not know
if these assets that they were
whether these people were involved in
drug trafficking at least we should know
whether it's reportable or not we know
we're pretty cih and we know isn't it
doesn't the pen say knowledge is our
business or something like that well uh
we're pretty categorical though miss
pelosi on the issue of blandone and
meneses
and their uh lack of relationship with
cia ricky ross as well
and you'll just have to be patient with
us because in volume two we'll deal with
a greater volume of uh allegations and
uh
get away from those central figures but
i think you can take volume one as
pretty categorical on the point of uh
blandon menises ricky ross
uh weekly and lister
well i just think that perhaps in our
investigation we can talk to the people
you couldn't subpoena we can figure out
why it wasn't worth thirty five thousand
dollars or thirty six thousand dollars
to go to costa rica for a deposition and
we can find out if the cia mistakenly
identified
and somebody if they had not mistakenly
not identified somebody as well if they
can make a mistake in one direction they
might make one in another direction as
well that is not to say that within the
limitations
uh that you have the inspectors general
inspector general's office that you
haven't made a good effort to to
make a presentation to us but i'm afraid
it keeps open some questions that i hope
that it would close but nonetheless i
thank you for your testimony today thank
you mr chairman
thank you mr skaggs
thank you chairman
i think
it is appropriate to make the
observation that this exercise is
uh
one that that bumps up against the
inherent impossibility of proving the
negative
that we're trying to establish that
something didn't happen and and that is
always a ripe field for
persons for whatever reason who who wish
to see conspiracy or deception or
whatever it may be so you've got
a heavy
burden to overcome just in in that
respect
most of us
are familiar with
what inspectors general are all about
but certainly not everybody in the
country is and with the attention to
this matter i thought it would be useful
to invite you
to explain who you are officially who
you work for who you report to who
you're accountable to
uh you know are you an agent
of
the director of central intelligence
be happy to attempt that congressman
skaggs and i appreciated your earlier
remarks we've had a
long friendship and i hope it will
continue even as you leave congress and
i leave this job i was appointed to this
position in 1990 by president bush
it is i am the first statutory inspector
general of
cia
this committee played an enormous role
in creating the statute that gave rise
to the office i think it's fair to say
it flowed out of some of the limitations
that the administrative ig was deemed to
suffer from
uh out of that the iran contra affair
revealed
uh we are supposed to be chosen on a
non-partisan basis
we are specifically directed by you to
follow the trail wherever it leads
we have independent hiring authority
although we obviously conform to the
security rules of the cia
and i report to the director of central
intelligence i am an executive branch
employee but my reporting does not stop
there
this committee benefits from a
semi-annual report of our activities
that sets forth what inspections
investigations and audits we've
performed over the preceding six-month
period
and we come to this committee on uh
extraordinary occasions have done it
twice to report significant violations
of the rules
and
frankly without your
from the legislative branch
interest in the work that we do i am
sure we would not be able to
get it done
now we have uh
authority to compel testimony
not by subpoena from all current
employees of cia they are subject to
dismissal if they do not answer our
questions
and there are no files or other
materials that are off limits to our
search
the director of central intelligence
could stop an audit or investigation
on vital national security grounds if he
chose to do so but he would have to set
forth his reasons for doing so and
inform this committee and that has not
happened on my watch
so i appreciate your question so i could
set that forth
the director of central intelligence
cannot or at least in this instance did
not attempt to control your
investigation in any way he did not
the staff of the ig's office that
assisted in this investigation
can you give us an idea of the extent to
which those individuals are career ig
staff as opposed to persons that may go
back into the agency after serving a
tour with you
we are 90 percent
uh career cadre in terms of the makeup
of our
our
investigative committee and i suspect
the other 10 are going to elect to stick
with us as well the point being that uh
and one of the things that hasn't been
mentioned here
uh this was a 17-person effort it took
us 18 months
uh it is a prodigious amount of work
it's one that as you suggest is hard
simply because of the difficulty of
attempting to
prove or or at least deal with an
accusation and to determine whether or
not it's well-founded but uh i know ours
is a career cadre and uh
i think it's appropriate that it remains
so
then we should have no fear that any of
the people that worked on this were
pulling punches because they're
eventually next year or the year after
or whenever going to back go back into
the agency to work with the colleagues
that they might be critical of correct
and in most instances they will they've
in order to pull a punch they would have
to done it in full view of
some of their colleagues on this team
and it wouldn't have washed and we would
have
uh we would have seen it in terms of the
uh sources for the reviews no i have no
no no concern at all that punches were
pulled here
thank you mr
thank you mr scott mr bishop good
afternoon
[Music]
and thank you very much mr chairman let
me apologize for for my delinquents and
getting here i had a two hour mechanical
delay with my flight and
i didn't want to rush that
but i am
delighted to be here and i commend the
chairman for holding this hearing and i
welcome the witnesses i also want to
commend
mr hitz i've read the report
i have a statement that i will submit
for the record but i would like to make
several observations uh the first of
which
the scope and level of detail of your
report i very much appreciate in volume
one mr hitz
and i want to join my colleagues in uh
commending you as you retire from the
cia and i want to take this opportunity
to join them and thanking you for your
service to
the agency and to our country
i also would like to make the
observation that allegations of of cia
involvement in the introduction and
distribution of crack cocaine as as
alleged in the mercury articles are very
very serious and it really created a
firestorm
and in minority communities it
immediately generated comparisons to the
tuskegee syphilis study
which of course you know where where
african-americans were injected with the
syphilis
germs and and were left untreated for
purposes of
of study
and uh to
inject this kind of a communicable
disease into our community
is horrible and it's terrible it's a
terrible thing for the government to do
and in this day and age the introduction
of drugs or the allegations of the
introduction of drugs
crack cocaine into our community is
equally
as bad and reprehensible and we
certainly uh
feel it appropriate
that this committee and
the agency and all interested parties uh
really get to the bottom of it and i
commend you for the effort
i
really want to ask you some a couple of
questions uh with regard i note that the
the report of the investigation
indicates that you reviewed
quarter of a million documents
pages of documents between
september of 96 and december of 97 you
interviewed over 365
individuals um
and with all of the
interviewing and review of documents
and the securing of what we believe to
be relevant information
let me just ask you in
doing all of this did your office
receive the full and complete
cooperation and support
from the management
of the central intelligence agency
yes we did mr bishop and i think we did
uh
at least in part and no no small part
because of the concern you earlier
expressed in your remarks i think the
allegations were taken
extremely seriously by
top management of cia when the san jose
mercury pieces first appeared uh this
committee has clearly taken them
seriously and we putting as many uh
people on the
investigation as we have have been
equally concerned so my cooperation was
was full were
the current employees
cooperatively providing information and
did any
government agency official or state
agency or individual
attempt to influence
your investigation in any way no we had
good cooperation and no
nobody tried to push us around
what about this fellow the cia attorney
that could not recall the facts of the
case or the meeting in question that
doesn't sound to me like full
cooperation
well uh again mr dicks
it's regrettable in the sense that uh we
would like to have uh
gotten his
uh if he was the person who authored the
uh document and he's the person that
made the intervention with the u.s
attorneys their office it would be have
been helpful had he remembered but we
had a pretty good written record
and in point of fact uh that's what we
were stuck with
thank you for yielding
uh you're welcome um
would you just tell me what
were the cia's legal and regulatory
responsibilities from 79 to 96
regarding the reporting of potential
crimes and the maintenance of
relationships with persons that were
suspected
in the involvement of
drug trafficking in the los angeles
areas
i think uh just before you arrived i
spoke to a rather odd history there
in point of fact
the period of 82 to 95 was one in which
there was no official requirement to
report on allegations of drug
trafficking with respect to
non-employees of the agency and they
were defined to include
agents uh assets uh non-staff employees
that has since been changed since 95.
uh that having been said i mean that was
the
the agreement that was struck between
then attorney general smith and the
agency
there are numerous instances of
referral of allegations of criminal
activity to law enforcement during that
period that in fact turned out to
involve
assets
i was going to ask also if the cia
intervened otherwise played a role in
any of the investigative or judicial
processes involving the prosecution of
former los angeles
county sheriff's deputies on corruption
charges
no we did not
uh did you
uncover any evidence
concerning
agency attempts to recruit michael
rupert who was a former
la police officer who claims to have
knowledge of cia links to the
foundation
we found we found no evidence of such
efforts
uh has the cia ever had any relationship
with mr rupert
and if so what was the nature of that
only i think is detailed in the report
none
none
excuse me
and i assume that that you've already
covered uh this whether or not uh
the cia had any information concerning
uh the drug trafficking activities in
los angeles by individuals affiliated
with the contra movement
i assume that you've already covered it
we have and and to repeat it our
concentration in this california story
was cia
uh employee involvement with uh
any uh assets who were uh running drugs
uh and the contras
so we have as you know
uh been reported on
the statements of both meneses and
blandone that they made
[Music]
proceeds of their drug
operations uh available between three
thousand and forty thousand dollars
uh two contra support groups but there
was no cia involvement in that
okay yeah in the procedures that you
outland
you indicated that there were several
people that you
did not interview because they declined
to give information
is that that's correct excuse me yes and
do you believe that the outcome of the
investigation would have been different
had you
been able to have access to them into
that testimony we do not believe so we
would like to have taken their testimony
to be absolutely sure but we do not
believe so
all right i
appreciate the chairs indication that we
will continue this at the committee's uh
pleasure at a later time and with that i
will cease my questioning and thank you
very much mr hitz thank you mr bishop
miss bishop thank you i
wanted to
yield for a closing comment very briefly
to mr dix but before i did i wanted to
also point out one more time
that
we are greatly obliged to our colleague
a member of this committee a very senior
valued member of this committee and a
member of congress who is also senior in
valued as well
mr julian dixon for the extraordinary
amount of work he has done not to say
that all the other members have not
acquitted themselves very honorably and
done their homework as well but mr dixon
has been preeminent and i want to thank
him publicly for that and i would yield
very briefly to him to respond
mr chairman but i don't want to leave
the impression i don't think committee
that the work is over with
this not at all i was setting you up
actually for what's coming next
mr dicks
concur in those very fine remarks mr
chairman uh
congressman dixon has done an
outstanding job going back to the
question i asked you about the you know
your look ahead into into uh
the second report
you've indicated that your investigation
has found instances where cia did not
expeditiously and consistently cut off
relations with individuals supporting
the conscious who were alleged to have
engaged in drug trafficking did any of
these allegations involve trafficking in
the united states
yes
did any of these allegations involve
trafficking in california no
that that was covered by uh
volume one
not specifically
did
did did your investigation attempt to
resolve these allegations
well uh
frankly mr dicks we wanted to we wanted
to put a spotlight on the allegations
and the exchange of information uh we
haven't
i think as such taken any uh uh
position on them but you will see that
when we set them forth i think you'll be
in a position to make up your own mind
as to the gravity of the allegations and
come to your own conclusions thank you
mr chairman
thank you mr dicks we are beyond the
appointed hour and i know that we have
uh
added even longer to the length of your
already long day mr hits but we're very
thankful as you can tell there's a great
deal of interest there will indeed be
several follow-up questions
coming along on this subject as we
proceed with our investigation
in the select committee i want some of
those areas of questions we will be
asking i want to give you a little bit
of a heads up
uh i don't know whether you've done any
costing work yet but we're
interested in in how much this is
costing and
realizing that you've got so many
hundreds of thousands of pages of
documents we're looking a little bit at
it from our own staff equity point of
view too
and the uh the second thing i would
point out for members uh
i have promised that we are going
forward we all know that we are and uh
we are not going to necessarily uh
suggest that we're all of this is going
to be done uh publicly
uh i would tell members however that
there has been a lot of testimony and
concern about these seven members who
who declined to participate uh mr hitz's
efforts uh we have been in contact i
understand with all seven of them
and we have varying degrees of response
so i i offer that only as a token of the
commitment to uh proceed forward on this
and we'd like to add mr strickland to
that list
well
we will certainly take that under
advisement
uh if you're talking about the mr
strickland of this report
well we also would like to ask you said
to put a few of the articles in the
record absolutely without objection i
would last like to ask one final
question mr hitz if i could i've read
this report very closely
it is a narrow report it focuses as you
say a spotlight on a specific set of
allegations
the report i think is very clear in what
it says it is signed by you yes did you
sign this report without reservation and
do you stand behind what this report
says i did and i do
thank you very much i appreciate
everybody's attention and participation
in this this meeting is concluded
[Music]
[Music]
later this afternoon the house meets at
12 30 p.m eastern time for morning hour
speeches on any topics and then at 2 pm
that's at noon eastern 9 a.m pacific on
our companion network c-span 2.
[Music]
a view of the u.s capitol on this friday
the middle of the month august the 14th
this is eastpan's washington journal
coming up on our program gary webb who's
the author of a new book called dark
alliance he spent nearly the
last 10 years as a reporter
investigating stories for the san jose
mercury news during the next hour we
want to hear from you our numbers are on
the screen 202 624 1111 is our liberal
line
202-624-1115 for conservatives and
202-737-6734 for moderates during the
course of the morning we want to find
out what you find of interest in your
hometown newspaper gary webb will be
with us for the first hour and later
we'll move on to detroit the c-span
school bus one of two is in michigan and
we'll be talking with jeff hayden of the
detroit news and addie rimmer of the
detroit free press
but we'll begin with a look at the
morning headlines and as you might
imagine the story that is going to
dominate the next couple of days is
dominating the morning headlines
beginning with the philadelphia inquirer
jody edna wrote the piece how the
clinton testimony may change the nation
she says while the investigation of the
president's alleged peccadilloes is
widely perceived as being far less
serious than richard nixon's watergate
scandal it does have the potential to
transform the nature of the presidency
and the relationship among the president
the courts and congress this is what the
headline looks like this morning on the
front page of usa today a new survey out
says the public is ready for the truth
and this morning a story that we'll be
spending a fair amount of time talking
about is on the front page of the new
york times it's also on the front page
of the baltimore sun the new york times
wire service and it's this headline the
president weighs admitting he had sexual
contacts the story which was written by
james bennett and richard burke neil
lewis and others for the new york times
says quote mr clinton would say he based
his previous denial in a deposition in
the paula corbin jones lawsuit on a
definition of sex approved by the judge
in the case his advisors believe this
definition does not cover certain
activities including oral sex
gary webb on that note good morning to
you thanks that's a fine note
what do you make of this
i think this is the most bizarre story
i've ever seen i mean this is uh going
into definitions of sex now and uh to
have the president be questioned about
what he thinks sex is
uh it's just it's just astonishing to me
i mean you read the definition of the
new york times and we're getting down to
things like touching genitalia and
touching anuses and things like that and
i'm sorry i'm glad i hadn't had
breakfast yet before i read that story
let me continue an acknowledgement of
some kind of sexual encounter poses
considerable risk particularly if it
were linked to a legal argument that
rests on the narrow definition of sex
the new york times goes on to say this
morning but mr clinton's advisors have
said it poses a greater risk to tell
anything less than the truth to a grand
jury about sex with ms lewinsky it is
not clear how precisely mr clinton has
described his relationship with ms
lewinsky to his lawyers my question to
you is how does the new york times get
this information who's talking it's the
same way that the washington post gets
the information if you look at
washington post store it's a very
similar story and the people are talking
obviously are the people that are close
to clinton the question you have to ask
yourself when you see a story like this
is is this real or is this a trial
balloon that that's being floated now to
see how the public's going to react to
it
and this has the ear marks to me of a
trial balloon i think people are trying
to see how the public's going to
react to the president saying well i may
have had oral sex but i don't consider
that to be sexual contact
before this program began i was going to
ask you why this story is not on the
front page of the washington post the
early edition does not have it on the
front page but the later editions has
this story by peter baker uh that says
counseling a narrow admission of sex
based on that could you assume that the
washington post received this after the
first deadline of its early publication
no i what i would suspect is that people
saw the way the new york times played it
um and and remade the front page to put
their surround the front page as well
we'll be talking with gary webb for the
next hour and also discussing his latest
book called dark alliances but first
garden grove california on our liberal
line good morning to you good morning
what are you reading today uh l.a times
and do you have a copy of it in front of
you is it i know it's early
um no it's in the other room
but i'm calling in regarding the uh
upcoming testimony in the clinton
lewinsky matter
and
i don't know i mean i've seen the tenor
of the news sort of change in the last
couple of days
and suddenly people are talking about us
getting real serious and etc etc
and the president hasn't changed his
stance
and i think you know it's turning into a
big showdown
and
clinton is heading right into it i think
the pressure is really starting to come
down on star now
i mean if clinton really didn't have a
relationship with this woman
i mean it's going to be just a
tremendous in your face political
victory
for clinton i mean it's going to put
this entire political charade um
on
on the center showcase
and even if he did
it should be a pretty simple thing for
him to
defuse
and after all the
everything that we saw starting with
quail and then rush limbaugh
and all the tremendous political attacks
and everything it just cracks me up here
we are in 1998 and the the biggest
feather in the republican cap is this
little sex scandal that they have going
with clinton thanks caller we'll get
another view from little rock arkansas
on our conservative line reading the
arkansas democrat gazette good morning
good morning i love c-span sir um this
morning in our paper we have an
editorial by meredith oakley where
she
samples some of the opinions from
different uh states concerning hillary
clinton's statement
that uh clinton's troubles the
president's troubles is because of an
anti-arkansas bias i am so steamed today
that she would say that about our state
i mean it just appears to me that you
know that the that they're unraveling up
there about how to treat this problem
with his not telling the truth to the
american people it has nothing to do
with an anti-arkansas bias
it has to do i think with the failure to
just come out and level with the
american people i'd like to ask your
guest what he thinks about it and let me
also point out jill lawrence has a piece
this morning uh the headline in usa
today hillary clinton public fighter
private mystery well i think the most
significant story in the last couple of
days has been the admission by the star
people that their final report may have
absolutely nothing to do with whitewater
to me that was the idea behind this
whole special prosecutor
argument was that we were going to get
into whitewater and find out what went
down down there
and now it's going to be limited to
monica lewinsky which tells me that
there was nothing behind whitewater if
he's got nothing to bring forward to
congress to bring forward to
the courts
and
i think it's sort of a sad comment that
we spent all this money and all this
time and all we've got is like the
caller said a tawdry little sex scandal
i i just don't think the american
public's all that interested in in what
the president does
with his private life i'm sorry i mean i
know it's on the front page of all the
newspapers but i don't sense from
talking to people they give a damn one
way or another usa today says the public
is ready for the truth here's how the
story begins americans want president
clinton to tell the truth when he
testifies money to a grand jury even if
it
means admitting to that he had a sexual
relationship with monica lewinsky the
poll suggests trouble for clinton if he
commits perjury monday if that can be
proven three-fifths of those surveyed by
usa today said it would be serious
enough for them to consider him moving
removing from office we got a call from
fort lauderdale good morning yes good
morning and thank you for taking my call
i just wanted to uh talk about the
swiss banking settlement and i think
that's great that they finally owed up
to their mistakes but i like to see our
politicians put pressure on the swiss
banks to
quit being the bankers for the
international uh
terrorists and drug dealers supposedly
this guy that
blew up the embassies and uh kenya and
tanzania is some billionaire from saudi
arabia i wonder where that guy keeps his
money probably in the cayman islands or
swiss or
a whole host of these other banks and i
wish there was some pressure in the
cleanup the banking system all these
terrorists and drug dealers wouldn't
have any place to put their money
there's a story on the front page below
the fold in the washington edition of
the la times that profiles the saudi
dissident who you refer to hasami bin
laden he is
his father
had 52 children from a number of
different wives he is worth
several hundred million dollars
according to robin wright who wrote the
piece for the la times
and he profiles she profiles how he
turned against the americans essentially
as a result of operation desert storm in
1990 well you know there was a there was
a very interesting book written a couple
years ago by a journalist named jonathan
whitney it was called endless enemies
and his theory was that
the united states foreign policy simply
creates uh enemies wherever we go and
and i think this is another example
when when we intervene in the in the
affairs of other countries when we shoot
at people and people get shot at with
american bullets and american weapons we
create enemies
and
if this if this is true that this man
turned against the united states
government resulted desert storm we've
created another enemy there we might not
have had before
two things related to this an editorial
cartoon in the washington times has a
character of president clinton hello
saddam what you doing this sunday in the
headline in front of him president to
testify on monday
what do you make of that what's your
reaction
uh well it's the old wag the dog story
you know you get in trouble you start a
war
and that's the way i read that cartoon
and the new york times editorial this
morning saddam hussein makes his move
the editors of the paper say two
international inspectors who know the
most about iraq's efforts to create new
weapons of mass destruction have raised
an alarm that president clinton and
other world leaders must not ignore the
editorial concludes that he the
president must not let these and other
matters prevent him from dealing firmly
with a crisis in iraq that grows more
dangerous by the day
yeah and and there was there was another
story we're going to talk about a little
later along with similar lines about the
problems in russia that are sort of
being diverted and swept under the rug
while we concentrate on whether or not
oral sex is sex uh i think it's an
excellent point michael mcfaul who is a
fellow at the hoover institution and
also a professor at stanford has a piece
this morning it's called perspective on
russia it's on the op-ed page of the la
times the headline is forget about
monaco it's moscow and the stakes are
global let me just read you two or three
sentences from the piece he writes quote
by this time russia very well may be
down the throes of a major market
meltdown which in turn might trigger
political upheaval on a scale similar to
indonesia different from indonesia
however russia still has ten thousand
nuclear weapons
the gravity of russia's crisis makes
this september summit one of the most
important foreign policy missions of the
clinton presidency and an event of much
greater importance than his grand jury
testimony by the way there's a story in
the front page of most newspapers about
the financial situation and boris
yeltsin who as of now is saying that he
is not going to devalue the ruble
michael mcphail concludes this morning
in the la times by saying no one has
greater interest in promoting the
consolidation of democracy and
capitalism in russia than bill clinton
if russia eventually succeeds in
becoming a member of the international
community of democratic states president
clinton will secure his place in history
as an important foreign policy president
yeah and that's the point i made earlier
there are a lot more important things
going on around the world
that we're reading nothing about because
the news media is consumed with this
monaco story
and this is michael wein's piece just a
quick uh headline stock and bond prices
drop in russia as investors bolt stock
and bond prices plunged today jarring
russia's hopes that the government could
avert a depletion of its finances and a
meltdown of russia's banking system back
to your phone calls santa fe new mexico
on our moderate line good morning good
morning uh yes i'm calling regarding
monica lewinsky and i just find it very
interesting that
this dress that she
supposedly turned in to
for dna
he has kept for
two and a half years
why would anybody
in their normal right mind keep a dress
that
for that period of time without even
washing it
i mean um
i i just look at all these little
circumstances
i find it very interesting in your book
dark alliance i'm curious in your
thoughts possibly i know it's pretty
basic but uh i i think it brings up some
fundamental questions
gary webb well i think it's interesting
now that now that the dress is
resurfaced and now that it's in the
hands of the fbi we're seeing stories in
the paper about how clinton is weighing
whether or not to admit a
a relationship with lewinsky
i don't think you can conclude that
they're unrelated i think there i think
there might be something to that and you
know i think most most americans like
that usa today paul said
if it happened tell us about it let's
get on with it roxanne roberts of the
washington post on the style section
this morning yuck the scandal that's
taken the romance out of sex
that's yeah
read the new york times story this
morning uh if you want to talk about
taking the romance out of sex read the
definition of sexual relations in the
new york times this morning we will let
them read it we're not going to talk
about it that's that's exactly my point
but let me read you what roxanne roberts
said the consensus is in this is a bad
sex scandal please god let this all be
over soon morality aside this sex
scandal and it is a sex scandal despite
all the rhetoric about obstruction of
justice and suborning perjury is nothing
but an unseemly embarrassment to the
presidency to women into sex itself
what kind of man allegedly calculates
his trust to confirm to a legal
definition of technical fidelity and
what kind of woman keeps a stained dress
as a souvenir then gives it to her
mother the public is disgusted the media
embarrassed and sophisticated adults at
a loss for polite discourse says one
woman who was active on washington's
dinner party circuit you know the thing
is funny is that a number of years ago
we in the american press used to make
fun of the english press for for
concentrating on these sex scandals and
um yeah because the british tabloids
have been full of this kind of stuff for
years
and i'm not sure that you know the fact
that rupert murdoch has come in and
bought a bought a lot of companies and
we now have a lot of english journalists
over here uh practicing in our
profession that this is an outgrowth of
that i mean english politics has been
based on sex scandals for many many
years
and we used to be above that in american
journalism now now that's what we are
sturgess michigan good morning on our
conservative line good morning
uh i would like to know why
last night on msnbc
there was a they read a letter from a
democratic senator i think he was from
georgia
that was asking the president to resign
before he tears the country up and i
have heard
nothing on any of the other stations and
may i say one thing these people that
write in and say that i mean call in and
say they don't know why she kept the
dress
she knew bill clinton and she knew what
he was going to try to do to her and
that was the only evidence she had
and i think this man is a
habitual liar
and he should be tried for treason thank
you thanks for that call from our
conservative line we'll get one more
view on our liberal line from chicago
reading the sun times good morning yes
good morning how are you mr webb i'm all
right um the headline is for us
sometimes is young suspects go home uh
that's about the two young boys involved
in
in the killing of the
11 year old girl
that's an important story
but i want to
this year on this one mr webb i wanted
to
to talk about um
how
a lot of what's in the media correlates
to what i think that happened to you and
your story that ran into mercury news
when i was growing up in the 60s and 70s
they were telling us well don't trust
government you know and to be
suspect of what the government tells you
and i think that now we've gone beyond
there to where now we can't trust all
the time what the media is telling us uh
it seems that
there's reason to
um to question that the media is being
dupes of
some
some some um
some power who wants to
manipulate
what the public thinks uh your story
they read in the mercury news
uh they totally went out to try to
discredit you
um
and i i didn't believe it when they did
it i
i know what you were saying in your
story and they accused you
of um
saying that the cia was
selling drugs which i don't believe
that's what your story was saying but
this is the way that they went about
discrediting you so that your story
wouldn't have life and it was an
important story thanks caller i'm going
to stop you there because we're going to
spend a couple of minutes uh next
talking about this book and his
background in san jose but you brought
up the earlier point about the headline
of the sun times on the case involving a
seven and eight year old boy and i just
want to give him an opportunity to
respond to that and then we'll talk
about his book that that is really a
tragedy i mean i have never seen a case
and i don't i don't think anybody else
has of two children i mean these are
these are infants basically
killing a girl
i think that's that's
a sign of the times you know i think
it's a very sad sign of the times when
you've got children killing other
children now and the previous caller
from michigan said that she knew exactly
why monica lewinsky kept the dress did
you want to respond um boy i don't know
why i
don't know why at all
our guest is gary webb he is the author
of this book called dark alliance the
cia the contras and the crack cocaine
explosion what led to this
i had been uh working covering the drug
war for the mercury news for a number of
years and
this was an outgrowth of a story that i
had done
about the state of california's asset
forfeiture program which is a program
where if the police believed you were a
drug dealer they could come in and take
your house and your car and your money
without even charging with a crime
and i had been doing stories on that and
uh a young lady in oakland had read one
of them and called me up and put me onto
a story about her boyfriend who was an
accused cocaine trafficker who had had
that happen to him he had his property
taken away daniel blanton
his name was rafael cornejo it turned
out that the key witness against him for
the federal government was his fellow
danilo blandon who had been a
leader of the contras in california in
the early 1980s and had been a huge
cocaine trafficker in his own right
and when i got into investigating her
boyfriend's case i came across
blandon and i came across his
involvement with the contras and his
involvement
ultimately with a major crack wholesaler
in los angeles and freeway ricky ross
and so i did a series
that that said that the crack market in
south central los angeles had been
created in the early 1980s with the help
of this contra drug ring
and showed how
once crack got hold in south central and
once the gangs got a hold of it it was
spread from south central to other
cities in the united states
and it ended up being a huge controversy
you begin by talking about the samosa
family and the allegiance that the
family in nicaragua the ruling family
had with the u.s government for more
than 40 years
and then you write that the americans
wanted him to disappear what happened
well he became an embarrassment to the
american government
his his army the national guard was
committing human rights abuses and
remember this was during the carter era
and human rights were big on our agenda
at that time
and so they came to him and said this
has gotten out of hand you need to step
aside we need somebody else to take over
and at that point they were still trying
to salvage the american government's
relationship with with nicaragua
obviously at that point it was too late
and the san anisis came in and threw
everybody out
and what happened was a lot of the men
close to samosa a lot of the men from
his army came to the united states
because we had been allies with them for
a long time and among this flood of
political exiles were these two major
cocaine traffickers who set up a drug
ring along the west coast and dealt tons
of cocaine in the united states for many
many years while the us government was
aware of it so connect the events that
began with this and then led to the
series in the san jose mercury news and
you write about howard kurtz of the
washington post right who you had a
conversation with claiming that the
mercury news was trying to suppress the
story or parts of the story this was
this was afterwards after the series
came out um the my story and myself were
attacked by the washington post the new
york times and the la times
for drawing conclusions that were
unwarranted essentially
and
after the
counter tax and the media started the
mercury news sent me back down to
central america my partner george hodel
and i
wrote another series of stories
that essentially took the knowledge of
this drug ring even further in the
united states government the mercury did
not print those stories and howard kurtz
called me up and i mentioned to him that
there were additional stories that we
had written that the mercury news was
suppressing
and he did a column about it in the
washington post why did they suppress it
at that point you know they had been
beaten up for about nine months by the
mainstream media and at that point the
decision was made either we go forward
with this story and we get beaten up
some more or we back off of the story
and and it goes away and what they
decided to do was back off of it and go
and you know similar to what happened
with the cnn tailwind story
pursuing it would have created a huge
controversy backing away from it created
a minor controversy at the time and now
the story's gone it's off the radar
screen so
who's the dark alliance with
the dark alliance referred to the
allegiance between the these contra drug
traffickers and the the gangs of los
angeles who were their main customers
and who are the countries the contras
were a you know former samosa supporters
former samosa military officers
who were
had been kicked out of nicaragua in 1979
and were trying to retake the country
with the aid of the cia and the one
thing that's important and a lot of
people don't recall because this is
ancient history you know what happened
15 years ago
was that the contras were a creation of
the cia and so when our story came out
saying that the contras were dealing
drugs in los angeles and elsewhere
and that these drug traffickers were
meeting with cia agents
a lot of people took that to say the cia
created the crack epidemic which is
clearly not the case and i spent a great
deal of time in the book talking about
how crack was on its way
at the time this happened
but
the the impact of it was that when you
had all this cheap cocaine going into
south central los angeles right at the
time people were figuring out how to
take this powder cocaine and turn it
into crack
you had sort of a
collision of historical events in a very
odd place
and and what happened from that was you
had a spread of crack nationwide because
the gang spread nationwide the gangs
after the la market got saturated took
this to other cities and set up crack
markets and other cities didn't have
them what led to your departure at the
san jose mercury news well a number of
things
the fact that the mercury news backed
off the story i mean i had worked a year
on this i had been an investigative
reporter for them for nine years done a
lot of major investigations for them and
you know i had a very good reputation at
that newspaper
the fact that they would back off the
series because they were being
criticized by their newspapers
i found very disheartening and then i
was taken off the story when i believe
the story had only been half told
so one of the reasons i quit was to
write this book
and finish telling the story because
this i think this is an important part
of our history
that that had been denied us for a long
time the book is called dark alliance by
gary webb it is published by seven
stories press in new york there is an
article in the latest edition of esquire
the september edition with the headline
the pariah have you ever been called
that before i recall a lot of things
before but never a pariah although in in
this case i think it's meant ironically
charles bowden wrote the piece two years
ago gary webb wrote a series of articles
that said some bad things about the cia
and drug traffickers the cia denied the
charges and every major newspaper in the
country took the agency's word for it
true
true and that was that was sort of that
was the strange part about it is that we
laid out a series based on a year of
investigation that had buku government
documents most of the series is based on
government documents dea reports fbi
reports the testimony of government
witnesses
and the other papers came back with
unnamed sources
mostly unnamed government sources saying
well this couldn't be we don't believe
it
these drug traffickers weren't as
significant as webb made out
and that was it and
and at that point the series is viewed
as discredited because unnamed
government sources told the washington
post that they didn't believe it so
you know i think i think this is an
interesting lesson uh for the press and
i think what you've seen as a result is
that the sort of cnn tailwind
fallout
now that
investigating covert cia operations
investigating the cia in general is now
off limits to the press unless you have
what ted turner call proof beyond a
reasonable doubt which when you're
talking about covert operations you're
never going to find as a journalist so
from where you sit who was telling the
truth cnn
the report the producers who were fired
or let go or the cia i think that there
it's still an open question i don't
think the the issue was solved at all
but the debate is over with i mean the
tragedy that cnn taylor story is i think
they had a good story
i think there was a lot of evidence to
suggest that this occurred
the problem is when you retract it it
buries it forever nobody's going to look
at it i mean the issue is like
radioactive now and nobody will touch it
again and we'll never know the truth i
mean if it's not true there's ways to
find that out and i think the cnn story
was significant enough to warrant
congressional hearings i mean if you've
got incidents of nerve gas being used
against american defectors that's
something congress should be looking at
what are you doing these days i'm
working for the california legislature
investigating government agencies i work
for the task force on government
oversight could you see yourself working
for a newspaper again
i liked writing the book real well i
would like to keep writing books back to
your calls with gary webb of dark
alliance meredith new hampshire good
morning thanks for waiting oh my gosh
i've waited a long time we're glad to
hear from you we want to talk a little
bit about this book so that our viewers
having some background on our guest well
i realized it was interesting too uh i
want to make a comment and then i want
to ask this man a question
my comment is one person is called in
and then you put an article where they
say
what kind of a woman would say this
dress
but the point is what kind of a
president would get himself involved
with a woman who would save this dress
what kind of president
would put his whole future in the hands
of this dumb adolescent
knitwood from california i don't think i
think this i'm i'm and i'm being very
serious this president needs a
psychiatrist he is i don't understand a
man who's been wanting to be president
since he's in high school supposedly
and then he lets this
girl come in even more important what
kind of staff does he have
that lets him do this it reminds me a
little bit not to the same degree but of
hitler and his bunker and he didn't have
one person who could tell him the truth
that the war was lost doesn't he have
anybody around him that can look him in
the eye say
go get counseling mr president you're in
trouble here
thanks now the question i want to ask is
you made a flat statement more or less
flat
that this report is going to be only
about sex you have you don't know any
more about that than i do
that the re that the star report is
going to only be about this you haven't
got a clue about that when you make that
statement no it was in the newspapers a
couple of days ago that the report was
not going to deal with water with white
water it was going to deal primarily
with the lewinsky case and obstruction
of justice and that sort of thing the
president will testify
monday for about five to seven hours in
the white house
when do you think we'll hear the first
reports of what he said a couple of
hours that's how things that's how fast
things leak anymore
carabelle florida is next good morning
on our conservative line good morning
good morning to you first of all let me
tell you how much we enjoy c-span well
we appreciate you watching
it it's a breath of fresh air with some
of the things that we see
and i'm kind of changing pace this
morning
with an article by kathleen parker
entitled families to switch babies act
nobly
she starts out by saying
every now and then someone comes along
to restore faith in humanity a round of
hosanna's pleas for the families of two
babies switched at birth
she goes on to say
how the families met without attorneys
and judges to complicate things and how
well they handled things
and how amicable things have gone
in hopes that they are not
pressured
by
attorneys
to to change this so it's kind of a
pleasant thing to be able to read
people getting along together
my opinion of attorneys continually
diminishes
and it seems to me that they cost us
a lot of money
caller if you have access to a website
the washington post in its metro section
and i don't have it in front of me
unfortunately has a piece looking at
the five-hour window that they think the
babies might have been inadvertently
switched and both the families in the
hospital are now saying that it was an
accident there's also a
half-page ad
in the washington post by the president
of the university of virginia medical
center uh admitting that uh there may
there needs to be corrections in the way
uh these uh babies are uh watched in the
nursery as they arrive and and
i have it right here in front of me so
it's in the metro section of the
washington post uh the headline is
baby's mother zeroes in on the time that
the switch could have occurred
and i think that's fine the thing that i
found interesting about kathleen
parker's story about it was not
necessarily the the rather bizarre
details that might have taken place
but the idea that people can act
independently and and responsibly
without always having a commissioned
attorney around
which seemingly which seems to me
to cause all of us a great deal of
inflation in in our
expenses that that we all
have to participate in i i think we need
a few less attorneys and a little bit
more common sense thank you caller from
carabell florida are you an attorney uh
no i'm happy to say my brother is
however we'll get a call from decatur
texas on our liberal line reading the
times in record good morning
good morning
i'm calling about a
uh
article it's called pentagon says army
should have charged for services
this is by
jim abrams associated press
and it's the article it says preparing
for the republican takeover
of congress and uh
95 it says here but it was 94 newt
gingrich
this passed top aides and lawmakers to
the army
for sessions of military strategy
now the pentagon says the army
inappropriately provided the services
without charges the politicians
before the several days before the
republicans swept into power
soon to be house speaker gingrich a
self-styled military brat
whose stepfather was a career army
officer
sent his
chief of staff dan meyer
and other aides to the army
training and doctrine command
tradoc
at fort monroe virginia for a briefing
on organizational design
and over the next year other visits
followed
in which gingrich aids and gop lawmakers
attended seminars on information
management strategic thinking the art of
battle decision making
gingrich made three personal visits to
fort monroe in 93 95
97 for briefings on subjects of
at lessons learned in somalia
warfighting concepts the army's future
this is an associated press story caller
yes and it's in your paper this morning
it is gary why would something like that
appear now any idea
somebody got a tip i mean that's that's
the the most likely explanation is
somebody got a tip about it i'm still
not sure i understand the point of it
it's that the army should have charged
gingrich for these lessons is that the
carl you have the story in front of you
is that the headline uh pentagon says
army should have charged
for service now this is for
based on an audit
is this based on an audit a pentagon
audit it is a whole or article it's jim
abrams it says has been tasked by
gingrich it says peter hofstra
who attended two sessions has evidently
been on a strategy doctrine function in
the house
and as i understood it to expand it to
the senate as well
hoextra's office said the congressman
went at the speaker's request to try to
learn how
organizations like the army deals with
problem solving
ron foreman spokesman for jim colby now
jim comey
claims not to be
really he said in kobe's case the inve
invitation was
to attend
came from the army and not from gingrich
so it's also looking at the
organizational structure of the army
when the republicans to do
something for the house before he to run
the house like a military operation ever
speaker okay thank thanks caller we'll
get some reaction from our guest
appreciate you passing that along and uh
we like that when you share with us
stories that we have not seen
here in washington so thank you
yeah i i it's hard to tell from the
description what that story is about but
it sounded like they were receiving
training for the military on how to
organize um i don't know the republican
caucus or the the house or something
i think it's an interesting story the
militarization of congress by the way
the speaker of the house is in ireland
the date line is inch island ireland
this is an ap story that said house
speaker newt gingrich who dug into his
rebellious irish roots yesterday an
experience that he called far more
emotional than i would have imagined mr
gingrich and a congressional delegation
are on an eight-day tour of ireland and
northern ireland and have held meetings
with many of the parties in the new
power sharing assembly in the british
rural province by the way the president
will be in ireland and northern ireland
september 3rd 4th and 5th on his way
back from russia he leaves for russia on
monday august 31st based in wyoming is
next from our moderate line good morning
good morning
i would like to make a comment and
congratulate gary on his book
thanks
i was born in the late 40s
my own dad was a career army person
my stepdad was navy
and you know i just feel like the cia
answers to no one
and it's about some time somebody took
them to task regardless
and they have had strange bedfellows for
years
yeah and that's sort of the tragedy of
all this is that and one of the points
that the esquire piece makes is um
how there is a long record of cia
involvement with with suspected drug
traffickers and drug trafficking
organizations
and this is a history that's mostly
unknown to the american public
what i tried to do and i think we could
have done it better in in the original
series was show that this is this
situation involving the contras in los
angeles dealing dope to the gangs was
not an isolated incident it wasn't an
aberration there have been reports of
cia involvement with drug traffickers
all the way back to the secret warren
laos there's a whole book written by
professor alfred mccoy
called the politics of heroin in
southeast asia which the cia actually
went to court and tried to prevent from
being printed back in the 70s
about the cia's involvement with laotian
drug traffickers and and here was you
know
this story i think showed
what happens when you get in bed with
those kind of people
uh
the results are sometimes unintended and
and i think in this case this was a case
you know this stuff happened so often
this guy has a word for it's called
blowback it's what happens when you do
something overseas that comes back and
blows up in the face of the american
public
and in the case of the contra war you
had a situation where we got in bed with
drug traffickers there was a story which
i frankly never thought i would see on
the front page of the new york times i
know it was july 17th
in which the times reported that the cia
now admits that they had
relationships with about two dozen drug
traffickers during the contra war
and continued the relationships even
after being told that there was there
was evidence these men were trafficking
drugs by the way if you can't get
through on our phone lines and want to
fax us a question during the course of
the morning our number two zero two
three nine three three three four seven
that's three nine three three three four
seven and we'll take your faxes
throughout the morning you can also
email us our address on the internet is
www.cspan.org and our email address is
journal
cspan.org an email for you from a viewer
in san diego who says in the course of
your research what if anything did you
learn about the following number one
oliver north's contemptuous knowledge of
countries smuggling drugs into the u.s
number two drugs being flown from the
cia from central america to u.s military
bases under cia protection do you think
anyone will ever be held accountable for
these crimes thanks for your courageous
work
well the
the first question on what oliver north
knew about it one of the
one of the sources i used in preparing
the book were his diaries that were
produced during the iran contra
investigation and it's very clear that
washington posted a story on this when
he ran for uh congress senate a couple
years ago
on all the drug related entries that
were in north's diaries
he was clearly getting information
from his people in central america that
the contras and a number of the
organizations we were supporting down
there were engaged in drug trafficking
the post story raised a very good
question as to what did north do with
this information
north says he turned it over to the dea
the dea said we never got anything
one of the chapters in my book i talk
about a an incident involving an
investigation by a u.s customs informant
in costa rica
he was looking into allegations that the
dea office in costa rica was protecting
contra drug labs and
along the border
the chapter is essentially about how
north was able to get the evidence that
this
informant dug up down in costa rica
and how this evidence was destroyed by
one of north's aids which
it made the iran contra report but a
very tiny little segment in the back and
i expanded on this in the book for a
whole chapter the second question about
drugs being flown from central america
to us military bases
this was evidence that we found in a
court file in nicaragua there was a drug
case down there in 1992 in which a
government witness said
that
this drug ring was using a military base
in el salvador
and loading cocaine on salvador and
military aircraft and these aircraft
were flying into an air base near fort
worth texas and unloading
i could not corroborate that because all
the flight records from that period had
been destroyed by the air force but
there you know there was testimony of to
that effect in a court case in nicaragua
and more details outlined in gary webb's
new book called dark alliance as we
continue with your phone calls you'll be
with us for another 15 to 20 minutes
flatwood west virginia on our
conservative line good morning good
morning
my husband was in the navy and he had to
do a tour on on land unfortunately in
vietnam he was an ordinance head
ordinance man he said this never
happened with cnm's uh iron item that
came out he says if anything
people should have gone directly to the
ordinance man and asked them the
question in vietnam and on the ships out
at sea he says there was nothing with
any kind of chemicals that went out
there except for gas that was it you
know kind of
uh you know stinking stuff but nothing
nothing in nerve agent not nothing and
any kind of chemicals that would kill
anybody
and i have a a question to ask you i'd
like to know what's in the post because
i get most of my information from your
station thank god
the post from back east about the
president and whatever
and another station was talking about it
and they were saying how you know i
guess it was a little lethal but i i
would like to get that information
well the washington post and the new
york times both have a story that uh we
spent a little bit a little bit of time
talking about earlier
essentially
what is the definition of sex is is that
a thera i think that's a yeah that's a
very fair statement this is the headline
president ways admitting he had sexual
contacts the narrow definition would
explain in earlier denial and we'll go
inside in just a moment to uh give you
some more insight into what they said
did you want to respond to the caller i
think
the thing that surprised me about this
story that i had not heard before is
that when clinton was responding to
these questions
about did you have sexual contact
he was doing so after being given a
definition of what sexual contact was
and this was a definition that had been
worked out by paul jones's lawyers
and you know like you said we don't want
to get into it on family television but
um
when you when you realize
this this is an important story because
you know everybody thinks that clinton
was just asked the question and
responded to it off the cuff when
actually he was responding to a question
that was
very tightly drawn by the attorneys in
the paul jones case
so
you can read that again like anything
that's written by a lawyer you can read
it a couple of ways but
i think it's an important
important thing to know and in fact the
front page of the washington times just
below the fold takes a look at that
deposition which took place on january
17th and over the course of the next
couple of days you will likely hear a
lot of discussion on what exactly the
president said in the paula corbin jones
case a case which we should also point
out has since been thrown out uh paula
jones by the way is also in the news on
another issue which we'll talk about in
a moment but let me show our viewers
he said
267 times uh i don't remember i don't
know i'm not sure i have no idea i don't
believe so i have no recollection i
can't say i can't remember to the best
of my knowledge i honestly don't
remember that's all i know i just don't
know i really don't know
i can't deny that i just i have no
memory of that at all
well i don't know if that that tops ed
meesa's record before the iran contra
committee so i think meese
had it 300 times or so so
and paula jones in the news
we'll show the pictures to our viewers
uh the before and after this according
to uh names and faces in the washington
post it's also in the new york times usa
today
and probably in your hometown paper as
well she had a
a nose job
plastic surgery
all right um
that's fine
there's a uh an even bigger picture this
morning in
the the uh washington times it's called
paula's new look and the picture is from
don't you i like her new look i'm gonna
go on to another call key west florida
good morning on our liberal line good
morning
hello
oh hello good morning um
i'd like to draw a parallel between
the author's book dark alliance and a
previous book written in 1972 called the
politics of heroin in southeast asia
let's serve prize winner alfred w mccoy
and uh he
details u.s government involvement in
the drug trade pro all the way from
before the boxer rebellion through
luciano is released from prison to
reorganize the corsican syndicate
and it's uh the cia involvement in in
vietnam
the um
the other the other point i had is uh is
regarding this lewinsky thing i think it
mainly draws media attention away from
issues that really matter such as
pollution overpopulation
the greenhouse effect on down
and uh
sort of sort of a sort of a smoke screen
really
well you've got to understand the media
to understand why this is such a great
story it's titillating uh it sells
newspapers and it's a very easy story to
do you don't have to
do a lot of work
these are handout stories you go to the
president's people they give you their
spin you go to ken starr's people they
give you their spin you go back and
write it up and at the end of the day
you've really you know you've
illuminated no one but you've titillated
a lot of people and so that's why sex
scandals are such great stories for
reporters because they're easy to do
stories like the greenhouse effects
stories about
i think one of the biggest stories
going today is the south africa truth
commission they've just had the hearings
uh regarding this incredible program
they had there called project coast
which i've read very little about the
american press it's mostly been on the
foreign wire services
that is a remarkable story of modern day
evil it's at its worst
but you haven't read anything about it
because you know we've got three
thousand reporters assigned to the
monica lewinsky story there's also the
case in burma with the six or eight
american students who were charged with
passing out leaflets in a pro-democracy
uh activity some of the students for
from american university here in
washington the trial is taking place
today are you following that yeah that's
another story you've heard very little
about um you know
and i think i you know it's just a
matter of news priorities and
i
unfortunately foreign events don't
interest us that much anymore i mean you
used to see i started in the business in
78 and i've seen a really
significant decline in foreign news
and this
sort of fixation with the sex lives of
politicians martha moore has a piece
this morning in usa today looking at the
media's role in all of this
she begins this way like a good son
dennis ryerson who is the editor of the
des moines register called his mother
last week she gave him an earful she
said your father is so sick of monica
and bill he says he's not going to read
one more word about it ryerson says i
had to tell her mom we just decided to
put the story on top of page one
tomorrow the story continues by saying
with the lewinsky investigation and all
of its legal twists it's still being
followed intensely by millions of
americans
creating television figures such as
cnbc's chris matthews and gerald rivera
cnn's bob franken and msnbc's keith
olbermann
i know dennis ryerson he used to work at
the cleveland plain dealer with me and
he's a very
thoughtful journalist i'm sure that
if he had his druthers he would not be
putting this on the top of page one
denver good morning on our moderate line
uh good morning i was calling about the
comparison between the
uh this cnn tailwind story and gary webb
story which i've been following i saw
the
the interview he did with gil noble in
new york a couple weeks back
uh in fact i'm looking at it right now
the transcript of it um i had uh um i
the thing that concerned me that
disturbed me the most
about the floyd abrams report in the
tailwind
scandal was the the degree to which
um
the it seemed like a lot of the errors
to me
that were committed by cnn were
committed by editorial people and yet
the floyd abrams report
virtually ignores those that side of the
story
and my question for mr webb was
before the mercury news backed off of
your story
did you find
the
that your
editors
helped you make the story
be a better story or did you find that
they were
hardly responsible for
some of the misinterpretations that
later came out about it that's a good
question one of my uh one of my
favorite lines was when i would submit a
story to my editors and i was in the
bureau about 150 miles from uh from the
main office so you would send it up over
your computer modem i would hit the
transmit button and say it's all
downhill from here um i i think you know
i'm biased obviously i'm a reporter and
there's a constant conflict between
reporters and editors but in the case of
the tailwind story i thought it was
significant that the producers of that
of that show asked for an hour
and to me if you're going to accuse the
united states government of gassing our
own citizens an hour doesn't seem like
too much to ask
to air this story they got 18 minutes
and
the criticisms in the abrams report were
consistently over things that were left
out
now in my case it was very similar i
mean i had turned in a series it was
four parts originally it was cut to
three
and a lot of things that we were
criticized for not
for not reporting were things that
actually had been reported initially and
were and were cut out to save space
um and and i think you know that's a
problem if you're going to do serious
investigative journalism
and you're going to do stories
implicating the government and
essentially crimes of state
you shouldn't be worried about well
should we have 18 minutes or should we
have an hour you should give these
reporters the time they need to do the
story right and i think a lot of these
problems we're seeing would not uh would
not appear michael kramer who is the
executive editor of this publication
brill's content will be our guest sunday
and on page 115 is the q a looking at
the cnn nerve gas retraction and we'll
be talking to him for about an hour to
an hour and 15 minutes that's sunday on
c-span's washington journal which gets
underway at eight o'clock east coast
time ridgewood new jersey is next on our
conservative line good morning hi good
morning mr webb i was wondering if you
have ever gotten a chance to look into
the
rumors and reports that mena arkansas
was a major drug trans shipment center
during the 80s
i think that's been reported by michael
morrison of the wall street journal
editorial page and i think emmett
terrell's also touched on this issue we
also have an email from a viewer who
asked the same question from encino
california what have you uncovered about
mina arkansas and the bush clinton
involvement yeah the mena story takes up
about a chapter in my book and the
reason i included it was because what
was going on amino arkansas during the
1980s was very similar to what was going
on in los angeles with this contra drug
ring for those people who don't know
there was a major drug trafficker named
barry seal who was based his air fleet
at mina which is a tiny little airport
up in the mountains of
arkansas and um
drugs were going drugs were coming into
the country seal was a one of the
biggest traffickers in the southeast of
the united states during those years and
there were lots of rumors that he was
flying guns south and
mika morrison from the wall street
journal really has been the only
reporter to treat this as a serious
issue and to actually do some
investigation
there had been a story that was done a
couple of years ago by roger morris and
sally denton
initially for the washington post called
the crimes of mina which took a look at
seal's personal records and and drew a
very chilling story about how law
enforcement investigations into this
drug ring and this money laundering
operation were quashed
the washington post refused to run the
story
eventually and it appeared in penthouse
magazine but this is another story that
the national media sort of blown off as
some wacko conspiracy theory
two weeks before my series appeared
the cia inspector general issued a
report which is still classified if i'm
not mistaken but the results were leaked
to the press and it said the cia
admitted that it had a presence at this
air base in mina it admitted that it had
done repairs of aircraft at this air
base in mina
and
this is a story that sort of came and
went i mean
jim leach's banking committee was
supposed to have done an investigation
it may have actually done one and i
don't think those those
those reports have ever been released or
his findings have ever been released if
you've just joined us we're talking with
gary webb who is the author of dark
alliance his father was a marine officer
so you grew up throughout most of the
country i understand began his
journalistic career in kentucky at the
kentucky post and also the cleveland
plain dealer spent nine years in san
jose working for the mercury news and
has a new book out called dark alliance
and is also working on another
publication by the way i want to follow
up on an earlier call
who had
commented about an editorial that was
written by a member of congress and i
believe it was a former member of
congress and democrat ben jones from
georgia who served from 1989 to 1993 the
former hollywood actor and he wrote in
yesterday's roll call mr president do
the right thing and step down so a
follow-up to the previous caller who
phoned in uh this was used last night on
either msnbc or on cnbc's geraldo
program new york city is next on our
liberal line good morning yes good
morning uh yes i've been calling uh
about several things but i'm interested
in finding out if you can first of all
the taliban uh was also part of the cia
cooperation i believe
and i think the meanest thing i'm just
these are peripheral things that i'm
just going to mention the only interest
people have in that is so that they can
assign that claim to clinton now they're
not so much interested in the use of the
airport for drug trafficking as they are
to see if they can find another thing to
tie onto his tail
my own purpose in calling is to really
ask why there has been such a blackout
of any information about mr skafe
there have been no investigative reports
the newspapers are not interested in
discussing it there's been
it seems to me
my own conspiracy theory is that there
really is a right-wing conspiracy to try
to make sure that the democrat the
democratic party is really uh defend
destroyed and the result of that will be
that they can get what they're really
after which is the new deal it just
seems to me that the same old uh enemies
have gotten together with a lot of money
a lot of reporters are certainly in the
loop many of them admit that they have
been on the
receiving end of help the newspapers are
now owned by
right-wing
owners and the purpose is to get at
public education to get at uh the
medical uh services to the poor to get
at erasing the environmental laws best
way to do it is to make people so sick
and tired of voting that noah
we had lost that call i'm sorry uh to
the caller and i apologize that was my
mistake i inadvertently did hit the
button but you asked about richard
mellenscape and so i'll follow up and
ask you to respond to the caller's
comment and again i apologize i i think
that's a good question and i believe
that's who hillary clinton was referring
to when she talked about this vast
right-wing conspiracy to tar the
president
scafe uh is a is a very interesting
figure in american journalism and you
know when i was looking for stories
about him i saw a piece i think it was a
columbia journalism review many years
ago
there was a very definitive look at who
richard mellenscape was
and i i think it's good to look at the
people who own the media
and i think it's it i think scafe has
sort of gone unexamined but it was
there was a david hale story for a while
down in arkansas where they talked about
the american spectator and possibly
money being paid
for people to become witnesses in the
paul jones case
and scarcity but
i think there's something there worth
worth looking at and that's who owns the
media and and how much of it
sort of reflects your ideological bent
do you agree with the caller's argument
i i agree that it's it's it's an issue
worth exploring definitely and the press
has done a really rotten job of an email
from john androcco i am appalled that
you would have gary webb on your program
there he sits mouthing anti-government
garbage about how tailwind was stopped
and how the question is still open as to
what happened he has no business on a
credible program with his bias against
the government he must be a product of
his times and a typical california nut
there have been too many investigations
into the drug charges to have his idea
promoted as truth
the moderator sat there referring to me
and questioned him as though he believed
this nonsense about tailwind
unbelievable for c-span
well i think as a reporter you're you've
got to have some sort of an
anti-government look at it to cover them
fairly if you're a pro-government
who needs you
my my
view is that when you're a reporter
you're supposed to be reporting things
the government doesn't want you to
report not the things the government
wants you to report they have millions
of people on the payroll who are happy
to tell you all the great things that
our government is doing for us
and that's fine but it's not the press's
job to be cheerleaders for the
government gary webb with us for another
10 minutes or so and then later we'll
take you to detroit where the c-span
school buses parked and talked to a
couple of reporters from the two
newspapers in that town long island new
york good morning on our moderate line
good morning amayan you sure are i just
heard this gentleman say
uh uh that a reporter could be uh uh uh
uh is uh you're either anti or pro
government i don't think you should be
either i think that what you should do
is examine that statement sir in
fairness i don't think that's what he
said but stay on the line we'll get you
uh equal time do you want to rephrase
exactly what you said what i meant is
you shouldn't be you shouldn't have a
bias
but you should not be afraid of being
anti-government being labeled
anti-government you're you're label you
know when you're an investigative
reporter you're out to uncover
wrongdoing essentially and if you go
into the job believing that everything
the government tells you is true you're
not going to be very good at what you do
and unfortunately a lot of reporters
these days are not reporters as much as
they are stenographers
and they go to the government they they
write down what the government tells
them and then they go back and put it in
the paper without really examining it so
to be accused of being anti-government i
don't think is all that much of a of an
epithet frankly am i on still you sure
are oh
i thought i'd give
i'm 73 years old and i've i've done my
stint in german prison camps and things
like that i've seen uh what what the
press and what certain people tried to
say never happened the holocaust i
walked right past it myself and mr
eisenhower did
i can see what the press can do i can
see how how the press can take a
statement and blow it up i can see how
they're turning around now and trying to
define sex the man had sex everything
that they say about what he did is true
it's just a bunch of lawyers trying to
play games with the english language i
don't understand at all what's going on
here how an intelligent person like you
or people of your age group can stay
with a man like this who's double
crossed labor he got our vote we voted
for him he turns around he signs nafta
which is going to put us down the tubes
we're losing jobs like crazy in this
country and in 25 years my grandchildren
if they can't go to college and become
some kind of a scientist or something
they won't be able to get a job we don't
have anything left in this country
thanks everything
has been to put this country down thanks
uh for the caller from long island new
york well you know one of the comments
he made was how the press is is trying
to split hairs on what what sex is uh
the press isn't doing anything but
reporting the the spin of the clinton
office in this case
um it's not the press that's doing it i
mean the press is covering the story
obviously but it isn't coming up with
these i agree with these hair brained
explanations of what sex is and what it
is let me go back to the new york times
story again this is a front page
which outlines in great detail
what is sex according to what the
lawyers have defined but there's also a
quote from ann lewis who is the white
house communications director on january
25th she appeared on the fox news
program
quote sex is sex maybe only in
washington is this considered something
we ought to spend a lot of time on
but no a sexual relationship means what
it says and what and that includes sex
the story goes on to say in mr clinton's
practice sessions his advisors and his
lawyers are questioning him and
designing answers that allow him to
acknowledge a relationship with ms
lewinsky without going into any graphic
detail
that's that's a big difference between
saying i never had sexual relations with
a woman uh now saying well we had a
limited sexual relationship and what did
nixon call that the limited hangout uh
route during the watergate
murfreesboro tennessee good morning good
morning how are you fine thank you how
are you i'm fine thank you um mr webb
i'm i'm curious if you're familiar with
a book uh called spite house s-p-i-t-e
by monica jensen stevenson
a friend of mine she wrote the book
about a friend of mine and bobby garwood
one of the only i think
servicemen who was actually
convicted of defecting
during the vietnam war and one of the
things then one of the chapters they
discussed in there was related to
the use or let's say the service going
after defectors
not necessarily the use of nerve gas but
certainly um
in a vicious way to take care of them
without due process and of course all of
us know that sometimes in the ucmj
uh that due process is often set aside i
mean it's a it's a way that the service
deals with things so
i'm just curious if you're familiar with
that book at all
yeah i have not read it but i'm familiar
with the book you're talking about um
and i believe garwood was on
the national radio program the other day
talking about what had happened to him
and it and i did not i did not hear the
show but it was described to me that the
other guest on the show was a military
officer who had been sent to kill him
um so you know what you're saying is not
outside the realm of possibility i mean
defectors were treated very badly and
and you know if he was an actual
defector i'm sure a lot of people
wouldn't be too sorry about that
another email mr webb earlier pointed
out that the media loves covering an
easy sexy story ad nauseam sad but true
our media now mirrors the ugly fleet
street type of yellow journalism from
jolly old england i find it disturbing
that a special prosecutor has been
questioning american citizens concerning
the sex life of our president
welcome to the age of the sex police it
has only just begun many others on
capitol hill have skeletons in their
closets such fodder for the american
mind we got a call from flagler beach
florida good morning on our liberal line
good morning mr webb you were saying
that you were you'd like to write some
books i have a suggestion you might want
to consider
i was paying attention for a while about
how many military aircrafts were going
down
if you wish to check the last three
years alone you'll be astounded and
elaborated at the amount of airplanes
throughout the world united states
military airplanes helicopters that have
crashed there are i got up to 65
just with my now a way of finding out
i think you're going to find billions
and billions of dollars and hundreds of
pilots and it's not being uh nobody's
checking on this you can also check in
that book if you were interested in
writing the book about how the industry
private industry
is stealing away our talented pilots i
have a friend who has two sons who are
jet were jet pilots
and they won aircraft carrier navy
pilots and they went to iraq and they
became
what they call them experimental
training
and actually they're astronauts right
now they're twin brothers and they're
both astronauts
but they were offered a fortune by
private industry and it cost a million
dollars each to train these guys but the
thing i think should be looked into is
why and how many of these aircraft
military aircraft are crashing just to
suggest you might want to consider that
bye-bye
i i think actually a reporter a couple
years ago won a pulitzer prize for a
story and i think it was military
helicopters if i'm not mistaken how
often they were crashing so i mean
you've got a point florida city florida
on our moderate line good morning good
good morning yeah i was i was a smuggler
out of miami from 1967 1983. what did
you smuggle i smuggled pot out of
colombia and in jamaica and why did you
do it well because it made a lot of
money how much for the money for the
money of course and the action and the
fun but anyway well hold on hold on how
did you do it obviously you flew but
first we used to use uh sailboats uh in
the early 60s and then we switched over
to uh you know uh fur freighters and
stuff until about the early 70s so you
didn't fly huh you didn't fly you used a
boat well and then we switched over to
airplanes and
and we used airplanes i used airplanes
up until about 83 when i was captured
how much money did you make huh how much
money did you make oh i don't know we
made a few millions of it and what are
you doing now
ben cramer was the last people i was
involved in that was one of the biggest
seizures in the history of this country
but anyway let's not talk let's talk
about the cia well one last question
what are you doing today oh i'm i'm
retired
retired from drug smuggling i did 10
years of probation and time
and uh and it was it was all right but
anyway i was very interested in anyhow
but anyhow because i have connections
with nicaragua because my father was
part of the clinton crew that captured
and executed the santino brothers
that they named the san andreas after
but anyhow
what i want to talk about is the cia
connection with drugs see i used to my
competitor was one with the cubans
and the cuban connections with the cia
are are legendary right and uh i was
wondering if he had any can any story
about well whether right now they're
about ready to turn over homestead air
force base to this group of people i
used to be my competitors with latin
builders association cuban organization
but anyhow i was kind of curious
about
in 1988 i lost a d18 on a one-way trip
to costa rica to haul you know canvas
and bees and stuff for them
and i never got the plane back you know
it just kind of went down there and i
believe they probably loaded with dope
and took it to california the next time
i saw it on was miami vice you know it
was out there you flying on an air on on
the tv program
but anyhow i was kind of curious if you
ever found out and knew anything about
any connection between the cubans and
the cia
with drugs because i i i thought that
was a pretty big story in the in the
head godfather jorge mosca knows just
died we'll get a response thank you
caller from florida city there's a lot
of questions i'll try to remember them
all yeah
there was a very heavy cuban presence in
the contra organizations down in costa
rica
that were they were involved in drug
smuggling um there was actually a
company uh called frigirificos de
puntorenas that was based in costa rica
was a shrimp importing company that was
owned by cuban american drug smugglers
and they had a state department contract
to haul supplies to the contras
so you're right i mean there was a very
very heavy cuban presence down there and
um i'm trying to remember some of the
other questions he had about um
well
the caller's not with us now but i was
intrigued by his own background and
wondering how many of those type of drug
smugglers
there are or were in the time that you
did your research there were there were
dozens of them there were dozens of them
and and you know one of the things he
mentioned about losing an aircraft i
interviewed a former cia pilot in
florida named ronald lippert who leased
one of his aircraft to this contra
organization and it wound up in mexico
being seized by the mexican police with
like 2500 pounds of pot on it so i mean
it's a situation that happened time and
time again during the contra war briefly
can you explain how it worked for a
pilot like this or a uh
the operator of a boat to get the drugs
from south or central america and bring
it back what they were doing in this in
this one particular drug ring in the
book was they were flying it up through
um
from colombia to
costa rica or to el salvador it would be
offloaded from from smaller planes on to
either military aircraft in in san
salvador
um or it would be flown up um and and in
that case they would be taken for this
base outside of fort worth at least
that's what the the evidence suggested
in other cases they would simply they
would load him on like he said colombian
freighters and in the case of the this
drug ring it was the grand columbiana
line and they would ply the waters off
the coast of california and oregon and
seattle and go into these ports and
literally dump cocaine over overboard
and frogmen would swim at a shore and
that's that gave the
one of the famous cases in california
that i write about in the book it's
called a frogman case and it was the
biggest drug seizure in california
history dark alliance the cia the
contras and the crack cocaine explosion
by the way there's also a forward by a
california congresswoman maxine waters
why did she write
the the start of the book well because
this impacted most heavily in her
district in south central los angeles
and she has been the leading
congressional advocate for an official
investigation i mean essentially right
now we've had investigations done by the
suspects the cia the justice department
and she's pushing for a
real investigation by an outside agency
or outside bonnie a few more minutes
with our guest louisville is next on our
conservative line good morning yes good
morning gentlemen uh i have two points
i'd like to make with regards to the
clinton problems that are in the media
right now i've seen president since
harry truman's day all right that makes
me a little older than you two fellows
but i can tell you this that this
gentleman we have as president now is
the most grossly immature man we've ever
had in the office and i think that is
unquestionably so
second we hear a lot of people calling
in and complaining about the
partisanship of mr starr
i'd like to remind everybody that
there's a gentleman working with mr star
by the name of samuel dash and if i
remember my history correctly
samuel dash was a democratic counsel to
sam irvin on the watergate committee and
he was instrumental in bringing richard
nixon down now this is such a partisan
investigation why are most of well not
most of them but why are some of the
prosecutors democrat and why is mr dash
in fact working with mr starr thanks
caller gary webb i don't know the answer
to that other than the you know
prosecutors or prosecutors i don't think
most of them by and large are
particularly partisan although
there's a lot of evidence of
partisanship by ken starr
there are two
nixon references that i want to bring to
our viewers attention first jack germain
and gerald's what cover in the baltimore
sun syndicated columnists have a piece
the nixon tapes cutting up history at a
price
under court order and you may have read
about this recently the national
archives had begun cutting out 820 of
the 3 700 hours of tapes to excise would
have been characterized as private
conversations of richard nixon with
various individuals during the period
after the 1972 watergate break-in and
cover-up john carlin who's the archivist
at the of the us says he entered he
entertains the hope that the nixon
estate at some point may agree to make
public some of the conversations on
political matters now classified as
personal or private but waiting for that
to happen is about as likely as waiting
for nixon to admit guilt at the time or
later in the watergate cover-up
this is uh you know this is another
instance where our history is being
controlled by other people um i think
whatever on those tapes belongs to the
american public i mean nixon's privacy
rights died when he did paul jagot in
the wall street journal has a column
called potomac watch and he says
woodward and bernstein lose their
fastball the big reason i got into
journalism was carl bernstein and bob
woodward as a college reporter i cheered
their zealous pursuit of watergate in
all the president's men but it seems the
years have given the pair second
thoughts about holding politicians
accountable under the law or so i
conclude from their views about
presidential scandal expressed sunday on
nbc's meet the press mr bernstein the
legendary rebel now sides with the white
house establishment mr woodward was more
balanced but he still embraced mr
bernstein's new proportionality standard
at least for president clinton paul
jacob goes on to say that mr bernstein
now says that the clinton scandal is
merely about a private consensual sexual
matter that bears no resemblance to
watergate you know i was at a convention
of investigative reporters a couple
years back and seymour hirsch was one of
the keynote speakers you know the
semi-legendary investigative reporter
for the new york times
and this was not too long after clinton
had been elected and hirsch got up and
said clinton's big problem is he cannot
tell the truth and this was long before
whitewater it was long before
lewinsky and i thought i thought back to
that today
when we talk about how clinton's
waffling on this and waffling of that
some reporters have known this for years
denver is next on our liberal line good
morning
hello hello you're on the air yes
jonathan denver and i just wanted to say
that i really believe that uh since the
kennedy assassination
the whole
governmental climate i.e um
united states
with the press and everything has been
manipulated has changed to the point
where
the situation we see today which
actually has no merit or bearing on the
lives of a common person such as myself
as a single parent
or my friends
is way out of control and i applaud mr
webb
not being a california nut or whatever
that he was
but uh i think it's important for people
such as himself
to bring out the points of how things
are actually working underneath the
seeming underbelly of our society and
that's all i'm going to say and um i i
love washington journal and um keep up
the good work and mr webb
i can't wait to buy your book well
thanks
annapolis is next good morning
hi how you doing there fine thanks
uh
i was just listening to your
program this morning and i wanted to say
to uh mr webb
[Applause]
a couple of people come to mind uh when
you talk about the cia and drugs
henry b gonzalez when he was in the
house of representatives
noriega george bush when he was director
of cia
bill bennett is a drug czar
and uh
i also read a lot of noam chomsky and so
i don't really think you're that far off
the mark sir
there's compelling evidence to support
your theory
well
if you look at the book i've got 70
pages of source notes
like i said like the series most of the
book is based on government's own
documents and the testimony of
government witnesses now you can argue
that well this wasn't official cia
policy which a lot of people have argued
i will point out that at the house
intelligence committee hearings in march
the inspector general of the cia
frederick hits disclosed that there had
been an agreement signed in 1982 between
the director of the cia william casey
and the former attorney general william
french smith
which allowed the cia not to have to
report incidents of drug trafficking by
its agents and its assets
and i think
you know that sort of eliminates the
question as to who knew what when when
you've got the chief law enforcement
officer of this country and it's top
intelligence official agreeing
sort of making a gentleman's agreement
that the cia doesn't have to tell the
justice department when it's agents in
assets or drug trafficking you've got a
serious problem there
and i think the most shocking thing to
me and to the members of the
congressional committee was the fact
that this agreement stayed in effect
until 1995. so you had 13 years here
with the cia did not have to report drug
trafficking by its people how long has
the book been out it's been out
approximately a month and a half and the
reaction the reaction's been very
favorable i mean even the washington
post which is a very strident critic of
the series gave it a gave it a fairly
positive review last sunday and where
will this all lead what's going to
happen as a result of this book well i'm
not sure anything will happen unless
unless congress has the will to to lift
these rocks up and look under them and
the last serious investigation we've had
of the cia happened during the the pike
committee in the church committee in the
70s and the agency took decades to
recover from those i'm not sure congress
has the will to look at what they've
been doing since then and finally based
on some of the calls and what you have
alluded to in the last hour or so with
the cia have you had any reaction from
the government from the cia or anyone
involved in what you have been
investigating as a result of this book
well this like i said the cia has
finally gotten around to admitting what
a lot of people knew back in the 80s a
lot of the contras were drug traffickers
and they didn't do anything about it and
i think that's a giant step forward when
we talk about you know being accountable
and having accountability to the public
but you personally
oh well i lost my job at the newspaper
i'm not sure the cia had anything to do
with that but
i mean the repercussions on myself and
my partner nicaragua was getting serious
death threats he finally had to leave
the country the book is called dark
alliance our guest for the last hour and
15 minutes has been gary webb thank you
very much for joining us thanks a lot
we're going to take a short break and a
reminder that uh sunday on c-span's
washington journal michael kramer who is
the editorial director of content
magazine will be our guest on tuesday
pat buchanan will be here a week from
sunday nachi loeb of the manchester
union leader c-span's washington journal
gets underway each weekday at 7am and on
weekends at 8am eastern time we'll be
right back
[Applause]
next we join the c-span school bus from
detroit's belle isle park we'll talk
with two local journalists about today's
news
at about 9 10 eastern time we'll talk
with addie rimmer deputy managing editor
of the detroit free press
next the deputy editorial page editor of
the detroit news jeff patton